Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Willkommen beim neuen Jahr.
Willkommen.
Wir haben uns natürlich schon gleich 0 uhr 1 ein gutes neues Jahr gewünscht, aber an dieser Stelle auch nochmal für alle gutes neues Jahr.
Ein gutes neues Jahr, das Ereignisreich beginnt.
Und komplex auch.
Um das noch abzubilden, wir sprachen noch an Silvester, nun wir waren erst gemeinsam in Europa, in Wiesbaden und waren dann in unserer geliebten Bar in Frankfurt darüber, dass es diesen Einbruch gab in Gelsenkirchen in der Bank und du hast dann gesagt, dass es das Thema, das in den nächsten Wochen dominierend sein wird. Was du natürlich nicht ahnen konntest, ist, dass etwa 20 andere Dinge danach geschehen, die auch einen enormen Ereignischarakter haben.
Aber was haben sie gemeinsam?
Sodass Gelsenkirchen immer noch wichtig ist, aber natürlich schon überdeckt wird oder zumindest Konkurrenz bekommt durch andere Ereignisse.
Ja, aber die Themen haben ja alle etwas gemeinsam. In Gelsenkirchen wird das Ding ausgeraubt und man weiß nicht, ob es 30 oder 300 Millionen waren, wie auch immer. Und man stellt fest, in den AGBs steht etwas, aber die Anwälte sagen, wenn da 10.000 Euro drinsteht, ist das eine überraschende Klausel. Da muss die Bank erst mal nachweisen, dass das gerechtfertigt ist. Plus, welche Verantwortung hat die Bank, um das zu verhindern, dass das passiert? Also relativ viele Sachen, wo man sich denkt, ich dachte, es sind in den Texten geregelt, aber anscheinend doch nicht.
Ja, mir war ja auch gar nicht klar, ich habe kein Schließfach, dass das Schließfach dann nur bis 10.000 Euro versichert ist. Denn da frage ich mich, bei 10.000 Euro kann man es ja fast in den Nachttisch legen, dann brauche ich ja kein Schließfach.
Genau, für 10.000 Euro brauche ich ja gar kein Schließfach.
Es sei denn, ich habe jetzt ein paar Dokumente oder alte Liebesbriefe, die ich gerne sicher aufbewahren will, dann kann man das dort tun. Aber zu sagen, ich lege da fünf Rolex-Uren rein, wäre dann eher dumm.
Genau. Und dann stellt sich ja die Frage, was ist ein Schließfach der Sparkasse? Ist das nicht stellvertretend für den Staat? Wenn auch nicht faktisch, dann zumindest in der Gefühlslage. Ja, das ist also noch zu klären. Jetzt haben wir neue Themenlage gehabt, die natürlich auch drastisch ist. Stromausfall in Berlin. Und interessant ist schon, dass sich so langsam kommunalpolitische Sachen hochspielen. Ja. Also sie werden irgendwie so relevanter. Manduro ist so ein Ausnahmefall. Aber schon ist man wieder in Minnesota, wo Eis jetzt Leute auf offener Straße erschießt. Und von daher wird dieses Jahr durchaus komplex. Ja. Aber nicht wegen Manduro. Das ist das Einzige, was nicht komplex ist.
Und alle kennen jetzt den Bürgermeister von Berlin. Das war auch vorher nicht der Fall. Und man fragt sich, warum wir ja Tennis spielen. Dass es jetzt die Frage, die an ihn gestellt wird, ist natürlich der Wunsch da, jetzt so eine Verantwortung herzustellen oder auch eine nicht vorhandene Macht dann in dem Moment. Das sind bestimmt für die Boulevardpresse tolle Geschichten. Aber ich glaube, dass es am Ende sehr weit weggeht von dem, was jetzt eigentlich interessant ist, nämlich, dass tatsächlich so eine Vulnerabilität, um diesen Begriff mal zu nennen, vorhanden ist, dass also so schnell so viel passieren kann von einer offenbar kleinen terroristischen Gruppe.
Sofern es überhaupt Terrorismus war, niemand hat von dieser Vulkan-Gruppe je gehört.
Ich hatte das auch nie gehört, ja.
Sie kommt von diesem isländischen Vulkan, weil damals die Flugzeuge nicht flogen und irgendwas hat mit dieser Zeit zu tun, keine Ahnung. Also ja, Linksextremismus, okay. Ich habe mich jetzt die letzten Wochen durch Bezüge, über die ich später nochmal rede, sehr viel mit Linksextremismus im Sinne von Widerstand gegen LS beschäftigt. Also man liest von Tucholski, Osijetski und so weiter und dann heißt plötzlich, das sind Linksterroristen und offenbar denkt gar keiner mehr nach, was das eigentlich bedeuten sollte überhaupt. Und taucht dieser Text auf, alle Fragen, die ich so, was hat es damit auf sich? Das Tennisspiel von Kai Wegner finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, denn es erinnert ja an Anne Spiegel, die also in den Urlaub fährt und deswegen ihren Job verliert als Familienbundesministerin.
Ja, also während der Ahrtal Katastrophe fährt sie in den Urlaub, sagt dann, dass sie an Konferenzen teilgenommen hat, stellt sich nachher heraus, ne, sie hat auch an vielen dieser Online-Konferenzen nicht teilgenommen. Hier geht es jetzt um einen Mittag oder Nachmittag, den Kai Wegner nicht mit Krisenmanagement, sondern mit Tennis-Spiel, ja, verschwendet hat. Es ist schon erstaunlich, dass man in der Situation auf die Idee kommt, Tennis zu spielen. Also ich würde auch sagen, da muss irgendwas ein bisschen schieflaufen.
Wir lesen heute ein Buch.
In der Regierungskompetenz.
Die Meritokratische Falle. In der steht drin, dass in Amerika gewählte Politiker pro Tag vier Stunden mit ihren Spendern verbringen, im direkten Austausch. Ja. Die wichtige Frage ist also, mit wem war Kai Wegner Tennis-Spiel, nicht ob er Tennis-Spiel war. Und warum konnte er diesen Termin nicht absagen? Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, in diesem Buch wird auch abgehandelt, dass es jetzt gerade das erste Mal in Amerika lukrativer ist, bei einer Bank zu arbeiten, als sie zu besitzen. Es wird quasi das ganze Geld für, weil die Leute plötzlich Milliarden verdienen müssen, rausgeben an Leute, die es wirklich können. Jetzt können wir diese Welt mal aufteilen in Leute, die es können, und Leute, die so als Zuschauer daneben stehen. Es fällt Strom in Berlin aus. Alle sind noch so in Weihnachts-Neujahrs-Stimmung, sind ein bisschen alarmiert. Und es geht ein Hilferuf an alle Behörden, die damit zu tun haben. Und wirklich jeder Feuerwehrmann rückt aus. Die Polizei steht an jeder Straßenecke. Alle sind zusammengezogen. Was braucht man in diesem Moment nicht in diesem Szenario? Einen ganz fleißigen Bürgermeister, der auch die ganze Zeit denkt, er kann da noch was mitmachen.
Das glaube ich nicht. Nein, der Bürgermeister muss ja ein Riesenmanagement mitgestalten. Also er ist ja nicht nur repräsentativ. Aber ich bin da ja auch bei Anne Spiegel ganz rigoros. Wenn man den Job hat, muss man einfach zur Stelle sein. Was ich nicht erwarte, ist, dass man irgendwo mit Gummistiefeln rumläuft oder dass man sonst irgendwas macht mit der Taschenlampe da durch die Häuser.
Was ist die Stelle, die keine Wegner da haben?
Man ist im Büro und arbeitet.
Was ist Arbeit in dem Moment?
Es wird in diesem Moment Dinge zu tun geben, die wichtig sind, die man als Bürgermeister zu tun hat. Und man geht dann nicht Tennis spielen. Dann ist man im falschen Job. Und genau so war das auch bei Anne Spiegel. Wenn sie sagte, ich bin Mutter und wir waren überfordert und brauchen Urlaub. Schön und gut. Aber dann ist sie in diesem Moment nicht die Richtige im Job. Denn das muss sie hinten anstellen, bei einer solchen Katastrophe, wie sie im Ahrtal war.
Ja, das finde ich auch sehr gut. Und wir kommen gleich auf dieses Thema. Heute passen zwei Clips, die ich habe, beide dazu. Wir sehen doch jetzt an vielerlei Stellen so eine Art soziologisches Display von Leistungs- und Publikumsrollen. Und wir alle haben vor Augen, wie Donald Trump da in Mar-a-Lago in diesem schwarz umhangenden, was auch immer, spontan errichteten Situation-Room sitzt. Und Piquet Hecthes neben ihm sitzt und es gerade noch schafft, am Computer x.com aufzurufen, in der Suchzeile Minezoela reinzuschreiben, um einfach zu gucken, wie die Weltöffentlichkeit darauf reagiert, auf den Content, den sie gerade hergestellt haben. Mit diesem Content haben diese Leute nichts zu tun. Die haben einfach Befehle gegeben. Dann hat das Militär drei Tage lang gesagt, das Wetter passt gerade nicht. Und der Präsident sagt, da könnt ihr jetzt langsam mal. Und die so, ne, wir haben hier die Hoheit darüber und müssen unsere Soldaten beschützen. Das Wetter passt gerade nicht.
Trump hat wieder gesagt, wie im Fernsehen war es.
Es war eine totale Unterordnung dieser Zuschauerschaft der totalen Leistungsrolle, nämlich Oberbefehlsgeber. Und so ist das auch in Berlin. Ich glaube einfach nicht dran, dass es irgendeine Aufgabe für Kai Wegner gab, die zu erfüllen ist. Wobei ich auch denke, die Bereitschaft ist dann das wichtige Signal. Man geht dann tatsächlich nicht händisch.
Mir geht es nicht darum zu sagen, der hat das ja, das Zepter in der Hand und der kann das alles managen. Das kann niemand glauben, genauso auch bei Arne Spiegel. Es geht aber auch nicht nur um ein Signal, sondern es geht schon darum, dass Arbeit zu tun ist. Also wenn sie nicht zu tun ist, dann brauchen wir diese ganzen alle nicht mehr.
Den Kai Wegner brauchst du, bis diese Katastrophe passiert. Danach ist hoffentlich alles in Place. Das ist die Aufgabe der Politik. Nicht plötzlich in die Leistungsrolle der Ausführenden.
Aber die Politik ist auch in einer Funktion zu entscheiden.
Ja, ich weiß, dass alle Leute so denken, weil genau ihnen das von den Tagesthemen und so reingeredet wird. Aber ich glaube, das Gefüge ist grundsätzlich anders.
Die Frage, die wir uns hier stellen, ist, kann Kai Wegner den Unterschied machen oder nicht? Und wir würden beide sagen, wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber es ist schon so, dass er mit seiner Arbeit auch Beiträgt zu all dem Ganzen. Also am Ende kann ich auch sagen, ob der eine Feuerwehrmann jetzt da noch steht oder nicht, der hat ja auch Tennis spielen gehen können. Nein, alle sind herangezogen. Und dann gilt das natürlich auch für den regierenden Bürgermeister.
So, jetzt zur komplexen Sache. Friedrich Merz, Völkerrecht, irgendwas passiert im Ausland, er weiß auch nicht weiter.
Also wir sind jetzt schon wieder im Bereich der Regierungssimulation angekommen.
Wir sind thematisch wo ganz anders, aber bei demselben Problem. Die Spitzenleistungsrollen in der Politik stehen neben einem Geschehen und versuchen, uns zu erklären, was sie da anrichten. Denn ohne Frage, Friedrich Merz, ist in Mitverantwortung in so etwas passiert. Also wir wollen dann einfach hören und sei es auf einem Marktplatz gebrüllt, ob das jetzt okay ist in den Irak zu ziehen und man die Sperenzie nicht mitmacht. Oder eben damals war es ja nicht nur Gerhard Schröder, sondern es war ja auch Joschka Fischer, der eben gesagt hat vor der UN, you have to make the case. Und wenn der Case nicht da ist, können wir leider die Sperenzie nicht mitmachen. Und jetzt hat sich ja Merz einfach davor gedrückt und hat gesagt, ich sehe wohl, dass da was passiert, aber ich kann es noch nicht ganz deuten. Es ist sehr komplex.
Völkerrechtlich kompliziert.
Während ja Armin Laschet im Prinzip das Vorgehen Verteidigte von Trump, das ist ja ganz erstaunlich, dass er im Prinzip diese Schritte alle mitgehen würde.
Aber da sind wir ja schon in jemand hat sich halt positioniert und wir können es kritisieren, aber sich einfach daneben zu stellen und sagen, ich als Jurist, der sehr stolz darauf ist, Jurist zu sein, der sogar eine 20-jährige Politikpause für die Juristerei gemacht hat. Ich erkenne es gerade nicht so. Das ist ja schon eigene Qualität. Und witzig ist ja im Kontrast dazu, dass es, also wie wenig es komplex ist, dass nicht mal jemand eine Anstrengung übernimmt, um überhaupt eine Komplexität im Sinne von, es gibt auch noch eine Alternative herzustellen. Und es gibt einen sehr witzigen, also ich habe mich wirklich totgelacht, habe ich auch zehnmal schon gesehen gestern, Ausschnitt von Donald Trump in der Air Force One, der versucht, der Presseöffentlichkeit etwas zu erklären. Und neben ihm versucht Lindsey Graham, dasselbe zu erklären, aber eben im alten Modus der Tatsächlichen. Es ist komplex. Kennen wir ja alle noch von früher, wie es eigentlich war. Die Demokratie, das Diktator. Genau, da sind Massenverdichtungswaffen. Also alles total kompliziert. Da brauchen wir jetzt militärische Spezialisten, die das machen. So. Und ich habe mich leider, dieser Clip ist 3 Minuten 46. Ich wollte ihn nicht kürzen, weil John Stewart hat es so wunderbar umrahmt. Also wir nehmen uns jetzt nur einen Clip, aber den mal ein bisschen länger vor, um einfach den Gegenpol zu, es ist wahnsinnig völkerrechtlich kompliziert. Und zwischendrin hört ihr dann Trump und Lindsey Graham. Also wunderbar eingefasst von John Stewart.
Generell in der amerikanischen Geschichte, wenn wir in einem anderen Land intervenieren, ob das wahr ist oder nicht, kommen wir mit einer hohen Prätenz auf, die Menschen verbreitet, die Demokratie verbreitet, die Baseball in den Japaner verwendet, Sie haben es zuerst geblieben, aber es war total wert. Auf welcher moralischen Grundlage wird dieser Konflikt gefeiert?
Wir werden in Venezuela eine Präsenz haben, die sich an Öl beherrscht, aber wir werden die Öl flüchten, wie sie sein sollten.
Öl, eine preisreiche Komponente, sicherlich. Aber nicht der Grund, warum ein Land, das 250 Jahre vorgegeben wurde, auf die Ideen von Freiheit und Selbstdeterminierung, in ein Land gehen würde und einen Mann nachts schnarchen würde.
Wir werden eine enormen Menge der Werte aus dem Boden nehmen.
Wir brauchen totalen Zugang. Ich sehe, wo wir gehen.
Jetzt ist die Statue von Saddam Hussein gefallen. Das ist ein Tag der Freiheit. Ich erinnere mich noch an Talkshows, als sei es gestern gewesen. Wer alles gesessen hat, inklusive Michel Friedmann und Helmut Karasek, alle waren begeistert davon, dass jetzt endlich dieses Volk befreit wurde. Man wurde immer von links gesagt, es geht eigentlich um Geschäfte, um Öl und all das. Das Geschäft am Ende ist nicht besonders gut ausgegangen für die USA. Das war eher teuer. Und ein risikoreiches Investment, das Risiko hat sich nicht gelohnt. Aber das war eben der Diskurs, der aus so einer anti-imperialistischen Perspektive herauskam. Dass man sagte, eigentlich mit so ein bisschen Lenin im Rücken, ja, das ist eben der imperiale Kapitalismus, der dort als kolonial herauftritt.
Der imperiale Imperativ. Das muss jetzt so sein. Die Leute, wir müssen hier Befreiung. Jetzt hat man hier schon Lindsey Craven gesehen. Jetzt hören wir ihn gleich.
Ist das dein erster Krieg? Ich meine, was zur Hölle? Senator Lindsey Graham, du bist eine alte Hand im Krieg. Du hast das schon einiges gemacht. Du bist auf dem Flugzeug. Kannst du diesem Jungen mit dem Casus Belli helfen, und Trump von dem Wissen zurück zu Öl zu bringen?
Also es ist eine wunderbare Szene.
Es ist einfach genial. Und jetzt steht ja der Handelsminister auch noch im Raum.
Ich glaube, sie haben es für das Öl gemacht. Ja, nein, ich habe es für das Öl gemacht. Ist es noch eine andere Grundlage? Kannst du uns was geben? Es gibt viele Probleme, z.B. Menschenrechte, politische Gefahr, in Venezuela. Wir können sie sicherlich befreien und die Leben der Verlusten verbessern. Du wirst beantworten, dass Delci Rodriguez die Opposition-Figuren zurücklassen oder politische Gefahr befreien. Stefan kann dir das auf seinem Weg aus dem Wagen sagen.
Sie haben Steel, Sie haben Minerale, alle kritischen Minerale. Sie haben eine große Mineralsgeschichte, die schon rostig ist. Also Steel, Aluminium, Minerale.
Diese ****** sind vor unseren Augen voll Conquistador gehen. Ich meine, sie haben Öl, Steel, Minerale. Oh, und nicht vergessen, die Spiegel. Spiegel. Wir werden unsere Schiffe mit Cinnamon und Kartoffeln und Öl und alles Bagels laden.
Also wir brauchen auf gar keinen Fall ein Gedenken an Kolonialismus, weil das ist ja erstens ganz lange her und wir haben ja keine Städten dafür. Außer, dass das ganze Fernsehprogramm voll ist davor.
Ja, ja, Wolfram Weimer tut so, als sei der Kolonialismus so weit zurück, dass wir uns schon nicht mehr an ihn erinnern müssen. Dabei erleben wir ihn fortwährend. Und es ist interessant, dass Leute wie Armin Laschet, und er ist ja wirklich nicht der einzige, sondern es gibt ja einige, die das feiern oder auch im Springerhaus, ist man sowieso ganz begeistert jetzt von dieser Intervention, von diesem völkerrechtswidrigen Angriff. Anders kann man es ja nicht bezeichnen. Und was wir ja dann erleben, aber im deutschen Diskurs ist, dass diese Leute immer noch versuchen, das so hinzudrehen, dass es hier dann doch eigentlich um die Dissidenten und weiß ich nicht wen geht. Und die könnte man ja tatsächlich als solche thematisieren. Die haben aber nie interessiert in den letzten Jahren. Nie hat sich irgendjemand diese Leute für Dissidenten in Venezuela interessiert. Aber jetzt kommen sie natürlich plötzlich damit an. Sie sind eigentlich noch nicht angekommen in diesem Zeitalter der neuen Ehrlichkeit, das ja hier ganz klar ausgerufen ist. Denn deutlicher kann man nicht werden. Die Altvorderen wie Lindsey Graham versuchen es nochmal nach der alten Art. Aber nein, Trump fährt ihm über den Mund und sagt, nein, es geht hier ums Öl, ums Öl, ums Öl. Das ist die neue Ehrlichkeit, auf die man sich einstellen muss. Und da hilft das auch nicht, wenn man so noch von europäischer Seite, wie das ja auch Kaya Callas getan hat, die war auch ganz entsetzt davon, so zu tun, als müsste man es doch nochmal schauen, wie man es bewertet. Sondern es ist ja von den Initiatoren schon gesagt worden, was die Intention ist. Da muss man ja sich nicht selbst fragen, finden wir nochmal eine neue Intention. Das ist aber etwas, was wir jetzt immer wieder erleben können, dass so im deutschen Diskurs oder auch im europäischen Diskurs Dinge wieder glatt gebügelt werden, obwohl es eigentlich schon, man legt noch mal ein Schleier drüber. Die ziehen selbst den Schleier runter und wir holen nochmal den Schleier raus. Und ja, Callas schaut nochmal, ob man doch nochmal so tun kann, als sei 2004.
Ja, also es ist wirklich ganz verrückt und dieses Wort Komplex hat ja ein Gegenwort und es ist eben nicht kompliziert und einfach, sondern es geht ja nicht, mehr Zeit nicht sagt, ist Völkerrecht kompliziert, sondern also kompliziert ist es durchaus. Gibt es einen guten New York Times The Daily Podcast dazu, wie hier Völkerrecht und indentisches Recht. Und wie ist das jetzt, wenn amerikanische Soldaten im Ausland angegriffen werden? Also offensiv wird geschossen, obwohl sie ja gerade invaden. Und wenn man dann zurückschießt, ist das durchaus als Selbstverteidigung. Aber nun nach amerikanischem Recht. Das Völkerrecht sagt dazu dann wieder gar nichts, weil ja schon vorher geklärt werden muss. Ist das dann ein illegaler Einmarsch? Und das ist auf jeden Fall. Denn wir haben ja die Statuten, entweder du wirst von der UN beauftragt da einzufallen oder das Land selber holt dich. Und das ist beides nicht passiert. Und in der Sicht ist es alles ganz klar. Und das Gegenwort von Komplex ist Komplett. Und mit Komplett ist eben gemeint, es gibt jetzt keine zweite Abzweigung, keine andere Möglichkeit der Deutung oder irgendetwas, sondern es ist eine komplette Geschichte. Die muss nicht gedeutet, die muss einfach nur gelesen werden. Und hier ist einfach, Amerika hat ein Interesse an Bodenschätzen und sie haben eine Macht, um sich diesen zu bereichern. Und eins plus eins ist zwei. Und da ist nichts kompliziert.
Sie hätten noch ein anderes Land gehabt, wo sie auch ähnliche Ölvorkommen haben, ähnliche Bodenschätze finden können. Das war Kanada. Das ist aber ein bisschen aufwendiger, wenn man da rein will. Insofern hat man sich für Venezuela entschieden.
Jetzt kann man bei Spiegel Online halt die großen Aufschlüsselungen. Ja, das ist so viel Öl, dass es für Deutschland 500 Jahre reichen würde, für die komplette Stromversorgung. Oder was man sonst noch mit Öl macht. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Öl nicht in so einem guten Zustand. Also man hat es nicht mit so arabischem Öl zu tun, dass man einfach direkt verfeuern kann.
Nein, man hat aber diese Raffinerien, die im Prinzip jetzt gerade wie leer stehen und die man jetzt damit...
Ja, aber das kostet viel Geld.
Das kostet amerikanischen Boden, dass man das da macht. Was ja auch klimapolitisch eine interessante Perspektive ist, dass man hier also Öl für die Ewigkeit haben will. Das heißt, das ist ja nochmal ein ganz klarer Schritt dazu, dass wir uns vollkommen loslösen, zumindest hier in diesem politischen Westen, der ja auch dann noch von Deutschland und Europa mit unterstützt wird, von so etwas wie einer Politik gegen den Klimawandel. Denn das hier ist ja nun mit das Schlimmste über das Völkerrecht und das ist hinaus das Schlimmste, was man gerade machen kann aus klimapolitischer Perspektive.
Und im Grunde, und wir haben das letzte Mal diesen von Milanovic, diesen Tenor mitgeliefert bekommen, wenn es mit dem Imperialismus nicht klappt, macht man Isolationismus. Und jetzt sieht das ja aus wie Imperialismus. Nur das, was hier stattfindet, ist ja auch das große Eingeständnis. Wir haben im Wettstreit mit China darum verloren, diese Energie einfach günstig und auch zivilkompatibel herzustellen. Nur wir haben halt das Militär.
Das haben wir noch.
Also nutzt man jetzt einfach das Militär.
Das ja jetzt nochmal verstärkt werden soll. Also es sind ja 500 Milliarden im Gespräch bei Trump jetzt. Bei China sind wir nochmal für das Militär. Es gibt Gerüchte, dass Trump jetzt nochmal viel mehr ausgeben will.
Also der Haushalt ist ja schon 800 Milliarden.
Es ist ja interessant, wenn man sich die Militärausgaben insgesamt ansieht, ist man bei 2,7 Billionen und davon sind 37 Prozent an Militärausgaben bei den USA, 12 Prozent bei China. Und jetzt will Trump das nochmal stärker erhöhen, was deine These nochmal bestätigt, dass man sagt, also wir haben schon mal die ganzen Stationen überall, so viele Militärbasen hat sonst niemand. Wir können da nochmal mit weiter kommen und folgen dann eigentlich so eine alten Frontier-These aus dem 19. Jahrhundert. Go West oder nach Venezuela oder sonst wohin, wo wir gerade dann einen Zugriff haben auf die Ressourcen, die wir benötigen. Und das ist die einzige Chance, weil man ja das andere abwickelt. Interessanterweise ist ja jetzt auch Elon Musk wieder an Trump heran gerückt, obwohl er ja eigentlich sehen müsste, dass ja diese Ölgeschichte genau das ist, was er ja einst, wir haben es fast vergessen, vor 10, 12 Jahren, als ja auch aus der liberaldemokratischen Mitte viele Leute Elon Musk gut fanden, dass ja etwas war, was Elon Musk überwinden wollte, weshalb er Tesla so gegründet hat und auf die Elektromobilität gesetzt hat. Da kommt man gar nicht mehr so richtig zusammen.
Also wir sehen hier ganz viele Plan Bs einfach, weil Plan A's schon nicht mehr aufgehen, aber die Plan Bs werden halt noch theatralisch auf der Vorderbühne ordentlich aufgeführt. Und es führt uns zu einem Thema, das auch mit dem Buch heute viel zu tun hat. Diese meritokratische Klasse, von der da geschrieben wird, die im Grunde eine alte Aristokratie, aber diesmal mit Know-how ist. Also Leute wissen dann wirklich, wie die Sachen funktionieren, statt einfach so Angestellte dafür zu haben.
Ja, also Leistung ist das Prinzip und nicht mehr Geburt.
Genau. Und da stellt sich einfach die Frage, wo bleibt denn jetzt der Show-Aspekt? Also die alte Aristokratie, wenn man sich Frankreich vor der französischen Revolution anschaut oder andere Beispiele in Europa, die man so hat, die sind ja nun, und darauf sind wir bis heute sehr stolz, von Herrlichkeit gezeigt. Und wie lässt sich das eigentlich noch retten, wenn einfach jeder direkt zeigen muss, dass er es wirklich kann? Also wenn gilt, wie eben schon gesagt, dass das Mitarbeiten in einer Bank, das Angestellten sein, lukrativer ist als das Besitzen. Da hat ja offenbar jemand jemanden gesagt, ich weiß hier Bescheid, ich kenne die Umsätze, ich hätte gern 80 Prozent davon. Und dann bleiben für den faulensten, den aristokratischen Eigner halt nur noch 20. So, das ist ja das Prinzip. Das heißt, wir haben eine Neuordnung von Show Aspect und Musikgang und eine Neubedeutung von Industrie und echten Ackern. Und es gab einen Boxkampf, du hast mir gerade auf dem Weg hierher gesagt, du hast davon nichts mitbekommen oder nur gehört, dass es das gibt. Also auf Netflix kam letztes Jahr gegen Ende noch ein Boxkampf. Jake Paul gegen Anthony, Anthony, wer ist er denn? Joshua, entweder Joshua Anthony oder Anthony Joshua.
Ich habe nur damals den Boxkampf Jake Paul gegen Mike Tyson mitbekommen.
Genau, den hat ja Jake Paul gewonnen, was ihm einigen Nimbus gegeben hat, um zum Beispiel überhaupt so ein, wie Joe Rogan sagt, Knockout-Artist, wie den Anthony, ich glaube, er heißt mit dem Nachnamen Anthony, was kann auch sein, dass Joshua der Name ist, wie auch immer.
Also ein Profi-Boxer, jedenfalls. Es ist ein Profi-Boxer.
Genau, nicht nur ein Profi-Boxer, sondern auch selber ein unglaubliches Show-Talent. Also man sieht ihn einfach auch gerne in Interviews oder so. Also ich habe das, als ich mir das so angeschaut habe, als ich den Boxer nicht gesehen habe, aber so im Nachgang, was das für ein Typ ist, habe ich gesagt, ja, macht was her, so. Und die beiden waren jetzt im Boxring und es stellt sich im Nachhinein raus, Jake Paul hat diesmal verloren, aber es gab wohl auf Polymarkets und so offensichtliche Wetten, die auch in die Richtung gingen, dass Jake Paul deine Chance hätte. Und jetzt stellt sich im Nachhinein heraus, never, also der größte fake ever wahrscheinlich, weil hier stehen einfach 160 Millionen Dollar Gage für die beiden, also jeder 80 Millionen, unabhängig davon, wie der Kampf ausgeht, einfach nur, weil Netflix Sendefläche hat so. Nur die Sendefläche muss halt genutzt werden, das heißt, wenn der Boxkampf ehrlich gewesen wäre, und es gibt jetzt auch Interviews mit Mike Tyson dazu, 10 Sekunden hätte man Jake Paul gegeben im Regen, und da wäre das eigentlich gegessen gewesen. Ja, sonst wäre der KO gepissen. Genau, also so weit kommt man dann doch nicht, wenn man im Grunde 1000 Videos macht mit Schabernack und nicht richtig Zeit fürs Training hat. Und wir gucken uns mal hier eine kurze Aufarbeitung an. Wir sehen es auch, aber es wird auch alles erklärt, und dann können wir das nochmal besprechen. Und das zeigt ihm auch zu, ja, ich habe das gesehen, okay, mach jetzt mal locker. Also Jake, Paul wurde nicht nur einfach niedergeschlagen, sondern sein Gegner hat ihm auch noch mal zurück die Zunge rausgesteckt, im Sinne von, ich sehe das schon, was du hier willst von mir. Aber wir sind hier gerade mit einem echten Boxkampf.
Alle Absprachen, die wir vorher getroffen haben, spielen jetzt keine Rolle mehr.
Und es ist auch schon Runde fünf. Aber jetzt geht es um meinen Fame. Und ich lasse mich nicht vorführen wie Mike Tyson, der durchaus damals seine entsprechenden medialen hohen Momente hatte. Also in dem Sinne musste ein junger Mann natürlich jetzt einfach zeigen, wer hier der Herr im Ring ist. Und Jake Paul wurde so niedergeschlagen, dass er jetzt wirklich vier Titanplatten hat und seine Zähne völlig derangiert, da neu gesortiert werden müssen und so. Also es ist einfach auch, wo man sich fragt, so ein bisschen nach, was das jetzt wert hat. Hat das Spaß gemacht?
Jedenfalls, um das nochmal deutlich zu machen, es gab offenbar Absprachen zwischen Jake Paul und diesem Profiboxer, dass man sagte, wir bekommen hier zwischen Jake Paul und den bisherigen Boxern, nämlich alle.
Das ist nämlich jetzt eine Rückabwicklung dieser ganzen Geschichte, die dazu führte.
Man macht also eine Show, bekommt, weil man Jake Paul ist und diese Leute heranziehen kann und bei Netflix ist, ein enormes Budget und sagt, lass uns das teilen. Ich will auch gerne noch weiter kämpfen. Die nächsten drei Boxer sind schon fest in Aussicht. Ihr könnt mir jetzt hier nicht die Rübe zerstören, sondern wir müssen sehen, dass wir einigermaßen simulieren, dass es ein echter Kampf ist. Aber ihr dürft nicht so zuschlagen, wie ihr es eigentlich tätet. Würdet ihr mit einem richtigen Boxer im Ring stehen?
Wir sind jetzt auf dieser Ebene angekommen, die es sonst nur in der Politik gab. Länder gehen Verträge miteinander ein und man fragt sich, vor welchem Gericht wollt ihr das jemals einklagen? Die gibt es ja gar nicht. Jake Paul wird auch ein Teufel tun, jetzt im Nachhinein eine Anklage zu formulieren mit, wir hatten doch eine Absprache. Und dann hast du mir trotzdem den Kiefer gebrochen, weil es geht ja gar nicht. Das wird auch für Jake Paul und diese ganze Internet-Gang, also nicht nur, weil sie von KI bedroht sind, dieses ganze Influenzertum, sondern auch wegen sowas. Sie haben dafür eigentlich das Wrestling, nur es hat ihnen nicht gereicht. Sie brüten mehr Echtheit. Genau. Und jetzt haben sie sich in Branchen eingemischt, wo es diese Gewinne, die sie glaubten, machen zu können, nicht gibt. Und es wurde ihnen sehr brutal jetzt vor Augen geführt. Also dieses Ereignis finde ich, das ist ein bisschen wie der Gelsenkirchener Bankdiebstahl. Das wird zwar jetzt auch erst mal ein bisschen verschwinden und Jack Ball wird auch einen Teufel tun, das jetzt irgendwie selber groß aufzuklären. Aber die Interviewanfragen an Mike Tyson waren alle erfolgreich. Also der sagt offen, ja, meine Leute haben mich gefragt, wie hast du das gemacht? Ich habe mich auch geärgert darüber, das fürs Geld zu machen und so. Also die Aufklärung ist eindeutig. Wir haben es jetzt nicht mit einer komplexen völkerrechtlichen Lage zu tun. Ja, sondern es ist komplett. Hier geht es jetzt zur Sache. Und das finde ich, also 2026 hat einige Überraschungen im Petto, würde ich sagen.
Wir sprechen über ein Buch, das die These hat, dass wir eigentlich eine neue Aristokratie bekommen haben, die aber durch Leistung sich manifestiert. Eine neue herrschende Klasse, die superreich ist und sich von der Mittelklasse fundamental unterscheidet. Und wir lesen auch hier die Zahl, die wir bei Branko Milanovic schon vernommen haben, nämlich diese Superreichen geben pro Kind 10 Millionen Dollar aus für Bildung, Erziehung, bis man dann groß ist und selbst dann zur meritokratischen Elite gehört. Im Vergleich zur Mittelklasse, was die an Budget zur Verfügung haben, beziehungsweise was an öffentlichen Geldern da sind. Das ist ein unglaubliches Buch mit wahnsinnigen Zahlen. Es ist ein Buch, das uns zeigt, eigentlich ist diese Idee der Leistungsgesellschaft, wir haben es schon bei Michael Sandel natürlich thematisiert, aber hier bekommen wir es nochmal ganz anders gerahmt, dass diese Idee der Leistungsgesellschaft eine enorm toxische ist, die eine Ungleichheit viel besser noch manifestieren kann, als das in der alten Aristokratie möglich war. Ich bin fasziniert von diesem Buch und habe dann aber zugleich schon etwas gefunden, was schon darüber wieder hinausgeht. Ich habe gerade die Zahl genannt, 10 Millionen Dollar und daran kann man auch sehr gut sehen, man kann offenbar aus einem Esel ein Rennpferd machen, wenn man nur genügend Geld reinsteckt, so funktioniert das und dann kommt eben das Kind auch nach Oxford, Yale oder wohin auch immer und wird dann nachher bei Goldman Sachs arbeiten. Und da könnte man ja noch einen Schritt weiter gehen. Ich erinnerte mich, als ich das las, daran, dass Francis Fukuyama, der dieses Buch auch geschrieben hat, Das Ende des Menschen, dort sagt er, was wäre, wenn es tatsächlich einmal möglich sein wird, Menschen zu züchten, die Sporen haben an den Füßen, mit denen sie die anderen treten wie Pferde. Ja, also damit wird gesagt, also was ist, wenn man diese Klassenunterschiede nochmal biologisch festsetzen kann? Diese neue herrschende Klasse, die erleben wir jetzt, dass sie darüber genau sich Gedanken macht. Natürlich spielen da alle schon erwähnten hier im Podcast Alex K., Peter Thiel und so eine Rolle. Wir hören jetzt Alexander Wang. Der ist der Gründer von Scale AI. Das ist ein Unternehmen, das natürlich auch Geld bekommen hat von Peter Thiel. Da ist Mark Zuckerberg mit dabei. Amazon ist da mit drin. Die machen was eigentlich?
Also Scale AI wurde 2016 gegründet. Und es ist ganz interessant, weil sie ja auf einen Bedarf reagierten, den es gab, den wir heute erst richtig einschätzen können. Aber Amazon hat ja recht früh angefangen zu sagen, okay, wir haben hier so Datenmaterial, das muss mal aufbereitet werden, zum Beispiel CD-Cover. Und das Problem war, dieses CD-Cover hat man einfach als Bild bekommen, also millionenfach pro Jahr, je nachdem, wie viel Musik halt so publiziert wurde. Und Amazon musste das ja auf die Seite bringen. Man hat es ja nicht einfach ins Regal gestellt im Sinne als Produkt, sondern da musste halt drunter stehen, was ist denn das eigentlich und wer singt denn da und so. Oder jetzt wie bei Spotify, dass die ganzen Liedtexte sekundengenau mitlaufen, um eine Karaoke machen kann und so. Das sind also Datenaufbereitungen, die müssen erledigt werden. Das sind echte Aufgaben. Und man hatte dafür ganz lange keine Computer, aber halt den Bedarf. Weshalb Amazon angefangen hat, solche Sachen wie Mechanical Turk zu gründen. Man hat selber Annotations- oder wie es auch immer heißt, also diese Zuordnung von Daten und der Datei sozusagen als Problem gehabt und hat das dann einfach ausgelagert in Click-Workerei. Das heißt, in Bangladesch oder wo auch immer konnte man einfach seinen Computer anmachen, auf mechanicalturk.com gehen. Dann waren wir bei Amazon auf der Seite und hatten einfach gesehen, ah, hier ist ein Task im Angebot. 100 CD-Cover und Lied-Texte matchen. Und dann hat Amazon geschrieben, das ist unsere 7,20 Euro wert. Und sehr viele Leute in Afrika und in Südasien, wo auch immer, haben gesagt, das ist eine gute Arbeit für mich. Also sitzen da Hunderttausende vor Computern und klicken den ganzen Tag, machen solche Minitas die ganze Zeit. Und scale.ai dachte sich, also wenn jetzt hier so ein T-Noy ist wie, die bei OpenAI sind schon recht weit und die brauchen jetzt hier solche Daten, und zwar von allem, was zur Verfügung steht, dann bieten wir das an. Also wir schaffen einfach Datengrundlagen, sortierte Daten.
Mit Clickworkern oder ohne?
Mit Clickworkern. Und das ist eben dieser Punkt. scale.ai, die uns heute dazu, dass Sam Altmann auf der Bühne stehen kann und sagen kann, das ist so faszinierend. Wir machen aus Sand Computerchips und in den Computerchips steckt Intelligenz. Also wir machen aus Sand Intelligenz. Die Grundlagenarbeit dafür ist menschliche Clickworkerei auf der ganzen Welt. Und dieses Business hat scale.ai angeboten. Also wir hören jetzt jemanden, der sozusagen die Spitze der Meritokratie formuliert, während er selber seine vielen Milliarden, die er verdient hat, einfach nur auf ich biete jemanden die Clickworkerei-Jobs, die mir 20 Dollar im Monat auf der Seite sind und verkaufe die dann als gesammelten Datensatz für Milliarden und Milliarden weiter. Das war im Grunde dieses Geschäftsmodell.
Alexander Wang, der jüngste Milliardär in der Geschichte offenbar, sagt jetzt Folgendes und das passt dann gut zu unserem meritokratischen Problem. Was wir also hier hören ist, die Kindererziehung kann man ja noch viel weiter treiben. Jetzt hat man zum Beispiel Vorschulen. Wusste ich auch gar nicht, wie wichtig Vorschulen sind für die Elite, um die ganzen Talente zu fördern oder überhaupt erst zu entdecken bei den Kindern. Wie viele Tausende man da schon für ausgibt. Aber wenn man es doch schon vor Geburt ein bisschen managen kann, beziehungsweise gleich nach der Geburt, also erstmal kann man natürlich mit Genpool und so weiter arbeiten, sind die ja auch alle dran aus so einem transhumanistischen Interesse heraus. Und dann könnte man doch mit Neuralink von Elon Musk oder anderem ein Update gleich im frühen Kindesalter verschaffen, weil da das Gehirn noch so flexibel ist.
Genau, wir haben ja den Text gelesen aus China, wie es damit der Genetik vor sich geht. Die sehen sich natürlich auch in so einem obskuren Systemstreit. Sie wissen nicht genau, welche nächste Kindergeneration aus China kommt und wollen halt mithalten. Ja.
In your first like seven years of life, your brain is more neuroplastic than at any other point in your life, like by an order of magnitude. I think when we get Neuralink and we get these other technologies, kids who are born with them are going to learn how to use them in like crazy, crazy ways. Like it'll be actually like a part of their brain in a way that it'll never be true for an adult who gets like a Neuralink or whatever hooked into their brain.
Das sind ja bisweilen dieselben Leute, ist auch so eine typische Podcastsituation, wie man sie da kennt. Also Männer sitzen im dunklen Raum und haben eine komische Beleuchtung. Dort wird sich normalerweise darüber unterhalten, dass die ganzen Gender-Ideologen mit ihrer Frühsexualisierung der Kinder die ganzen Kinder kaputt machen und zerstören. Und wir müssen die Kinder so aufwachsen lassen, und die dürfen gar nicht in irgendeiner Weise in Berührung kommen mit der erwachsenen Welt. Und hier wird einfach schon mal darüber spekuliert, was könnte man denen alles für Chips einsetzen in die Köpfe, damit es dann entsprechend funktioniert, wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Und die Menschen, wir wachsen nur an einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Die Menschen werden über Zeit smarter werden. Es ist nur auf der Zeitstelle von Millionen Jahre, weil Naturselektion und Evolution sehr langsam sind. Wenn du das vorwärtsspielst, wirst du AI-Leute, die weiter wachsen, weiter verbessern. Es ist möglicherweise gefährlich und zu deinem Punkt schrecklich und gefährlich, aber wir werden es einfach machen. Die AI wird so gehen, die Menschen werden sich bei einem viel schnelleren Raten verbessern und wir werden diese Fähigkeit hängen. Ich habe mit vielen Wissenschaftlern in diesem Raum gesprochen, und vielen Leuten, die auf dieser Sache arbeiten, z.B. den Leuten an Neuralink. Und Neuralink und Neuralangst sind so, das ist, wo die Technologie über Zeit gehen wird. Und so wie jede vordere Technologie, müssen wir das nicht verpissen.
Aber es wird ziemlich kritisch sein, wenn wir Menschen, die relevant bleiben wollen, als A-Modell, Ja, also wir hören ja beide den Doppelgänger-Podcast, weil der ist ja sehr gut und da wird der über, also da werden ja diese Schicksale ein bisschen eher begleitet so. Und seine neueste Karrierestufe ist ja Chef für KI-Sachen bei Open Air, bei Meta zu sein. Max Zuckerberg war also sehr unzufrieden mit der Ausbeute seiner Leute des größten Chipskaufs aller Zeiten. Also niemand hat so viel Nvidia-Kram gekauft wie Max Zuckerberg. Und am Ende kommt im Grunde nicht das bei Rom, was er wollte. Und da es nur wenige Leute gibt, die sich damit auskennen, hat er einfach Alexander Wang. Nur Alexander Wang ist halt ein Neokolonialist, der einfach die halbe Welt ausgebeutet hat mit Clickworkerei. Der hat auch keine richtige Ahnung. Also da reicht dann, also klar kann man mal eine Mathe-Olympiade gewinnen und so, aber so ist der Tenor, bringt jetzt nicht das mit, was man da braucht.
Ja.
Was bedeutet, er sitzt da zwar mit Milliarden unterfüttert in so einer Bar und redet so darüber.
Ist aber eigentlich mit Trap-Shipping reich geworden, könnte man sagen.
Genau.
Da irgendwo wird die Arbeit getan, dann nimmt man diese billigen Produkte und verkauft sie an Silicon Valley teurer.
Genau, ist ein ganz billiges Abitrage-Geschäft, was ihn so super reich gemacht hat, halt zur richtigen Zeit. Aber er hat im Grunde jetzt auch nicht mehr Ahnung als wir.
Ja.
Und die Leute, die davon Ahnung haben, also Sutzkäfer, Brockmann, dieser Deep-Mind-Typ, der jetzt bei Google sogar Nobelpreise dafür kriegt, die stehen zwar alle auf der Bühne und erzählen auch von großen Potenzialen, aber sie bleiben eben bei diesem Grundbegriff Potenzial und sagen im Grunde, man muss mal schauen, so richtig verstehen wir es auch noch nicht, wir machen hier auch sehr viel Forensik und dann kann man halt bei Anthropik so den letzten Stand der Forschung einfach veröffentlicht lesen und da käme niemand auf die Idee zu sagen, ja ich warte jetzt noch kurz und es ist ja bei ihm auch jetzt sagen wir mal einen Zehn-Jahres-Zeit-Raum, ja er ist jetzt 29 und will noch ein paar Jahre warten, bis die Kinder kommen. Er erwartet das jetzt irgendwie so in sechs Jahren, während du ja zu Recht immer sagst, dass es selbst mit dem selbstfahrenden Auto ist schwierig so. Und er erwartet jetzt einfach, dass das Gehirn-Interface fertig ist in den nächsten zehn Jahren. Also es ist ja absurd.
Die Sache ist nur, sie würden es tun, wenn es ginge. Und das ist das Bemerkenswerte jetzt hier, dass wir da eine völlige Loslösung haben von zum Beispiel einer christlichen Schöpfungsidee oder so, sondern dass die jetzt wirklich sagen, wir müssen den Supermenschen basteln, damit er im Konkurrenzkampf gegen China bestehen kann, gegen AGI auch noch in irgendeiner Weise eine Relevanz hat. Das heißt, wir haben es schon mit einer neuen Elite zu tun, die eigentlich sicher beisehend einen neuen Menschen zu schaffen.
Ja, aber hier wird es ja halt soziologisch, politisch und zivilgesellschaftlich wahnsinnig interessant, denn was macht diese Meritokratie, die der Daniel Markovits beschreibt, eigentlich so zu kräftig? Das sind die Grundbegriffe Fleiß zum Beispiel und diese Ansage, jeder kann es schaffen, weil es kann ja jeder einfach 100 Bücher pro Jahr lesen und 80 Stunden die Woche arbeiten und so. Kann ja prinzipiell jeder. Wenn allerdings die erste Generation mit so einem Chip im Kopf auftaucht, dann ist genau diese Erzählung nichts mehr wert.
Ja.
So, das heißt, die größte Ausbeutergeschichte, nämlich dass die meritokratische Klasse sich selber ausbeutet, durch diesen enormen Bildungsweg und dann 80 Wochenstunden arbeiten. Und diese Ausbeutung wirklich nur gemacht wird. Und die sagen selber alle, ja, ja, das sind schon Bullshit-Jobs. Und dann stellt er ja, also er ist Law-Professor in Yale und stellt seinen Studenten die Frage, wenn ich euch 15 Stunden die Woche Arbeit gebe, die völlig sinnlos ist und ihr wisst es auch, aber ihr kriegt dadurch mehr Punkte auf dem Zeugnis, würdet ihr es machen? Und alle sagen ja.
Und können auch die Frage gar nicht verstehen. Warum das ein Problem sei.
Schade, dass wir es machen so. Dann stellt sich ja da, sie wollen diesen Fleiß ausbeuten und damit zeigen, dass sie exzeptionell sind. Nur wenn sie diese Klammer zu den 99% der Rest nicht machen können, also wenn die Botschaft nicht mehr ist, ihr könntet ja auch, ihr müsst nur an der Schule richtig aufpassen, sondern es einfach Startvoraussetzungen gibt, die anders sind, dann haben wir es ja mit einer materiellen Neu-Diskussion zu tun. Also in der ganz viel Ideologie nicht mehr funktionieren.
Die es ja schon gibt, dadurch, dass sie das Kapital haben, dass ihnen das ermöglicht, das so zu machen und die besten Lehrer und all das so haben.
Und darüber läuft ja auch der Ungerechtigkeitsdiskurs.
Ja und jetzt können wir ja noch, der nächste Schritt wäre dann dieses Update sich zu verschaffen und dann kann man natürlich gewisse Erzählungen nicht mehr reproduzieren, aber Markovits schreibt ja auch, es gibt gerade bei den erfolgreichsten die größte Angst abzurutschen. Und wenn man dies vermeiden könnte, dadurch, dass man es grundsätzlich einprogrammiert, dass da nichts mehr ist, ja man programmiert sich den Erfolg ein durch diesen Chip, dann wäre das für die eigentlich die Rettung, um endlich ihre Abstiegsangst loszuwerden. Das ist der Punkt, glaube ich, der hier so stark verfolgt wird, denn alles läuft ja auf so einer Aristokratie hinaus.
Die zweite Dimension ist aber, dass die restliche Bevölkerung mitmacht. Und das muss anders hergestellt werden. Dann kannst du nicht mal sagen, wir sind alle in die Schule gegangen.
Nein, das dann nicht.
Von daher, das sind schon Herausforderungen, die er natürlich nicht sieht und so. Wir haben hier jemanden, der was gesagt hat.
Wir haben es jedenfalls mit einem sehr bemerkenswerten Buch zu tun. Wir werden darüber jetzt gleich ausführlich diskutieren. Ich will einen Begriff schon mitbringen hier vor den Salon, nämlich den Begriff exzellente Schafe. So bezeichnet werden ja diese neuen meritokratischen Eliten beschrieben. Das heißt, sie sind clever und sie haben alle Skills, alle Zertifikate, aber sind exzellente Schafe. Das heißt, sie machen alles mit und beuten sich dabei selbst aus. Es ist wirklich ein Buch, das uns vieles anders sehen lässt. Denn wir haben ja hier einen sehr starken Diskurs darüber, dass sehr viele Leute so ein Leistungsdosis-Einkommen beziehen durch Mieten etc. Aber es gibt eben auch das hier, dieser Fall, und zwar, dass man über das Einkommen so immens reich wird. Und in den USA ist das, auch das müssen wir nachher besprechen, viel stärker als in Deutschland. Aber wir sehen auch in Deutschland, wohin sich das bewegt, wenn wir uns den Genie-Koeffizienten dann genauer ansehen. Jedenfalls ist das das Buch, über das wir sprechen, The Meritocracy Trap von Daniel Markovits. Ein wirklich sehr interessantes Buch, über das wir im Salon diskutieren. Außerdem gibt es noch Empfehlungen von uns. Einmal Musik, Haydn, Streichquartett. Dann habe ich von der Essaystin und Künstlerin Hito Steyerl ein Buch über KI und Bildgenerierung gelesen. Eine Erzählung bringe ich mit von Ben Shattuck. Die Geschichte des Klangs, die bald verfilmt wird oder schon verfilmt ist mit Joshua Connor und Paul Maskell. Außerdem blicken wir kurz auf die katholische Kirche. Wie steht die eigentlich zur Aufrüstung? Und da ist es auch nicht so viel besser. Und wir üben uns an einer Kritik am Bundesverfassungsgericht, das ja hier im Podcast immer sehr hochgehalten wird. Aber vielleicht ist es ein Problem, wenn man nur juristische Argumente gelten lässt, sagt zumindest der Rechtswissenschaftler Uwe Volkmann in der FAZ.
Gut, ich für meinen Teil bringe mit ungleichheit.info. Wir lesen heute mal eine Webseite, denn Martina Linatas Buch, das ja im April kam, Unverdiente Ungleichheit, oder wie es heißt, haben wir ja verpasst, unverdiente Ungleichheit. Wie der Weg aus der Erbengesellschaft gelingen kann, ist ja sowieso, jetzt wo wir mal Markovits gelesen, wo wir heute das lesen, nochmal anders zu deuten so. Aber diese Webseite ist ganz interessant. Und ich bin auch total dafür, dass wir Webseiten grundsätzlich ein bisschen mehr würdigen. Wir betonen ja immer, dass unser Podcast eine Webseite hat. Ich sehe häufiger Podcasts, die keine eigene Webseite haben. Also schlage ich mich auf Seiten des Silicon Valley oder bei Spotify rum und finde Informationen nicht, die ich eigentlich mal bräuchte und so.
Brauchen wir also für Wohlstand für alle auch eine eigene Webseite? Unbedingt.
Ich finde, jede Person braucht eine eigene Webseite.
Ja, ich habe eine Webseite.
Ja, aber wir hauchen den Webseiten auch nochmal ein bisschen Lebendigkeit ein demnächst. Ich will heute schon anmerken, wir haben Ergänzungen. Dieser Podcast heute bekommt auch einen eigenen Diskurskanal. Das ist also die Standardangelegenheit für semiöffentliche Diskurser, also vor allem Podcastrückmeldungen, die man anders als Discord und der ganze Müll, den man wirklich kaum zu benutzen, einfach selbst hosten. Also smalltalk.neuezwanziger.de, aber es ist auch in den Show Notes. Kann man natürlich weiter E-Mails schreiben an uns, aber bei vielen E-Mails denke ich mir, die sind so gut und lehrreich, die könnte man eigentlich auch mal so semiöffentlich zur Verfügung stellen. Also vielleicht kann man seine E-Mail einfach benutzen, seine E-Mail-Adresse, um sich bei diesem Smalltalk anzumelden, beziehungsweise anmelden und einfach sagen, hier, das bin ich, dann kommt man in eine E-Mail und dann ist man authentifiziert und schreibt einfach sein Kram. Also das seht ihr dann, das ist sehr easy. Also Ungleichheit gehen wir einmal durch und zwar, wie es im Internet dargestellt wird. Dann ein Text, der wirklich schockierend ist. Die Ukraine ist in schwierigen Fahrwasser und es gibt einen Ausweg, und zwar fällt der Silicon Valley da gerade ein, um semiautonome Drohnen herzustellen. Und wir können nachher mal, wenn ich den Text vorstelle, überlegen, wo sind hier noch Unterschiede zu solchen Büchern, wie David Suarez Kill Decision, wo es einfach um kleine Schwärme geht, die vor zehn Jahren schon in der Literatur losgeschickt wurden. Also da hat auch Eric Schmidt von Google einiges getan, damit da einfach keine Lücke mehr ist zwischen Realität und Alterfiktion. Außerdem zwei Texte zur KI. Das eine ist den letzten Monat schon angekündigten, den wir heute mal besprechen. LLM und das M steht für Mistake. Large Language Mistake, glaube ich. Das ist also ein Text aus einer aktivistischen Richtung, der sich mit der Frage beschäftigt, Denkenmaschinen eigentlich oder ist es wirklich nur Simulation von Sprache? Also steckt was dahinter, während wir für uns denken, naja, auch wenn ich gerade nichts sage, denke ich ja. Und da steckt eine Qualität drin. Und das konfrontieren wir mal mit einem zweiten Text. Und der hat die Fragestellung, was wäre, wenn die Leser KI-Texte lieber mögen? Das ist hochinteressant von Vauhini, die ich nicht kannte, aber jetzt sehr schätze Vara, eine Autorin, die sowohl in diesem journalistischen Tech-Bereich, als auch in der Roman-Produktion zu Hause ist und im New Yorker einen wirklich sehr langen Text geschrieben hat, über diese Fragestellung mit einem ganz einfachen Szenario. Das will ich schon mal vorstellen. Du sitzt als Nobelpreislitteraturträger an deinem Schreibtisch und erlebst eine Schreibblockade, weil du darüber schreiben möchtest, wie deine Mutter erlebte, dass dein Bruder zwei Stunden nach Geburt starb. Also sie trauert und du gehörst zu dieser Familie. Und Leute, die diesen Text später lesen, wissen auch, das ist ziemlich authentisch, weil hier schreibt der Bruder über klar ist ein Roman, aber es ist sozusagen nah dran. Und dir wollen aber partout nicht die richtigen Worte dafür einfallen, wie diese Mutter trauert. Also du hast eine ganz spezifische Fragestellung. Und welchen Weg gibt es der KI zu sagen, mach mir Entwürfe für dieses Szenario, also einfach nur für die nächsten drei Sätze in meinem großen Roman. Und dann findest du einen Modus, in der die KI das macht. Und zwar so, dass du feststellst, ich kann es nicht übertrumpfen. Und die Testleser, die ich habe, loben mich dafür, was ich da wieder hingezaubert habe. Und man selber verzweifelt daran, dass man es nicht besser ausdrücken kann, als es die KI gerade gemacht hat. Und diesen Modus hat ein Professor wohl gefunden. Und sie schreibt darüber. Es ist auch, finde ich, ein richtiger New Yorker Text. Also das Magazin, ich habe letztens diese Doku gesehen auf Netflix, sehr beeindruckend, die seit 100 Jahren diese Zeitung machen. Und ja, da geht es ans Eingemachte. Da sage ich gut, wir hören die Wortlaute nachher. Ich habe sie von KI einlesen lassen. Also wir können wirklich überprüfen, was hier Sachlage ist.
Wunderbar. Dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich. Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Marx ist tot, aber haben die ihn wirklich überlebt, jetzt lande?
Ich glaube nein, auch wenn das Buch diese These vertritt.
Denn es geht hier wirklich zur Sache. Ich weiß nicht, wo wollen wir direkt beim Markt zerstärken? Keine Ahnung, wir kommen ja im Verlauf darauf.
Wir kommen im Verlauf darauf vielleicht so viel. Hier ist die Frage, die sich ja auch Branko Milanovic gestellt hat, wenn es Menschen gibt, die durch ihr Arbeitseinkommen so immens reich werden, dass sie völlig fernab von der Mittelklasse leben, aber sie weiterhin arbeiten und auch viel arbeiten und nicht zu Rentierklasse werden, also nicht zu denen gehören, die einfach so dasitzen und dann am Ende die Miete einkassieren oder einfach nur die Dividenden einkassieren. Dann ist doch eigentlich damit der Widerspruch zwischen Kapital und Arbeit aufgelöst. Die haben ja Kapital, dass sie da noch wirklich investieren wieder in anderes oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr in die Arbeit. Und trotzdem arbeiten sie so viel. Und dann sage ich Ja, das war etwas, was Marx nicht voraussehen konnte. Aber wir müssen uns da auch noch mal ansehen, inwieweit trotzdem Marx noch wichtig ist, nicht um diese Klasse zu beschreiben, also nicht um zu sagen, bei denen gibt es eigentlich auch noch das klassische Ausbeutungsverhältnis, wie Marx es beschreibt, aber das Verhältnis derer, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen, für wenig und für sehr, sehr viel Geld, muss vielleicht da noch mal mit Marx neu eingeordnet werden. Ich glaube, das kann uns gelingen. Ein Hinweis noch, gerade bevor wir jetzt in das Buch einsteigen. Wir haben ja am 20. März diesen Salon-Termin, und das wollten wir jetzt nur für die Salonisten ankündigen. Am 19. März sind wir in der Alten Oper, nicht in der Neuen Oper am Willy-Brandt-Platz, sondern in der Alten Oper, und gehen dort in ein Konzert-Streichquartett. Und zwar das Streichquartett-Isidor-Quartett spielt. Ich habe die auch schon mal gehört. Die sind sensationell gut. Spielen unter anderem Haydn und Wozak. Wer also da mitkommen möchte, und anschließend gehen wir noch was trinken, sollte einfach auf die Homepage der Alten Oper Frankfurt gehen und kann sich dort ein Ticket buchen. Es wird, glaube ich, sensationell.
Ja, und das ist alles ja relativ groß.
Es ist natürlich der Kammermusiksaal, nicht der ganz große.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ein Streichquartett in so einem großen Saal funktioniert kaum.
Genau, der ist wirklich sehr groß. Okay, dann steigen wir mal in dieses Buch ein und ich sage jetzt mal für mich am interessantesten. Jetzt haben wir Marx einmal aufgeworfen. Bevor wir also nachher auf die, er geht explizit auf Marx ein, gehen wir mal diesen Aspekt Kapital und Arbeit, dass Arbeit heute das Kapital ist. Denn die Zahlen, die hier genannt werden, finde ich, sind der eigentliche Einstieg ins Buch, der diesen Wandel beschreiben und sind auch einfach in absoluten Ausprägungen gesehen wirklich beeindruckend. Dieses Buch ist von 2019. Ja, wir haben eine Dramatisierung dieser Lage über sechs, jetzt schon sieben Jahre, die wir hier jetzt beschreiben. Für 2017 zum Beispiel. Drei einzelne Hedgefonds Hedgefonds Manager verdienen mehr als eine Milliarde Dollar in diesem Jahr.
Ja.
25 mehr als 25 verdienen 100 Millionen Dollar im Jahr. Das sind Menschen, die haben für dieses Geld gearbeitet, wenn man sich die Arbeitszeiten anschaut. Also die haben einfach damit zu tun. Laut einer Umfrage verdient ein Portfolio Manager bei einem mittelgroßen Hedgefonds durchschnittlich durchschnittlich 2,4 Millionen Dollar. Und die durchschnittlichen Boni an der Wall Street explodieren von etwa 14.000 Dollar im Jahr 85 auf mehr als 180.000 Dollar im Jahr 2017. Einem Jahr, in dem das durchschnittliche Gesamtgehalt der 175.000 Beschäftigten in der Wertpapierbranche in New York City über 420.000 Dollar beträgt.
Du hast ja eben zu Recht nochmal darauf hingewiesen, wir sind im Jahr 2019, bekommen hier Zahlen von 2017 oder 18.
Das ist wieder eine Dekade her.
Jetzt haben wir ja erlebt durch den KI-Hype, dass die großen Konzerne einfach sagen, wir haben da einen neuen IT-ler, 50 Millionen Euro bekommt er jetzt, aber der ist auch der Beste. Das heißt, durch auch diese Optionen, diese Anteile zu bekommen von Unternehmen, sind ja jetzt nochmal Tausende zu Multimillionären oder dann Milliardären geworden. Und wir sind also hier schon in einer völlig absurden Phase. Und Markovits hat ja nur solche Zahlen für uns parat auf jeder zweiten Seite.
Und wir wissen heute, die KI kann solche Investmententscheidungen ganz schön gut treffen auch. Also das ist Assistenz für die Leute, aber vielleicht auch für Leute außerhalb. Plus der neue Bürgermeister heißt Mamdani.
Ja.
Das wusste er 2019, also das Buch schrieb er auch noch nicht, in welche Richtung das so abtrifft. Die 14 Millionen Dollar liegt das Durchschnittsgehalt der CEOs der S&P 500. Die 500 steht für 500 Unternehmen, sind in der Lage dieses Durchschnittsgehalt zu zahlen.
Ich glaube bei DAX Unternehmen sind wir bei in Deutschland, sind wir also bei 6 Millionen.
Also so ein VW-Schiff mit 10 Millionen ist schon viel. Und 10 Prozent der Gesamtgewinne der S&P 1500 Unternehmen geht an die jeweils fünf bestbezahlten dieser Unternehmen. Ja. Es ist einfach. Also hier sind wir jenseits von allem.
Bedeutet also andere bekommen weniger. Und das ist die Mittelklasse. Wir müssen deutlich machen, dieser Autor beschäftigt sich mit den Superreichen und der Mittelklasse. Er beschäftigt sich nicht mit den unteren 50, 60 Prozent. Die interessieren ihn nicht. Das wollen wir ihm hier nicht zum Vorwurf machen. Er sieht die Mittelklasse und die Superreichen leben ein völlig getrenntes Leben. Das war vorher nicht der Fall, weil es diese Art der Reichen nicht gab. Es gab die Rentierkapitalisten, die einfach Kapital hatten und die anderen taten die Arbeit. Aber diese Hardworking-Class an der absoluten Spitze gab es vor einigen Jahrzehnten noch überhaupt nicht. Er hat hier tolle Beispiele, um uns das zu veranschaulichen, wie früher die Arbeitskultur war, zum Beispiel auch bei den Bankern. Man hat sich dann Handbücher angesehen, so Tipps für Banker oder wie man den Alltag gestaltet. Da steht dann drin, man kommt also um 10 Uhr zur Arbeit. Und um 15 Uhr sollte man schon mal den Schalter schließen, damit man um 15.30 Uhr nach Hause kann. Und dann wartet ja auch schon zu Hause die Ehefrau mit einem Drink. Das war die Idee vom Bankerdasein. Das heißt, man arbeitete weniger als die Industriearbeiter. Die mussten nämlich dann bis 17, die mussten oder länger sogar arbeiten. Also 9 to 5 und vielleicht noch Samstagsarbeit. Aber man hat als Banker und in anderen solchen Berufen eben nicht so lange gearbeitet. Heute erfahren wir dann von Bankern, die haben eine 80-Stunden-Woche, eine 100-Stunden-Woche oder sogar eine 120-Stunden-Woche. Warum denn nicht? Was wir hier auch deutlich machen müssen, ist, wenn wir jetzt sagen, also die haben für ihr Geld gearbeitet, dann sagen wir das in Anführungszeichen. Denn natürlich kann niemand so verdienen in dem Sinne, sondern wir sehen ja, hier wird umverteilt. Hier hat sich eine Klasse gebildet, die genau weiß, wie sie die Gewinne auf ihre Seite zieht und nicht nach unten abgeben muss. Aber was wir hier ganz deutlich sehen müssen, was die Arbeitszeiten einbelangt, ist, dass es ein fundamentaler Unterschied zu früher ist. Und wenn wir uns den Diskurs ansehen, zum Beispiel den gewerkschaftlichen Diskurs, der war gestern noch bei der EG Metall in Sprockhöfel, dann haben wir da ja einen Diskurs darüber, könnte man irgendwie die Arbeitszeit verkürzen. Und wir haben das ja auch hier im Podcast immer wieder betont, dass das eigentlich doch sinnvoll wäre. Wäre eine 32-Stunden-Woche möglich. Jedenfalls haben wir es also dort in der Industriearbeit bei den tariflich Beschäftigten mit Menschen zu tun, die zwischen 38 und 40 Stunden arbeiten. Etwa von der Klasse, von der wir jetzt hier reden, also diese meritokratische Klasse, arbeitet 60, 70, 80 und weit mehr Stunden. Und genau deshalb, weil sie so viel arbeitet, hat sie keinerlei Verständnis für Arbeitszeitverkürzungen und hat sie keinerlei Verständnis, dass überhaupt jemand klagt über einen zu niedrigen Lohn, weil sie ja sagen können, seht her, wie hart ich arbeite. Bei mir gibt es keine Sonntage und keine Urlaube. Deshalb habe ich es doch verdient, 30 Millionen Bonus zu bekommen.
Er schreibt nun im ewigen Kampf Kapital gegen Talent. Er nennt es ja nicht mehr Arbeit, gewinnt das Talent. Ja. Und wir sehen ja auch in Deutschland, wie gerade der Bürgergelddiskurs läuft. Der läuft ja nicht über die materielle Schiene, wie wir das nachher bei Linatas nochmal hören, dass die unteren 50 Prozent nur 0,5 Prozent haben. Also wenn man davon nochmal die untersten 10 Prozent nimmt, nichts zu gewinnen gibt. Aber wir lassen das ganz hart über dieses, die sind faul, die gehen nicht hin, die gehen nicht mal zu einem Termin. Die schaffen es einfach nicht. Darüber lassen wir das laufen. Und das ist natürlich prägend, denn die Frage, die hier im Raum steht, er kommt auf Deutschland zu sprechen, gilt das auch für uns. Und ich sage, ja, natürlich. Nur haben wir es in Deutschland immer anders hingekriegt, das zu verstecken. Die Milliardäre sieht man auf der Straße nicht, anders als in Amerika, wo man einfach weiß, wo sie wohnen und die reichenden Stadtviertel haben. Und er beschreibt ja auch, wie quasi alle Uni-Absolventen der Top 5 Unis in fünf Prozent des selben Gesamtgebiets leben. Also wie sie sich schon separiert haben und alle sehen ja Maralago und so. Das kennen wir ja von deutschen Milliardären nicht. Aber ich würde sagen, wir sind ja trotzdem ganz nah dran.
Die Tendenz geht ganz klar in diese Richtung, wenn es auch ökonomisch noch fundamentale Unterschiede gibt. Das können wir mit dem Gini-Koeffizienten ziemlich gut herausarbeiten. Der ist ja bei den Vermögen so, dass der je nach Schätzung bei 73 oder 76 liegt. Und um das nochmal zu sagen, also bei den Punkten bei null Punkten oder einem Punkt wäre alles gleich verteilt an alle. Ja, und bei 100 gehört einem alles. Das heißt, wenn der Gini-Koeffizient bei den Vermögen schon bei 76 ist, dann sehen wir in Deutschland, dann sehen wir, wie extrem ungleich dieses Land ist, was die Vermögen anbelangt. Wenn wir uns den Gini-Koeffizienten bei den Einkommen ansehen, dann ist der bei 32 oder 33 in Deutschland. Und das liegt nur daran, dass in Deutschland ziemlich progressiv besteuert wird. Also man bei einem Singeleinkommen, ich glaube, so ab 80.000 bei einem Grenzsteuersatz von 42 Prozent liegt. Dann nachher gibt es noch die 45 Prozent ab 270.000 Euro. Es gibt ja außerdem noch den Solidaritätszuschlag. Das heißt, da gibt es schon ordentlich Progression. Die Linke hatte ja im letzten Wahlprogramm gefordert, da muss noch mehr Progression her. Kann man diskutieren. Jedenfalls durch diese starke Progression ist es anders als in den USA. Also bei uns schien die Koeffizienz bei 32. In den USA bei den Einkommen bei 49. Da sehen wir schon, wie extrem es ist. Und dann hat sich Markovits noch mal angesehen. Ja, wie ist es denn eigentlich diese Ungleichheit zwischen der Mittelklasse und den Superreichen? Und dann stellt er fest, wie die Ärmeren, die spielen gar keine Rolle mehr in der Rechnung. Die machen gar nicht mehr den Ausschlag, sondern diese Ungleichheit des Genie-Koeffizienten, diese hohe von 49, kommt vor allem durch die Kluft zwischen Mittelklasse und Superreich.
Ja, also was wir hier sehen, wenn wir es jetzt historisch aufschlüsseln, wir haben in den 70ern überhaupt erst diese Containerschifffahrt und Geld, das nicht mehr an Gold gebunden ist in Amerika, wodurch plötzlich unglaublich viel Geld überhaupt zur Verfügung steht für Investitionen, das sofort genutzt wird, um die Werkbank China und so weiter zu nutzen. Dadurch entsteht überhaupt erst der Bedarf an Management, anders als eben der Manager vor 1960, der wie Humann sagt, einfach nur zum Akkord halt aufrief. Also es war sozusagen der Trommelschläger, aber zwar jetzt nicht inhaltlich irgendwas im Sinne von, da es wäre schon gut, wenn das ein Jurist wäre, der sich richtig auskennt oder so. Also erst in den 90ern haben wir diese richtige Computerrevolution, die überhaupt erst ermöglicht, dass man Finanzkonstrukte, Managementmoden entwirft und die dann hintereinander. Also wir haben es mit einer relativ wirklich sagenhaften neuen Entwicklung zu tun, während wir immer alle denken, hey, aber im Fernsehen sind doch immer noch dieselben Superstars wie vor 30 Jahren und Bert Hooger macht auch in zehn Jahren noch Quiz-Shows und so, hat sich hier einfach was komplett gedreht. Und bei den Eigentumsverhältnissen, die wir in Deutschland haben und den Bedarf, den wir jetzt eingeprügelt bekommen, das muss verteidigt werden und es geht nur über gute Bildung, wissen wir einfach, was in Deutschland droht, nämlich genau das, was hier beschrieben wird in diesem Buch. Das ist sozusagen Deutschlands Zukunft. In Amerika ist einmal durch, da wurden die Eigentümschichten jetzt einmal so verteidigt und sagt ja auch, das größte Opfer der meritokratischen Klasse ist die meritokratische Klasse selber. Denn im Raum steht die Frage, ja, macht es Spaß? Und dann ist die Antwort so, nicht so richtig, macht niemand Spaß. Aber es wird halt gemacht, weil es die Zukunft sichert, die Dynastie absichert.
Permanente Angst. Ich habe einen Bekannten, der das Kind auf eine Privatschule schicken will, ist natürlich aus einer Angst heraus.
Ja, das höre ich auch immer wieder.
Und aus diesem Denken, also die Angst liegt vor allem darin, also es wird dann ja manchmal so begründet, ja, sind die öffentlichen Schulen sicher oder so, aber ich glaube die eigentliche Angst ist natürlich, wird das Kind, wenn es 18 ist, im globalen Wettbewerb noch mitmischen können.
Ja, und der globale Wettbewerb ist eben, das Kind muss sich in der Schule gegen 99 Prozent durchsetzen und dann in der Universität noch mal. Ja. Und deswegen kostet es einfach 10 Millionen Euro. Anders kommt man da nicht durch diesen Teufelskreis.
Markovits schreibt, die Leistungsgesellschaft schadet auch der Elite. Eine leistungsorientierte Schulbildung erfordert, dass wohlhabende Eltern Tausende von Stunden und Millionen von Dollar investieren, um ihren Kindern eine Eliteausbildung zu ermöglichen. Und leistungsorientierte Arbeitsplätze verlangen von Erwachsenen der Elite, dass sie mit unerbittlicher Intensität arbeiten und ihre Ausbildung rücksichtslos ausnutzen, um eine Rendite aus diesen Investitionen zu erzielen. Die Leistungsgesellschaft verführt eine ängstliche und unechte Elite zu einem gnadenlosen, lebenslangen Wettstreit, um sich durch eigene übermäßige Fleißigkeit Einkommen und Status zu sichern.
So und ich finde es sehr interessant, dass er diese kleinen historischen, also von Containerschifffahrt und Globalisierung und Computern ist bei ihm nichts zu lesen, aber er macht eben diesen großen historischen Bogenschlag und vergleicht eben Meritokratie, deswegen beschreibt er sie auch so im Vergleich zur Aristokratie und sagt, ja, das ist im Grunde fast dasselbe. Es geht um eine hierarchische, wie soll man sagen, Schichtung der Gesellschaft entlang von Eigentumsverhältnissen. Nur diesmal mit dem Zauberwort Leistung unterfüttert und direkt die erste Überschrift lautet Leistung ist eine Farce. Und das ist wahnsinnig interessant, weil er ist ja auch heute noch dieser Law Professor in Yale, der selber so eine Bildungskarriere hingelegt hat.
Yale, London School of Economics, Harvard und wieder Yale.
Beeindruckend, oder steht vor diesen Studenten und er weiß genau, was mit denen geschieht und er möchte im Grunde diese Zwangslage beschreiben, wohl wissen, dass man da nicht rauskommt und dass jedes historische Ereignis, Corona Krieger, was auch immer, das nur noch mehr verfestigt. Also es ist auch so eine Zwangslage in der er sich, also so eine intellektuelle Zwangslage, dass er da einfach einen Job macht, von dem wir jetzt einfach hören, wie er darüber denkt.
Ich fand es auch so interessant, das genau jetzt zu lesen. Es ist vielleicht wirklich gut, manchmal Bücher ein paar Jahre später zu lesen. Denn das ist ja ein Vor-Corona-Buch. Und wir haben ja diese ganzen Schulschließungen gehabt, bei denen wir immer wussten, naja, für die reichen Leute ist das kein Problem. Die machen den besten Online-Unterrichter so. Ich habe ja auch mit einem Englisch-Lehrer gesprochen, also der Online-Coachings macht ja, der hat natürlich während des Lockdowns zu tun gehabt ohne Ende. Aber natürlich die Kinder der Elite hat er da unterrichtet, während die anderen irgendwie vor einem Laptop mit drei Leuten saßen und nicht wussten, wie sollen sie die Hausaufgaben machen. Niemand ist da in der Familie, der sich darum kümmert. Die Schulen bleiben geschlossen, wir schützen alle, wir bleiben zu Hause, bla, bla, bla. Das bedeutete, dass also damit diese ohnehin schon so existente Kluft noch viel, viel weiter aufgerissen wurde.
Genau, das zum einen. Und es ist interessant, das heute zu lesen, weil wir natürlich so eine KI-Wende haben. Wir selber kennen so einen jungen Juristen, der aus Ostdeutschland heraus eine Praktika in Manhattan macht und so. Und der sagte mir schon 2014 zum Jahresende, ja, mein Juha-Studium war jetzt für ein Arsch. Weil er natürlich auch GBT benutzt.
2024 meinst du.
2024, genau. Also es ist schon ein Jahr her, dass er diese Botschaft hatte. Und es gab jetzt nicht unbedingt Stimmungsaufhellung seitdem. Also diese Leute sehen ja auch, dass, sagen wir mal, wenn man jetzt so eine Minigereal Class hat, also die fürs Eigentum managt und dann aber extrem viel Geld abgrast, die kriegen natürlich jetzt auch andere Befehle vom Eigentum. Weil da einfach Befehle vorbereitet werden, mithilfe von KI. Genauso wie eine Belegschaft von unten jetzt auch ihre Beschlussvorlage schon mal ein bisschen anders formulieren kann. Und man nicht auf das hoheitliche, abgesegnete, der Justizia hat sich gerade die mir geschrieben, auf die wir ewig warten. Also in der Ansicht, kommen die auch wirklich unter Druck. Weil das sind nun mal genau ihre Berufe, die vorher abgeriegelt wurden über Bildung. Und jetzt haben wir eine Pressevorführung nach der anderen, in der Brockman und Altman und so wieder zeigen, wie man jetzt im Vergleich zu den Juristen und dass man jetzt das BA-Examen bewältigt und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist natürlich eine Lage, bei der man wieder einmal feststellen muss, der soziale Wandel, der Strukturwandel, ist so viel schneller, als wir immer glauben. Also der strukturelle Wandel und die Semantik hängen so krass nicht zusammen, dass wir hier einfach sagen, okay, es gab genau so eine Generation, die Eltern hatten gerade das Budget fertig für den Bildungsweg ihrer Kinder. 2019 wird dieses Buch geschrieben. Alle sehen noch mal, oh krass, so hart ist der Wettbewerb wirklich. Und heute, sieben Jahre später, kommen diese Kinder aus diesem 10 Millionen Bildungsweg heraus und die KI kann es besser.
Das werden wir sehen, ob das dann wirklich passiert.
Also die Abriegelung dieses Arbeitsmarktes muss neu erfunden werden.
Ja, ja, die große Herausforderung wird für die sein, wie kann sich diese Professional Managerial Class, die super verdient, wie kann die sich über den KI halb hinaus retten? Und das stellt sich ja dann auch für ihn als politische Frage. Denn wir sind also in der ersten Amtszeit von Donald Trump und so rahmt er das Buch. Er kommt ganz am Ende nochmal auf Trump zu sprechen, aber sonst spielt das fast keine Rolle. Aber am Anfang ist es ganz wichtig, für ihn nochmal zu sagen, die Mittelschicht betrachtet Eliteschulen, Universitäten und professionelle Unternehmen zunehmend als fremde Orte, die bestenfalls exzentrische Werte pflegen und schlimmstenfalls diese Werte allen anderen aufzwingen, als Clubs, die von wertlosen Bücherwissen, politischer Korrektheit und arroganter Selbstbereicherung dominiert werden. Ironischerweise konzentrieren sich diese aus der Ausgrenzung resultierenden Ressentiments, obwohl sie einer tiefgreifenden inneren Logik folgen, oft auf die Form der Inklusion, die die Meritokratie verherrlicht, darunter insbesondere, wie in Beschwerden über politische Korrektheit, die meritokratische Akzeptanz einer multikulturellen Elite. Um das jetzt mal zu übersetzen, wir haben eine Kritik an dieser woken Elite gehabt oder man gesagt, die Elite ist vogue, wenngleich immer schon klar war, naja, gewisse Teile vielleicht an der Universität, aber nicht überall. Es gibt ja ein Succession, diese Hochzeitsparty, ich weiß nicht, ob du die Serie gesehen hast, auch so eine super reichen, auch alle gehören zu dieser meritokratischen Elite. Also alle arbeiten hart und kuchsen, damit es dann auch gut geht, damit man morgen wieder früh antreten kann. Und da geben sie so eine Party. Und so einer kommt hinzu, der nicht so zu dieser Society gehört. Und dann bekommt er auch gleich gesagt, du kannst hier, du muss hier Hamilton nicht gut finden. Also wir sind ja unter uns, du musst dich jetzt hier nicht für diversity interessieren. Also da wird auch schon so gezeigt, naja, die Elite hat das jetzt so mal opportunistisch mitgemacht. Was aber hier entscheidend ist für Markovits, es gibt ja eine Kritik daran und die wurde ja hunderttausendfach bei Joe Rogan vorgetragen. Ja, ja, mit diesen ganzen Quoten. Ich habe ja schon Angst, wenn irgendwo im Vorstand ein Schwarzer sitzt, ist er nur über die Quote reingekommen. Das waren ja so Sätze, die immer wieder bei Joe Rogan fielen. Was die also sagten, war die Elite, die ist ja gar nicht richtig meritokratisch. Die hat ja sowas wie Quotenregelungen für Minderheiten. Die wollen also noch mehr Meritokratie. Und Markovits sagt, nein, nein, die haben das alles nicht verstanden. Aber es verfängt gerade sehr gut. Deswegen sehen sie in Donald Trump und in seinen Leute, die jetzt die Mittelklasse und ihren Status quo vertreten. Die vergessenen Männer und Frauen können sich also jetzt rächen und sagen, diese Elite ist ja gar nicht richtig leistungsorientiert. Und Markovits sagt aber jetzt nicht, ja stimmt, da ist irgendeine Quotenregelung, die ist vielleicht ein bisschen ungerecht. Sondern er sagt, nein, an sich alles auf die Leistung zu konzentrieren, das ist das große Problem, was permanent Verlierer produzieren muss. Und genau das ist das Problem der Mittelklasse. Aber die Mittelklasse selbst kommt aus dem meritokratischen Denken nicht heraus. Was wir ja sehen können, dass wir in Umfragen hier ja auch die arbeitende Klasse, den Industriearbeiter und so weiter haben, die ja vor allem sich über Uni-Quotenregeln und so weiter empören oder über Bürgergeldempfänger, die auch leistungslos ja irgendwo hingekommen sind.
Und von daher ist es auch bedrückend, das Buch zu lesen, denn er spricht von der Falle und man kann über die Falle gut aufklären. Und man sieht aber, dass man da nicht rauskommt. Und zwar genau aus dieser Logik. Dieser Alexander Wang zum Beispiel hat für seine Unternehmen jetzt gesagt, jetzt gilt nicht mehr DEI, also Diversity, Equity und Inclusion, sondern MEI, Merit, Leistung, Excellence und Intelligence. Und das ist natürlich die Klammer, wo sich die unterste Unterschicht und die höchste Oberschicht wieder treffen können. Weil sie sagen, ja, jetzt zählt Leistung.
So, und dann? Und dann glauben sie plötzlich, jetzt werden sie auch mit vertreten von den CEOs.
Genau. Was ja...
Immerhin Anti-Vogue reicht uns.
Genau, also Anti-Vogue, die große Klammer, wird ja auch mittlerweile so ein allgemeiner Begriff für debil, doof und so weiter. Also, dass man einfach so Vogue einpflichtet, in so Sätze, um das zu beschreiben. Nur, was er ja auch ein bisschen kurz beschreibt, nur ist, also er kommt zwar auf diese Arbeitgeber zu sprechen, Goldman Sachs und so weiter. Ich hab mir das mal angeschaut, sie reden ja wirklich von Human Capital Management. Das ist deren Personalabteilung. Und da geht es ausschließlich darum, das Potenzial, das da drin schlummert, zu heben. Sie werben als eine der drei Kennziffern darauf, dass sie nur 5% der Bewerber akzeptieren. Und lauter so ein Zeug. Also wir sind hier, wie Markovits schreibt, in einem gnadenlosen, lebenslangen Wettstreit, der sich gesellschaftlich als Strudel aus gegenseitigen Beschuldigungen, Respektlosigkeit und Dysfunktionalität besteht. Aber halt unter diesem Dogma, der die Bildung ist es. Der Fleiß ist es sozusagen. Da sind wir uns alle einig, egal aus welchen Richtungen und so. Und das ist einfach so eine Zwangslage, bei der ich mich, also auch soziologisch, wirklich frage, also da gibt es einfach keine Aufklärung. Also es gibt keine, also man kann eine innerliche Aufklärung machen, sich darüber informieren, aber das nützt gar nichts. Sobald man den Eltern von Hessen die Frage stellt, möchtet ihr, dass die Schule einfach, so wie in jedem anderen Bundesland, sagt, dass die Empfehlung der Lehrer einfach gilt, weil die das Kind gut kennen. Nein, die Eltern wollen natürlich selber darüber entscheiden, dass das Kind auf das Gymnasium geht und sei es mit 90 Minuten Schulweg verbunden. Also man kommt da einfach, man kann es allen Eltern dieses Zeug hinlegen. Jaja, kommst dann nicht raus.
Das ist das Ding, du kommst nicht raus und wir können dir das schon mal vorwegnehmen, die Lösungsvorschläge, die er da einbringt, die sind kaum der Rede wert, um das ganz offen zu sagen. Das ist ein verzweifelter Versuch, Handlungen vorzutäuschen oder Handlungsmöglichkeiten zu simulieren. Ich sehe da überhaupt gar keine Chance. Und das liegt dann...
Und das sagt Wolfgang, obwohl es auf fast eindeutige, also eins zu eins übernommene Markszitate hinausläuft.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Also er endet ja damit. Die Ketten, die sprengen und so weiter. Und das stimmt dann vielleicht nicht, weil sie die Arbeiterklasse, so Marks und Engels, haben nicht zu verlieren außer ihre Ketten. Aber diese Leute, die so verrückt arbeiten und auf die Frage, wie geht es dir, immer nur antworten, so busy, dass diese Leute dann doch einiges zu verlieren haben, nämlich diesen Status, den sie dort haben. Und er prägt ihre Identität. Also der Beruf und all die Zertifikate, die man erlangt hat, ist die Identität. Da ist nicht noch mal irgendetwas draußen, noch mal etwas externes, sondern es ist die Identität. Und was Markovits nicht leisten will, kann, wie immer man das beschreiben will, ist, dass man eigentlich grundsätzlich beschreiben müsste, wie das System funktioniert, also der Kapitalismus. Und vielleicht können wir das an einem ganz einfachen Bild machen. Selbst wenn sich ja alle anstrengen, dann ist es ja nicht so, dass dadurch Jobs, die benötigt werden, wegfallen. Also um es mal ganz plastisch zu machen, nehmen wir ein Krankenhaus. Jetzt könnte man sagen, wir setzen alles auf Null und alle strengen sich an, die höchste Position da im Krankenhaus zu haben. Selbst wenn sich alle gleich viel anstrengen würden und selbst wenn sie alle gleich viel Talent hätten, es spielt gar keine Rolle, weil es eben nur wenige Chefärzte geben kann, nur einen Klinikleiter, nur zwei Management und nur fünf Fachärzte und dann muss es eben die Leute geben, die pflegen, putzen, an der Pforte stehen, etc. Und so funktioniert im Prinzip unsere gesamte Gesellschaft. Das heißt, sobald ich in diesem Leistungsmodus einmal drin bin und sage, das ist jetzt die letztendliche Begründung für den Status, dann muss ich immer ein System der Verlierer akzeptieren und das wollen die aber nicht akzeptieren und versuchen sich das immer so zu rechtfertigen, mit verloren haben sie, weil sie es nicht verdient haben, hätten sie sich nun mal mehr angestrengt. Aber das ist ein Dilemma, das nicht zu lösen ist, außer mit einer anderen Wirtschaftsordnung.
Ich würde ja da sagen, es ist alles noch viel viel schlimmer, als man bisher so denkt. Denn wir wollen also Flüchtlinge aus Syrien dürfen, wenn überhaupt kommen, wenn sie Ärzte sind.
Jaja.
Nur die Leute wollen aber ihr Paket abends geliefert bekommen und das morgens jemand ihre Brötchen weckt und so. Und während wir alle, ohne dass wir das thematisieren und in Deutschland insbesondere in so eine meritokratische Falle reinlaufen, weil ja einfach niemand einen ernsthaften Diskurs über das Bildungswesen führt, sondern heute schon, also wie du eben meintest, Leute haben Angst und sagen, es ist besser, wenn mein Kind sein Abitur auf einer Privatschule vorbereitet und schreibt. Und dann liest man so in der Zeitung, das machen schon die Hälfte aller Abiturienten in Rostock. Wirklich? Selbst wenn du dich dafür entscheidest, mein Kind geht auf eine Privatschule, könnte es sein, dass du immer noch in dem 51 Prozent und nicht in den Top 10 rumhängst. Leute sind immer wieder überrascht darüber, weil es keine Aufklärung, keinen Diskurs dazu gibt, wie schlimm es eigentlich steht. Und dass diese spontane Lösung, die sie so haben, da kommen andere Älteren auch drauf. Sie sind schon voll im Mittelfeld, während sie denken, ich habe gerade voll die gute Idee, wir melden sie auf einer Privatschule an. Das ist alles schon abgeriegelt. Gleichzeitig hat man einen Migrationsdiskurs, der der ganzen Gesellschaft den Boden entreißt, weil niemand mehr die relevanten Tätigkeiten macht. Und dann kommt noch die KI hinzu. Und ich will es jetzt mal an einem Beispiel beschreiben. Wir betreiben jetzt ein eigenes Diskurs. Ich hatte das damals schon mal für den Aufwachen Podcast, nur da hatte der Anbieter selbst gesagt, du kannst es bei mir hosten, kostet einfach 100 Euro im Monat. Das war mir damals zu teuer. Ist mir jetzt immer noch zu teuer. Aber jetzt kann ich das einfach selber hosten. Nur um das selber zu hosten, brauche ich einen Root Zugang auf meinem Server. Den hatte ich bisher gar nicht, weil ich habe mich das nicht zugetraut, weil da bist du wirklich in dieser, okay, da läuft irgendeine Software, die ich nicht kenne, die ist auch nur per Text zu bedienen. Und wenn irgendwas falsch ist, ist er kaputt. Also das ist Root Zugriff. Also habe ich mir jetzt trotzdem einen bei Hetzner gebucht, weil ich bediene ja nicht den Computer, sondern Claude macht es. Ich sage ja Claude nur, was ich will. Also sage ich Claude, hier, das ist der Server, installiere bitte Discourse. Claude so, ja, das läuft mit Ruby, da braucht man die und jene Voraussetzungen, zum Beispiel Docker. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Ruby. Das ist also eine Software, die hat, ich habe sie mir mal rausgesucht, Yuko Hiro Matsumoto vor 20 Jahren erfunden. Und das Ziel war die Erschaffung der neuen Sprache, eine Synthese aus Elementen, der von ihm geschätzten Programmiersprachen, Perl, Smalltalk, Eiffel, Ada und Lisp. Ich kenne nichts davon. Ich habe diese Namen zum Teil zum ersten Mal gehört. Es geht um funktionale und imperative Programmierparadigmen, die da mal vereinigt werden in einem neuen. Ich habe davon keine Ahnung. Und wir haben trotzdem jetzt einfach diese Ruby Software installiert auf einer Docker-Container-Ecosystem-Entwickler-Umgebung, auf einem Server, der Root-Zugriff hat, also wo man alles sofort kaputt machen kann. Und es macht halt einfach Clot für mich. Kein ITler, der aus irgendeiner Uni nach zehn Jahren und so weiter. Also wir haben jetzt diesen Podcast Werbung gespielt von Procon. Wir schätzen solche Unternehmen oder Besserheit Genossenschaften sehr, weil die halt einfach im Grunde so organisieren, wie wir sagen, ja so kann man mal eine Energiewende organisieren. Alle setzen sich zusammen und fragen, ob ein Windrad eine gute Idee wäre. Wenn nämlich alle darüber entscheiden, ist ein Windrad eine gute Idee. Nur, um diese Werbung hier zu spielen, haben wir mit Agenturen zu tun gehabt, denen wir rechts und links eins um die Ohren hauen mussten, damit das mit den Vertragstexten mal stimmt. Ich bin kein Jurist. Das war die erste Auseinandersetzung mit Agenturarbeiten. Ich habe Claude einfach gefragt, was ist hier die Sachlage usw. Ich würde sagen, das ist ganz gut über die Bühne gegangen. Wir haben dafür keinen Juristen gebraucht, der durch eine Mega-Uni geht. Ich finde, diese Zwangslage verschärft sich nicht nur, dass wir nicht nur ein Buch haben, das schon vor sieben Jahren das Problem beschrieb, sondern dass nun echte Einschläge näher rücken, weil diese Umsätze, auf die die beruhen, ja auch gar nicht mehr da sind. Wir haben ja keinen Anwalt gebucht, wir haben auch keinen IT-Experten, der die ganze Zeit die Software am Laufen hält. Wir sind ja schon wieder in einer ganz neuen Welt, während wir noch nicht mal über diese Meritokratrie richtig aufgeklärt wurden. Da muss man sagen, das ist sehr bedrückend, das zu lesen. Einfach weil man diese ganzen Schicksale, man fühlt ja quasi, wie diese Studenten vor ihm sitzen und sagen, haben sie noch eine Aufgabe? Können ich hier noch, wo soll ich mein Praktikum machen? Urlaub?
Nie. Haben wir noch einen ZDFK.
Ein Tag frei für die Ehe. Das war es. Also wie beim Hochzeitstag, so oder?
Ja.
Und, ah, schlimm. Also es ist wirklich schlimm. Und ja, er macht es trotzdem sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Also wir kriegen schon eine gute inhaltliche Aufklärung. Sie nützt uns nur so wenig.
Ja, also das will ich auch gar nicht als großen Vorwurf artikulieren, dass ich sage, am Ende macht der Vorstecker, mit denen kann man eigentlich wenig anfangen. Das liegt an der Sache. Also er hätte auch einfach sagen müssen, und so ist es, Punkt. Ich glaube, das ist so dieses Konstruktive, jetzt so, wie könnte man da raus? Also er bezieht sich ja mehrfach auf Thorstein Wepplen. Der hat vor über 100 Jahren dieses Buch über die Liège-Klasse geschrieben, über die Freizeitklasse, also die Reichen und ihre Distinktionsmaßnahmen. Wie können sie sich absetzen von denen, die arbeiten müssen? Und da war natürlich, man pflegt Freizeit, man arbeitet wenig oder gar nicht, man hatte irgendwelche obskuren Hobbys, denen man nachgeht, macht einen Sport, den sonst keiner macht, kleidet sich so, dass auch deutlich schon signalisiert wird, in dem Outfit kann man gar nicht arbeiten. Das war das, was Weblen beschrieben hat, aber er hat es einfach nur beschrieben. Und Baudieu knüpft ja eigentlich dann genau an Weblen an. Hier hätte er eigentlich auch einfach sagen müssen, ich beschreibe euch das jetzt, wie es ist. Keine Ahnung, macht mal irgendwas damit. Wäre vielleicht besser gewesen, aber man kann die letzten 30 Seiten sich vielleicht sparen des Buches und hat ein sensationelles Buch dann in den Händen. Denn er zeigt uns erst einmal, wie verändern sich diese Eliten. Und da sind wir bei dem Thema Freizeit. Weit ins 20. Jahrhundert hinein war es eben noch so, dass die Elite fast nicht gearbeitet hat. Heute, ich habe es eben schon gesagt, bei dieser Superordinate Working Class ist es so, dass die alle wahnsinnig viel arbeiten. Die Elite-Universitäten früher waren nicht auf Leistung getrimmt, was man schon daran sehen konnte. Und da hat auch Michael Sendel ja drüber geschrieben. Man war der Sohn eines Alumnens. Und dann wurde man natürlich auch dort angenommen. Es wurden eigentlich kaum Leute abgelehnt, weil man das quasi vererbt bekommen hat. Und da sehen wir auch gleich in uns eine Ungerechtigkeit und sagen, ja, aber das geht ja nicht nur, weil der Vater jetzt in Jail war, warum soll der Sohn da hin? Das wickelt man dann ab. Er geht dann auch auf einige Protagonisten an diesen Elite-Unis ein. Das führt zu dieser meritokratischen Elite, dass man sagt, also nur wer Leistung zeigt, kann auch an so eine Elite-Schule gehen. Aber da kommt man ja nicht einfach nur hin, weil man Talent einfach hat oder einfach fleißig ist, sondern in der Vorschule, in der Elementary School, in der High School, da entscheidet es sich und dort gibt man Geld aus. Pro Jahr zum Beispiel auf der Privatschule 75.000 Dollar pro Schule. Bei den Elite-Colleges dann 90.000 Dollar pro Schüler, pro Jahr. So viel wird dann dort frei gemacht, um eine entsprechende Ausbildung zu haben. Also diese Elite-Unis sind dann mit Geld gepampert. Natürlich ohne Ende und es geht wirklich darum, dass man eine Elite herausbildet, bei der es dann auch wieder klar ist, dass hier vererbt wird, allerdings verknüpft mit der Leistung, wodurch wir nicht mehr diesen Diskurs haben können. Naja, die sind da einfach hingekommen, weil der Papa reich ist. Ja ja, der Papa ist reich, aber die mussten sich schon dann mit dem Geld des Papas quälen. Jeden Tag alle Tutorials machen, die ihnen angeboten wurden, damit sie am Ende alle Zertifikate erlangen.
Genau. So, dieses Buch ist in drei große Abschnitte geteilt. Wir sind jetzt schon sehr wild drin rumgesprungen, aber um Arbeitszeit- und Gehaltsstrukturen und Aufgaben zu thematisieren. Diese Einleitung, so vernachlässigbar die letzten Seiten sind, so gut, finde ich, diese Einleitung geschrieben. Denn in der Einleitung muss man sagen, da hat auch der Verlag gute Arbeit geleistet. Denn man weiß, Meritokratie, die Leute lesen sowieso nicht bis Seite 5, 10. Also handelt man besser mal auf Seite bis 10 schon alles ab. Also er beginnt mit diesem Einleitung, Leistung ist eine Phase. Das Versprechen der Meritokratie ist allenfalls ideell gegeben. Nämlich, dass man irgendwie die privaten Vorteile und die öffentlichen Interessen in Einklang bringen kann. Er beschreibt ja dann auch, wie das so abgefeiert wird bei Abschlussfeiern, was man so sagen muss in so einer commencement speech. Und dann kommt Obama vorbei und erzählt irgendwie, die Welt steht euch offen, aber denkt auch immer an die anderen und so. Also die ganze Idee wird so reingebaut. Nur für wen funktioniert die Meritokratie? Für niemanden. Es ist dadurch, dass diese Frage im Raum steht, ja macht es eigentlich Spaß? Und alle sagen, nee Spaß nicht, aber darum geht es ja hier auch nicht. So man wird also mit Milliarden und Millionen zugeschüttet von Anfang an, also dass man es wirklich ein bisschen runtergedimmt, ja wie so eine Osempic Ladung einfach, dass man das alles irgendwie durchsteht. Wir haben diesen Strudel aus Ressentiment. Er beschreibt ja auch immer die Reichen und der Rest, the rich and the rest. Also wir haben ein Gefüge, bei dem wir nochmal ein Dreiklang machen müssen aus, nicht nur die Mittelschicht und die Armen. Und dann gibt es ein Lohnabstandsgebot oder sowas, sondern nein, die Reichen, die Mittelschicht und die Armen. Und dann kann man die Mittelschicht und die Armen mal, wie er das macht, salopp so. Ja, ja, das ist sowieso uninteressant. Die Reichen und die Mittelschicht, das ist der Unterschied, der hier zu erklären ist. Und relativ früh kommt er da auf Trump zu sprechen und sagt, da kann man einfach eine große Ursache sehen. Schon allein, weil niemand drüber spricht, kommt jemand mit völlig unterkomplexen Sachen, die plötzlich so verfangen. Und man fragt sich, warum eigentlich? Na ja, weil die Gefühlslage halt entsprechend ist. Also, die Meritokratie sagt, er ist eine institutionalisierte Lebenslüge. Und er beginnt diesen Text mit, ich bin ein Meritokrat, ich lehre hier an der Yale Law School, ich habe selber den Bildungslauf gemacht und bin beteiligt daran, die neuen Leute da auszubilden. Und wenn sich Harvard als Zufluchtsort für die ehrgeizigsten Gelehrten der Welt versteht, ja, okay, dann ist das halt so, aber die strukturelle Grundlage ist halt eine andere, als diese Semantik verspricht. Und diese Abklärung der Abschlussfeiern, das ist auch sozialogisch hochinteressant zu lesen, wie er sich auch darüber lustig macht, was da einfach stattfindet, während er selber, seitdem er das Buch schrieb, schon wieder sieben solche Abschlussfeiern mitmachen musste und an jedem Einzelnen die Hand geben, so, viel Spaß jetzt. Da sitzen die Eltern, okay, wir gratulieren hier auch noch mal.
Vielleicht wirst du in 15 Jahren Partner sein.
Genau, werden sie einfach in die Welt geschickt. Der Glanz der Leistungsgesellschaft fesselt die Vorstellungskraft und fesselt den Blick, um kritische Urteilsvermögen zu unterdrücken und Reformen zu ersticken. Ja, und dieser Glanz, ja, das sieht man ja heute, dass Donald Trump es schafft, sich als Medienpräsident so zu inszenieren, dass alle sagen, ja, das funktioniert, weil er den Superarmen vorspielt, wie sie glauben, dass ein Superreicher lebt. Und wir stehen alle daneben und denken, was für ein absurdes Theater. Aber es funktioniert ja. Also haben Leute, die noch Bücher lesen und die noch Zeit für Muse haben, die sich also Gedanken machen. Ja, diese drei Prozent der Leute können sich halt Gedanken machen, aber die Welt ist, wie sie ist. Und hier in dem Buch ist einfach, ist herrlich zu lesen, gerade an solchen Abschlussfeierzeremonien.
Dabei erleben wir eine ungeheure Selbstausbeutung. Da heißt es, im Jahr 1962, als Spitzenanwälte ein Drittel dessen verdienten, was sie heute verdienen, konnte die American Bar Association zuversichtlich erklären, dass einem normalen Anwalt etwa 1300 abrechenbare Stunden pro Jahr zur Verfügung stehen. Heute hingegen erklärt eine große Anwaltskanzlei mit gleicher Zuversicht, dass eine Quote von 2400 abrechenbaren Stunden bei ordnungsgemäßer Verwaltung nicht unangemessen ist, was ein Euphemismus für notwendig ist, um die Hoffnung auf eine Partnerschaft zu haben. Also, wenn man Partner wird, das muss man vielleicht erklären, in einer Anwaltskanzlei, dann hat man so richtig das große Los gezogen.
Dann darf man delegieren.
Dann kann man auch schon mal überlegen, ob man Bentley nimmt oder einen Rolls-Royce. Um 2.400 Stunden abzurechnen, muss man sechs Tage die Woche von 8 Uhr morgens bis 8 Uhr abends arbeiten, ohne Urlaub oder Krankheitstage, jede Woche des Jahres. Absolventen von Elite-Rechtsfakultäten treten in Anwaltskanzleien an, die von ihren Mitarbeitern und sogar Partnern, üblicherweise, eine Wochenarbeitszeit von 60, 80 oder sogar 100 Stunden verlangen. Ich bin am Montag durch Frankfurt gefahren, weil ich da ins Kino bin. Früher, später Nachmittag war das. Und dann sah ich sie, wie sie mal so kurz über die Straße huschten, um vielleicht umgehen zu müssen. Und ich hatte schon einige Seiten des Buches gelesen und dachte so, hallo, ich gehe jetzt ins Kino, viel Spaß noch bei der Arbeit. Das ist eigentlich eine interessante Haltung, die man ja auch dazu einnehmen kann. Und die dazu ermuntert uns ja auch, dass er eigentlich sagt, das sind ja auch ganz arme Leute. Also die verdienen zwei Millionen, aber das sind ganz arme Leute.
Und um da anzukommen, einfach nicht mehr ins Kino gehen zu dürfen, muss man in Yale zum Beispiel sich bewerben. Man ist also dann in einer der Top amerikanischen Rechtsfakultäten. Dort sitzen dann drei Fakultätsmitglieder über diesen Bewertung und klären im Gespräch, wen man aufnimmt. Also hier ist auch einfach so im Sinne von, ne der Vater hat ja gestern eine Million überwiesen oder so, also das kommt da nicht weit. Dieser eine Punkt, den es mal gab, der wurde auch gestrichen. Also es gibt da gar keine einfacheren Regeln mehr, sondern die Eltern müssen dann wirklich ins Kind reingebuttert haben. Aber wenn man dann da ist, gibt die Schule wiederum 75.000 Dollar pro Jahr für die Schüler aus.
Genau das war jetzt eben die Zahl, die hatte ich glaube ich ein bisschen vermischt. Also 75.000 kommt von der Schule pro Schüler. Genau.
Aber man muss dann, also ihr vergleicht das ja mit anderen Zahlen, irgendwelche Wald- und Wiesenuniversitäten, die halt gerade mal so die 7.000 Dollar schaffen. Und ein Vorschulbereich, der halt hier völlig ausgespart ist. Also da kann man ja zumindest in Deutschland auch sagen, okay, man hat so ein Recht auf ein Kita und das heißt, da kommt dann auch schon der Stadtteil zusammen. Und dann kümmert man sich so ein bisschen, das ist hier völlig außen vor. Denn es gibt einfach ein privates Kitasystem. Das ist von Anfang an sowieso abgeriegelt. Dann hat er diese 2.400 abrechnungsfähigen Stunden. Als ich das las, er macht ja dann selber die Aufschlüsselung im Text, wie viele Stunden hat er eigentlich so ein Jahr? So und er kommt dann auf diese sechs Tage jeweils zehn Stunden oder zwei Stunden arbeiten. Er hat ja später Wochenarbeitszeiten, wo man sich denkt, wie viele Stunden hat er eigentlich eine Woche? Die 168 nennt er gar nicht, aber wenn man das dann selber nach googelt, fällt man aus allen Wolken. Also da beschreibt er, wie Leute noch 13 Stunden zum Leben haben, inklusive Schlaf. Das ist sozusagen ein ausgereiztes System.
Also das kennen wir und deswegen ist dieser Bezug, den er immer mal wieder zu Marx herstellt, so interessant. Es gibt zum Beispiel im ersten Band des Kapitals ja dieses Kapitel zur Arbeitszeit, eines der tollsten überhaupt. Und dort beschreibt Marx, wie aus den Arbeitern das Letzte rausgequetscht wird. Und da gibt es die, wie heißt sie, ich glaube Mary, ein ganz tragischer Fall. Also ein Mädchen, das aufgepäppelt wird, immer im Wechsel mit Rum und Kaffee, um weiter arbeiten zu können, bis sie stirbt. Und er schildert uns hier Fälle, bis zur Erschöpfung wird hier gearbeitet. Bis hin dann zu diesem einen Fall, der auch hier ein bisschen durch die Medien ging, von einem, der in London im Investmentbanking war und einfach mit Ende 20 an Erschöpfung gestorben ist, hat dann 120 Stunden und mehr gearbeitet.
Also mehr als die Hälfte der reichsten 1% der Haushalte haben heute ein Familienmitglied, wahrscheinlich immer der Mann, der mehr als 50 Stunden pro Woche arbeitet, während in den unteren die Arbeitszeit durchaus auch gesunken ist, in der Mittelsticht konstant. Aber diese Leute, also er spricht von einer Anwaltskanzlei, in der pro Partner ein Jahresgewinn von 5 Millionen Dollar erzielt wird, also das sind echte Umsätze und von 70 Kanzleien, die es schaffen, pro Partner mehr als eine Million Dollar pro Jahr zu erwirtschaften. Das bedeutet, das Schicksal dieser Unternehmen hängt davon ab, dass diese eine Person, egal wie viel sie dann delegiert und da Führungsspanner hat und so, aber diese eine Person muss ansprechbar sein. Man kann so und so viel Schriftstücke vorbereiten lassen, aber wenn der Klient drei Uhr nachts eine Frage hat, muss dieser Partner ans Telefon gehen. Ja, dafür kriegt man dann zwar sehr viel Geld, also die obersten ein Prozent der Haushalteverein mittlerweile etwa ein Fünftel des Gesamteinkommens auf sich. 0,1 Prozent, ein Zehntel, also es geht um 20 und 10 Prozent, dass sich auf ein oder 0,1 Prozent dieser Arbeiterklasse, aber es ist ja wirklich eine Arbeiterklasse, die dieses Einkommen da auf sich zieht. Und ich habe mir dann auch hier eine Notiz gemacht. Was sagt Marx dazu? Die zunehmende wirtschaftliche Ungleichheit resultiert also nicht in erster Linie aus einer Verlagerung des Einkommens, weg von der Arbeit hin zum Kapital, sondern vielmehr aus einer Verlagerung des Einkommens, weg von der Arbeit der Mittelschicht hin zur Arbeit der Oberschicht.
Ja, um das nochmal aufzugreifen jetzt mit Marx, also das stimmt natürlich. Also zunächst mal kann man sagen, es gibt auch noch sehr viele Menschen, die einfach ihre Renten bekommen, ihre Erträge aus was weiß ich auch immer. Und hinzu kommt ja auch, dass wir es hier mit einer Klasse zu tun haben. Die nimmt ja dieses Geld nicht und verkonsumiert es dann. Die geben ja nicht drei Millionen dann im Jahr aus für Parfums und Schals und Krabatten, sondern die legen das ja an und werden dann zu Kapitalisten schon mal dadurch, dass sie jetzt beispielsweise Aktionäre sind, Anteile an Firmen also besitzen. Aber darüber hinaus kann man ja auch sagen, hat sich also ein System gebildet, wo es natürlich noch die Kapitaleigner gibt, denen die Firmen irgendwie gehören und die haben meistens auch nicht einfach nur diese eine Firma, sondern da wissen wir, das sind so Portfolio-Strukturen, Familienunternehmen, wo wir wissen, das sind gar nicht Familien in dem Sinne noch und Familienunternehmen schon gar nicht. Und jetzt ist es so, dass diese Klasse, die dort so hart arbeitet, also diese obersten fünf oder ein Prozent, dass die ja auf dem Rücken der anderen, die auch ihre Arbeitskraft ausbeuten, also der Mittelklasse, diese Geschäfte machen, wodurch sie in einer interessanten Lage sind, dass sie zum einen wirklich Kapitalisten sind, aber noch im Angestelltenverhältnis. Da kommt man natürlich mit Marx nur noch bis zum gewissen Punkt, weil Marx das nicht voraussehen konnte. Aber die sind auf jeden Fall nicht so einzuschätzen, dass man jetzt auf eine grundsätzliche Formel kommen kann, wie man das vielleicht vor Jahrzehnten getan hat. Alle, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen, sind Arbeiter und alle anderen sind die Kapitalisten. Das geht so nicht mehr, sondern wir haben mit dieser neuen Elite haben wir nach wie vor auch normale Kapitalisten oder traditionelle Kapitalisten und dann gibt es eben die, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen, aber zugleich auch davon leben, dass sie die anderen, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen, ausbeuten können für ihre Gewinne. Und das beschreibt er ja sehr gut, wie die es eigentlich dann auch geschafft haben, dass diese, zum Beispiel industrielle Arbeit, eigentlich die ganze relevante Arbeit abgewertet wird und durch die Finanzialisierung, durch all dieses Management und so eine enorme Aufwertung erfahren hat, also diese oberste Spitze, was dann eben dazu führt, dass die Gewinne irgendwo hingewandert sind. Was man dann daran sehen kann, der Bankdirektor in den 60er Jahren verdiente das 50-fache des Bankangestellten und heute verdient er das 1000-fache.
Und da ist eben auch, also Jamie Dimon, sagt er hier, JP Morgan war ja mal die quasi Zentralbank Amerikas, also durchaus auch eine Bank, die man so braucht irgendwie als größter Bank sowieso. Und Jamie Dimon verdient heute 29,5 Millionen. Jetzt sagt er, das ist 1000-mal so viel. Was ja bedeutet der normale Bankangestellte. Also der es schon geschafft hat, bei einer Bank zu arbeiten, kriegt 30.000 im Jahr für allgemeinen Publikumsverkehr. Und er beschreibt ja später auch, diese Leute haben zum Beispiel damit zu tun, Kredite zu geben für Leute, die ein Haus bauen wollen. Und die haben gar nichts mehr damit zu tun, dass diese Leute ein Kredit kriegen für ein Haus. Sondern diese nur noch ausführendes, also Human Capital muss dann gemanagt werden, damit dieser Auszahlungsprozess stattfindet. Aber entworfen wird dann natürlich oben, wo so abstrahiert, einfach über ganz Amerika, so machen wir das jetzt, gespannt wird. Und es auch gar nichts, und das beschreibt ja auch bei McDonalds, es gar kein Wissenstransfer mehr gibt.
Nein, null.
Ah ja, da unten hat jemand die Schicksalhaftigkeit einer Familie, braucht jetzt ein Kinderzimmer, also ein Haus, und es wird so ein bisschen, nee, da wird nichts mehr eingepreist. Also einfach Zahlen-Salat und dann sagt die Maschine, das machen wir. Also Management und Maschine sagen, das machen wir und da unten ist das ausführende Organ, das heißt für ein Tausendstel des Chefs einfach das Geschäft auch wirklich ausführt. Das ist exekutive Organ.
Was bedeutet, der hat auch keinen Handlungsspielraum mehr, der normale Banker angestellt hat. Der kann nicht sagen, ach, den kenne ich schon so lange, der ist aber wirklich ein Vernünftiger, der bekommt den Kredit. Nee, der gibt was ein und dann...
Nee, der gibt von oben ein Formular vorgegeben und dann unterm Strich zählt, was da steht. So und dieser Separatismus, gerade in Bezug auf Marks Theorieangebot, ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, weil zum einen haben wir diesen Shift von Kapital zur Arbeit und auf der anderen Seite haben wir selten mehr Klassenstruktur gesehen als hier. Also was hier beschrieben wird, ist ja, okay, es kommt den Fleißigen entgegen, dass jetzt das dynastische Prinzip von in Yale bekommt man einen Punkt zusätzlich, wenn man Alumnikind ist. Das ist gestrichen. Führt aber trotzdem nicht dazu, dass da irgendeine Öffnung stattfindet, sondern er schreibt, dennoch umfasst die Studentenschaft ebenso viele und in manchen Jahren sogar mehr Studenten aus Haushalten, die zu den obersten 1% der Einkommensverteilung gehören, als aus der gesamten unteren Hälfte. Also es bewerben sich so viele und werden erfolgreich angenommen aus den unteren 50% wie aus dem 1% da oben. Obwohl es diesen Alumnipunkt so gar nicht mehr gibt. Also das muss halt jetzt inhaltlich hergestellt werden. Diesen Punkt gibt es nicht mehr, also muss der Punkt über die Leistungsfähigkeit des Kindes einfach kommen.
Ja, also noch mehr drillen, noch früher anfangen, noch mehr lernen, mehr Bereitschaft zeigen.
Genau und das schlägt sich dann nieder in dieser Einkommensstruktur. Während sich die Einkommen der obersten 1% verdreifacht haben, ist das reale Medianeinkommen seit 1975 um etwa ein Zehntel gestiegen. Also verdreifacht heißt 300% Medianeinkommen haben der Mittelklasse um 10% gestiegen. Und seit 2000 ist das Medianeinkommen praktisch gar nicht mehr gestiegen. Also das sind einfach dafür, dass wir hier so viele Diskurse über wer macht die eigentliche Arbeit? Na ja, Migranten. Die bauen die Häuser und machen den Service-Dienstleistungen. Und oben werden so Ideen entworfen. Und dann haben wir aber so eine Verquickung aus. Von oben kommen aber die Ideen, die die Debatte unten prägen. Nämlich bitte fleiß und keine Ausländer. Das ist einfach eine Schieflage, während gleichzeitig das, was Marx beschrieben hat, über einen anderen Weg so hart betoniert wird. Also so wirklich unzerstörbar. Einfach so ein Rekrutierungssystem in ein gesellschaftliches Schichtungssystem eingewoben wird.
Was bedeutet auch, dass man als Mittelklasse in der Welt der Reichen sich nicht mehr zu Hause fühlen kann. Man kann es sich einfach nicht leisten. Er kommt auf im zweiten Kapitel dann auf St. Clair Shores zu sprechen, eine Stadt in Michigan. Und da sind die Restaurants nicht so wahnsinnig toll. Ist also ein bisschen ja normal. Da kann man Burger essen und Pizza. Da ist eine Bibliothek, die schon was heruntergekommen. Und wenn dort von dort aus jemand auf eine Elite College geht, dann steht das in der Zeitung.
Schon wenn er sich nur bewirbt. Aber wenn er sich nur bewirbt, kommt gleich die lokale Zeitung und sagt wow, da haben wir wieder einen.
Warum beschreibt er diese Welt? Nun, da ist noch Mittelklasse und da kann man so ein Mittelklasseleben führen. Aber man sieht überall diesen Abstieg. Das ist nicht mehr so toll, denn so viele sind schon wieder weiter runtergerutscht. Also die Mittelklasse, du hast es schon beschrieben, da gibt es kein Lohnwachstum mehr. Und dann kann man ganz abrutschen. Und er bringt ja auch hier wieder das Thema Tod aus Verzweiflung. In diesem Kapitel die Opioid-Krise, die Suizide, wie sie zunehmen, dass sich von 1999 an bis 2016 die Drogen-Toten versiebenfacht haben. Das schildert er. Aber er beschreibt jetzt, in diesen St. Clair-Champs, in dieser Stadt, kann man noch ins Restaurant gehen und kann sich noch wie Mittelklasse fühlen, ein bisschen, wenn man das Mittelklassegehalt hat. Während, wenn man in eine der angesagteren Städte geht, man genau nicht mehr einfach in ein Pizza-Essen gehen kann, in ein Burger-Essen gehen kann. Denn dort ist es so immens teuer geworden, dass man die ganze Zeit merkt, ja, komme ich eigentlich nicht mehr vor, hier finde ich keinen Platz mehr, ich kann auch hier nicht mein Auto jetzt parken, es ist einfach zu teuer, wie soll ich mir das leisten können? Also muss man sich in diese Provinz zurückziehen und kann da noch simulieren, als würde man zur Mittelklasse gehören. Man tut es aber eigentlich schon nicht mehr so richtig, beziehungsweise die Mittelklasse ist eben jetzt ein relativ bärungsreiches Leben. Man ist jedenfalls nicht mehr in einer Welt, wo man früher mit denen, die übereinstanden essen gehen konnte. Und das muss man sich, glaube ich, auch für Deutschland klarmachen. Natürlich waren reichere Leute immer reicher. Das ist so. Aber wenn man sich so die Lebenswelten ansieht, wenn ich jetzt auch an meine Familie denke, also mütterlicheseits, väterlicheseits, wo auf der einen Seite ein bisschen mehr Geld da war, auf der anderen Seite weniger, dann waren aber die Lebenswelten sehr gleich. Also dann hat man, dann konnte also der einfache Arbeiter und der Zahnarzt, um jetzt einen konkreten Fall aus meiner Familie zu nennen, aus den 60er-, 70er-Jahren, die haben sich durchaus gesehen in der Wirtschaft und auch in einem Restaurant. Und dann mag das sein, dass man am Tegernsee Urlaub machte und dann ging der Zahnarzt in das bessere Hotel als der Arbeiter. Aber grundsätzlich hat man schon an einem Ort Urlaub gemacht, wo man gemeinsam hat von erzählen können, wenn man wieder zurück war, während man jetzt in einer Situation ist, wo die Welten vollkommen voneinander getrennt sind. Genau.
Und wie er das beschreibt, ist ja wirklich sehr drastisch, weil es auf der einen Seite so sozio-logisch aufgeklärt und dann wieder so menschlich dramatisch einfach. Also zu diesem Separatismus. Das Muster der nicht mehr vorhandenen sozialen Mobilität bedeutet heute nur eines von hundert Kindern, die in den ärmsten 20 Prozent der Haushalte geboren werden und weniger als eines von 50 Kindern, die in der mittleren in den mittleren 20 Prozent geboren werden, wird jemals reich genug sein, um zu den obersten 5 Prozent zu gehören. Was bedeutet, klang jetzt ein bisschen kriptisch und klar komplizierte Zahlen, aber die wirtschaftliche Ungleichheit führt heute zu einer größeren Bildungsungleichheit als einst die amerikanische Apartheit. Also die Rassentrennung über Jahrzehnte hat nicht so ökonomische Folgen gezeigt, wie heute zwischen Manhattan und diesem St. Clair-Shore. Und da muss man sich so, okay, was hatten wir damals alles als Gegenbewegung für diese offensichtliche Benachteiligung, was für große auch kulturelle Erzeugnisse, die daraus erwachsen sind, Martin Luther King, ganze Jugendbewegungen, eine ganze Pop-Kultur. Genau, und heute sieht man genau gar nichts dazu. Also gar keine Behandlung. Sondern wir sehen einfach nur, und jetzt Manhattan, ja, also Restaurants sind teurer, wenn 200.000 Leute in der Stadt 400.000 Euro verdienen, für 100.000 Dollar so, dann hat es einfach Folgen. Was bedeutet, fast 30.000 Schüler nehmen beispielsweise an der Aufnahmeprüfung für die acht elitären Fachgymnasien in Manhattan teil und konkurrieren um etwas mehr als 5.000 Plätze. Diese 30.000 sind ja schon die ausgesiebten. Das sind ja schon die aus dem ersten Durchlauf, hier musst du gegen 99 Prozent bestehen und dann kommen sie in den zweiten und bewerben sich auf diese Fachgymnasien in Manhattan. Und es sind immer noch sechs Mal zu viel. Also hier ist sich einfach niemand sicher, dass man diesen Platz hat. Und er kommt immer wieder darauf zurück und beschreibt es hier auch. Die Leistungsgesellschaft ermöglicht eine dynastische Nachfolge, aber sie erlegt ihre Dynastien eine schwere menschliche Steuer auf. Und das ist eben dieses, sagen wir mal, Lebenssinn, Lebensglück der Kinder. Einfach eine menschliche Steuer.
Das trifft man in der Aristokratie, wenn man zu den Reichen zählte, einfach Glück. Dann konnte man sagen, ah wunderbar.
Das war Geburtslotterie, genau.
Wir schauen mal, was ich am liebsten mache. Werde ich Golf spielen oder werde ich ein bisschen malen in der Mußezeit? Aber es wird eigentlich ganz angenehm werden.
Also er spricht von dem nie endenden Kampf, in dem sich die Elite selbst gefangen nimmt.
Weshalb sie auch, also ich glaube, damit haben wir auch noch mal sehr gut begriffen, warum unsere Debatten so merkwürdig geführt werden. Nicht nur gegen Bürgergeldempfänger, sondern auch gegen jede gewerkschaftliche Bestrebung, jeden Studenten, der sich äußert, man sollte doch vielleicht weniger arbeiten oder so. Das sind Leute, die haben eine solche Härte antrainiert bekommen, dass sie die natürlich in die Außenwelt abgeben und sagen, dort ist der absolute Kampf. Und wenn du denen nicht durchstehst, diesen Kampf, so wie ich es getan habe, dann hast du einfach versagt und du gehörst nicht dazu. Das heißt, diese Leute sind überhaupt nicht willens, aus diesem ideologischen Paradig mal auszubrechen und glorifizieren dann aber so mal kurz die Familie. Also wir haben das ja auch bei Bernard Arnaud, jetzt kürzlich gehört, dass ich die Clips gespielt habe. Da wird dann von jedem nochmal, der dann eine Rede auf Bernard Arnaud hält, betont, dass Bernard Arnaud sich samstags mit seiner Familie immer zum Land trifft. Das ist ganz toll, dass man sagt Mensch dieser Zusammenhalt, wie wunderbar. Aber man kann sich denken, was diese Elite ihren Kindern angetan hat, damit sie jetzt auch die entsprechenden Jobs erfüllen kann, die entsprechenden Zertifikate vorweisen kann.
Hier gibt es so ein Szenario, von dem ich denke, das ist so, also es zeigt so eine Art von Pervertierung, weil man wirklich wieder zurückgeworfen wird. Also die Anbahnung ist Folgendes, er beschreibt so Lebensläufe. Als Zweijähriger kommst du in die Episkopal School, wirst da von deinen Eltern eingeschrieben, danach lernst du bei Dorton, Princeton, morgen Stanley, gehst zurück auf die Harvard Business School, landest dann schließlich bei Goldman Sachs, verdienst da also was weiß ich 800.000 Dollar im Jahr oder so was. Verwendest dein ganzes Geld darauf, weil du brauchst ja 10 Millionen innerhalb von 20 Jahren, um deinen eigenen Nachwuchs wieder. Allein Nachhilfe in Südkorea, Vorbildhaft, 12 Prozent des Haushaltseinkommens, nur für Nachhilfe. So Goldman Sachs, da kommt es dann an. Die ganze Firma besteht nur daraus, der Öffentlichkeit zu verkaufen. Wenn ihr unsere Dienste bucht, kriegt ihr die klügsten Köpfe der Welt. Wir entwickeln sie für euch die ganze Zeit. Also hier ist Human Capital Management. So und dann beschreibt er ein Szenario, in dem eine Bewerberin für das Yale College selber stolz darauf ist, eine Geschichte zu erzählen, wie sie mal in einem intellektuellen Gespräch gefesselt war. Und sie war so überzeugt davon, dass man das Gespräch jetzt nicht verlassen darf, dass sie sich in die Hose pinkelt. Das sind die neuen Aushängeschilder für die Lastungsgesellschaft.
Ja, exzellente Schafe.
Also hier kommt man ja wieder auf so ein elementares, ekelhaftes Zeug zurück.
Also wir wissen von Amazon-Arbeitern, die müssen in Flaschen pinkeln. Und der nächste Schritt ist, man darf gar nicht.
Also Jeff Bezos beschreibt für die Amazon-Leute, wie sie arbeiten müssen. Und in einem Investors Call oder bei irgendeiner Veranstaltung beschreibt er, die Leute können hier, wie heißt es, exzellent, lange oder klug arbeiten oder sowas. Und es gibt keinen Grund, nur zwei von den Sachen zu wählen. Sondern hier muss einfach geackert werden und zwei Uhr nachts ist man anrufbar, trotzdem acht Uhr morgens wieder auf der Arbeit oder sechs Uhr morgens und so weiter und so fort. Also Amazon finde ich da auch sehr bezeichnend, weil es hat auch sowas von dem Alexander Wang, dass man, und wir haben immer diese Kritik über, in den Häusern muss man so viel laufen. Aber ne, das ist halt nur die eine Seite. Das Management steht da genauso unter Druck. Also da gibt es überhaupt gar niemanden, der irgend wem von irgendwas entlastet.
Ein völlig toxisches System.
Ganz gruselig darüber zu lesen.
Aber das ist so wichtig, dass wir das mit jetzt in unseren Diskussionen immer einführen, da wir ja noch sehr leicht jetzt, ich denke da jetzt auch gerade so an Linkspartei oder so, dabei sind zu sagen, wir machen das so über das Leistungsthema. Die Reichen leisten nichts. Und das verfängt natürlich nicht besonders gut dann vielleicht, wenn man sieht, ne, ne, die sind eigentlich in einer Leistungsfalle gefangen, wie Markovits das beschreibt, was auch bedeutet Mental Health. Wer nennt da die Silicon Valley Schule? 54 Prozent der Schüler dort haben Depressionen. 54 Prozent.
Naja, die Arbeitslogik der eine Fortune 500 Manager. Manche Leute brennen aus, werden seltsam, weil sie die ganze Zeit arbeiten. Die Leute an der Spitze sind sehr klug, arbeiten wie verrückt und brennen nicht aus. Sie sind immer noch in der Lage, eine gute mentale Einstellung zu bewahren und ihr Familienleben aufrechtzuerhalten. Sie gewinnen das Rennen. Also man hat das Rennen gewonnen, aber alles verloren. Das sind ja auch erstaunlich stabile Familien.
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt gleich zu kommen.
Und da würde ich sagen, das ist halt aus Alternativlosigkeit. Also die werden wirklich wie verheiratete Paare in der Aristokratie in diese Ehen reingezogen.
Ja, es gibt keine Alternative. Man muss als Yale-Absolvent auch eine Harvard-Absolventin heiraten und muss dann überlegen, wie man das geschickt macht mit den Kindern. Ja, auf diese Familiengeschichte müssen wir gleich zu sprechen kommen. Er hat auch für diese meritokratische Klasse, die sich ja dann ihre eigenen Finanzprodukte schafft. Also er zeigt ja diese Finanzialisierung. Wie konnten die das eigentlich schaffen? Also die Einkommensschutzindustrie, Income Defense Industry, die entsteht dort und die dichtet sich immer weiter gegen die Mittelklasse ab.
Und das finde ich aber soziologisch super einfach zu erklären, denn wir haben ja dieses Zauberwort der Autopoesis. Also wenn Systeme einmal eine operative Schließung haben, dann machen sie das halt. Und wenn man jetzt historisch zurückgeht, die Siebziger haben diese Containerschifffahrt, plötzlich heißt es, wir müssen eine Werkshalle managen, die ist 17.000 Kilometer weit entfernt. Wie machen wir das eigentlich? Na ja, da müssen wir jetzt halt mal so drüber nachdenken. Also kommen so Management-Ideen auf, wie man das macht. Damit auch die erste Verherrlichung. Also Onkel Egon ist so wichtig, der fliegt zweimal die Woche nach China. Also so dieses, was macht er da? Er steht in so einer Werkhalle und versucht, den Akkord durchzupauken. Und er muss es ein bisschen clever machen, weil er immer weiß, er ist jetzt eine Woche nicht da. Er kann also nicht alle zur Arbeit peitschen und in einer Woche muss es dann wieder hinhauen. Die haben also da noch echte Aufgaben, weil die Produktion muss stimmen und so weiter und so fort. Und dieses System des Remote-Managements, des maschinengetriebenen Irgendwas, wir brauchen die Strategie und so weiter, hat dann irgendwann sein Eigenleben, weil es ging ja immer nur um Profite. Und jetzt geht es halt weiterhin um Profite. Nur, dass sich Fluggesellschaften in Investmentsfonds verwandeln und Universitäten, die eigentlich Public Charity machen, so in keine Ahnung was, also, dass sich jeder so ein bisschen verändert. Und am Ende heißt es, ja, unser Management hat gesagt, das ist voll die kluge Idee, wenn wir 90% der S-Klassen erstmal von der Mercedes-Benz-Bank kaufen lassen, weil dann machen die da irgendwas mit. Und dann haben wir so einen Lobbyismus und er holt dann nochmal die Staatskohle rein und dann geben wir das als Dienstwagen raus und dann ist es nur Leasing 400 Euro im Monat. So, das sind natürlich, also wer so auf so eine Idee kommt, da ist natürlich mit der Herausforderung, ja, kannst du bitte mal mein Einkommen, mein Vermögen defenden. Es liegt ja auf der Hand, dass dann einfach, wie er schreibt, Banker, Wirtschaftsprüfer, Rechtsanwälte und andere Fachleute mal Sachen machen. Und das ist ja auch...
Und Warren Buffett dann weniger Steuern zahlt als sein Sekretär.
Ich habe nochmal nachgelesen, dieser John Paulson, der damals in der Finanzkrise Finanzvehikel mitentwickelte, in der Bank propagierte, dass man die jetzt nach außen verkaufen soll, um dann auf deren Verlust zu wetten, hat 5 Milliarden Dollar in diesem Krisenjahr 2008 gewonnen. Das geht überhaupt nur, wenn man das alles selbst gestaltet. Also wenn man so richtig King of the Game ist und gegen alle anderen ein System entwickelt und man der Einzige ist, der halt Einfluss hat, diese juristischen und finanziellen Strukturen überhaupt so aufzubauen. Und dann kann man 5 Milliarden und alle stehen daneben und sagen, das ist der King of Cash. Lass uns Filme machen. Das muss verherrlicht werden. Und es bricht alles zusammen.
Es liegt natürlich auch stark daran, dass diese Unternehmen so losgelöst sind von ihren Inhabern. Also die Inhaber, dass überhaupt nicht mehr einhegen können, sondern die haben sich eigentlich ja bedingen sich da ihre Rente aus. Die bekommen sie. Das ist Teil des Portfolios. Natürlich, da muss man was bekommen. Aber was dort eigentlich im Management passiert, wissen die überhaupt nicht mehr. Das ist dann ein völlig losgelöstes System oder weitgehend losgelöstes System, das im Übrigen den Leistungsgedanken überall sieht. Weshalb zum Beispiel er hier mal vergleicht, wie ist es mit Beamten. Beamte verdienen relativ wenig, auch wenn sie Spitzenbeamte sind. Er sagt dann sogar, so ein Fettchef verdient eigentlich relativ wenig, 200.000, 250.000.
Weniger als das 1.000 gehaltene.
Jetzt gab es ja gerade in der Bildzeitung ganz groß, dass Christine Lagarde wohl 700.000 verdient haben soll, obwohl das eigentlich doch weniger sein müsste. Das ist natürlich alles nichts gegen das, was da bei Goldman Sachs oder so gezahlt wird. Und diese Beamten aber sind wunderbar für diese Industrie, weil diese Beamten werden dann irgendwann rekrutiert. Er sagt, dass der Beamtenstaat ja vorurteilslos ist und deshalb auch die ideale Rekrutierungsstelle ist für vorurteilsfreie Akteure. Er sagt dann beispielsweise auch bei der ganzen Frage um Gleichberechtigung und so. Bei denen spielt das Ressentiment, weil sie es als Beamte schon abtrainiert bekommen haben, nicht mehr die Rolle. Und dann sind sie wiederum geeignet, um in diesen Unternehmen zu arbeiten, wo es ja auch nur um Leistung geht und nichts anderes. Die geschäftsführende Partnerin, der hypereditären und konservativen Anwaltskanzlei, Kravath, ist beispielsweise heute eine Tochter pakistanischer Einwanderer, sodass es keine Untergruppe der Superfähigkeiten mehr gibt, die durch Chauvinismus gezwungen ist, sich dem Reichtum zu widersetzen, anstatt ihm zu dienen. Das heißt, wer sich also der Meritokratie unterwirft, der kann sicher sein, dass er sonst nicht mehr gegen Vorurteile kämpfen muss. Wenngleich das 2019 ist, wir wissen schon nicht mehr, wie das heute bei dieser neuen von Donald Trump intronisierten Elite ist. Dort spielen ja genau diese Dinge jetzt wieder eine Rolle, weshalb das natürlich auch an dem Personal, das Trump direkt umgibt oder auch bei Peter Thiel und sonst wo anzutreffen ist, ja sehr deutlich sichtbar ist, wie wenig divers es dann wiederum werden kann. Und er sagt ja auch, da droht jetzt durch diesen Populismus von Trump, etwas noch Schlimmeres zu kommen. Also Meritokratie und dann noch so eine dunkle Seite, die hinzukommt, also die auch zugleich noch all die anderen Ressentiments doch noch mitbringt.
Ja, da kommt ja immer auf die Gesamteinnahmen da zu sprechen. Also Trump ist natürlich möglich, wenn diese Entfremdung, auch ein Marksgrundbegriff, den man hier mal ganz wichtig nehmen muss, stattfindet. Also es gibt eine Eigentumsklasse, die möchte, dass ihr Geld einfach mehr wird. Und denen ist relativ egal wie, die lassen sich einfach von den angesprochenen Bankiers, Wirtschaftsprüfer und so weiter die Bilanzen vorlegen. Und dann steht da einfach, du bist dieses Jahr drei Milliarden reicher geworden. Dann sagen die, aber zwei Milliarden davon hätten wir gerne. Also dir bleibt eine Milliarde für nichts tun. Dann sagen die, okay. Und er summiert das ja hier auf. Also die Gesamteinnahmen der 100 größten Anwaltskanzleien beliefen sich 2017 auf 90 Milliarden Dollar. Also einzelne Anwaltskanzleien, die im fast 10-stelligen Bereich im Schnitt, also da werden schon einige dabei sein, die so im 2-stelligen Milliarden-Bereich Gewinne verbuchen. Hinzu kommt Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften die 134 Milliarden Dollar. Und da geht es ja nur um vier. Da gibt es ja nur die großen vier. Und die zehn größten Investmentbanken machen also zusammen 250 Milliarden Gewinn. Das ist Geld, das ist, wie du es jetzt schon von den Beamten, den sozusagen der Publikums, also die Emotionalität im Kontakt mit dem Publikum schon austrainiert wurde, die da ankommen. Er hat ja noch ein anderes Argument und sagt, ja, das ist halt die Folge von diesen, da sind Physiker, die den Kalten Krieg gestalten müssen. Und dann ist aber kein Kalter Krieg mehr da. Was machen die Physiker? Gehen alle in die Banken und entwickeln solche Dinge. So, hier gibt es ja gar kein Publikumsverkehr. Also hier gibt es ja wirklich nur Bilanzierung. Und dann Pfeile nach oben, Pfeile nach unten. Und dieses Eigenleben, und das dann für die Entwicklung seitdem das Buch entstand, weil wir jetzt wissen, dass Trump wieder kam, ist halt so wahnsinnig interessant, weil wir dieses Szenario haben, dass diese Superreichen, da beschreibt ja auch zwischenzeitlich Bill Clinton und George W. Bush aus ihren unterschiedlichen, also Bill Clinton, der war aus Arbeiter, zusammen hinkommt, aber seine Tochter natürlich schon nicht mehr. Also eine Generation hat es gedauert, um das abzuriegeln. Und diese Leute halten also in diesen Universitäten diese Abschlussreden und erzählen dann irgendwas von der Verantwortung und man sollte ja auch mal und so weiter und so fort. Und bitte immer die Privilegien hinterfragen. Also übernehmt Verantwortung, hinterfragt euch selbst. So dann werden diese Privilegien, weil sich alle so umgucken, irgendwie so an, weil wir weiß und männlich sind oder so gebunden. So gleichzeitig hören aber Leute davon, dass sie ihre weißen männlichen Privilegien hinterfragen sollen, die eigentlich kurz vor dem Death of Despair stehen. Also da ist auch einfach eine Diskurslage, die nicht aufzulösen geht. Weil einfach 90 Prozent der weißen Männer haben diese Privilegien gar nicht, von denen sie die ganze Zeit im Fernsehen sehen, dass man die jetzt mal und so weiter.
Ja und das ist ja genau das Problem gewesen, bei, sagen wir mal so, den Hillary Clinton-Bogen, so will ich sie jetzt mal nennen. Dass sie ja eigentlich sich immer gerichtet haben, gar nicht an irgendeine Elite, sondern immer an normale Leute, die dann gedacht haben, hä, Privilegien? Wusste ich gar nicht, habe ich gar nicht gemerkt bislang. Und die Clintons sind ja so ein interessanter Fall. Also er beschreibt dann Bill Clinton normal aufgewachsen, also nicht arm, aber normal aufgewachsen. Und dann George W. Bush reich aufgewachsen, aber die Lebenswelten waren sehr ähnlich. Das heißt, der eine hat zwar in einem größeren Haus gewohnt, aber man hat eigentlich sehr ähnlich gelebt. Wenn man sich aber dann ansieht, dieser nächste Sprung, also Chelsea Clinton, die Tochter oder auch die Kinder von George W. Bush heute, die haben genau diese Elite-Ausbildung, nur Elite-Welt kennengelernt, Elite-Partner geheiratet und sind nie mit irgendeiner Mittelklasse je in Berührung gekommen. Also diese eine Generation war das Entscheidende und viele Politiker drängt es deshalb auch, irgendwie da mitzumischen in dem großen Spiel. 1970 wurden nur 3% der ausscheidenden Kongressmitglieder Lobbyisten. Heute sind es 42% und bei den Senatoren 50%. Alle in den Lobbyismus. Insofern kann man sagen, wie er es hier formuliert, Populismus ist kein spontaner Ausbruch, böswilligere Sentiments, sondern vielmehr eine natürliche und sogar angemessene Reaktion auf extreme meritokratische Ungleichheit. Trump ist für die a blue-collar-Billionär, also jemand, der die Mittelklasse verkörpert, obwohl er es nicht ist. Und Obama hingegen ist der meritokratische Triumph.
Genau. Ja, also das kriegt man eigentlich, also gefühlsmäßig kann man das total nachverziehen, aber man kriegt es sachlich nicht fundiert. Und schlägt sich halt in eindeutigen Zahlen nieder, also der Wahlerfolg der ersten Trump-Regentschaft in den 50 am wenigsten gebildeten Bezirken, also das kennen wir ja in Deutschland auch so, wenn wir dann die thüringischen Landkreise sehen, wo die AfD so erfolgreich ist, hatte Trump 31% Vorsprung demgegenüber in den 50 am besten gebildeten Bezirken und die werden ja auch genannt, also da, wo sie alle hinziehen, die aus diesen Unis kommen, hat er 26% Rückstand gehabt. Also eindeutiger kann man es gar nicht runterbrechen. Das sind ja wirklich glasklare, dass hier Gefühlswelten und strukturelle Welten nicht zusammenpassen und das Wahlergebnis eindeutig erklären. Also hier gibt es gar keine andere Erklärung, die irgendwie plausibel ist, wenn man sagt, nee, das ist die meritokratische Falle einfach. Und zwar im Denken aller, auch derjenigen, die nicht selber als Superreiche da drin sind, sondern als ausgeschlossene daneben stehen und sagen, ja, der Fleiß und das Weißsein und überhaupt. Also in der Ansicht mal eine ziemlich eindeutige Rückbindung auf die politische Sachlage, die uns ja als weltweit betrifft. Also solche Spurenz, die wir jetzt in Venezuela haben, haben genau damit zu tun, dass irgendwelche Leute ihre Biografie nicht verwirklicht sehen.
Die Hochvermögenden, 56 Prozent von ihnen, arbeiten 70 Stunden und mehr. Jetzt mal zu dieser Kluft. Die Kluft zwischen den Freizeitstunden derjenigen, die zum neunzigsten und zum zehnten Perzentil der Freizeitverteilung gehören, vergrößert sich zwischen 1965 und 2003 um 14 Stunden pro Woche. Die zunehmende Einkommensungleichheit geht mit einer zunehmenden Ungleichheit bei der Arbeit und einem spiegelbildlichen Trend bei der Freizeit dann her. Darüber hinaus erweisen sich Einkommensungleich und Zeitunterschiede als eng miteinander korreliert und sogar miteinander verflochten, sodass dieselben Menschen, die steigende Einkommen erzielen, auch mehr Arbeit leisten und weniger Freizeit genießen. Du hattest hier diese wunderbaren Clips mitgebracht von unserem Freund Gabor Steingart. Der sagt, die Deutschen wollen doch eigentlich mehr arbeiten. Sie müssen mehr arbeiten. Sie haben doch Lust auf Wohlstand und all das.
Genau, Lust auf Wohlstand.
Der spricht ja zu einer Elite, die 60, 70 Stunden arbeitet und sich deshalb einbildet, das hundertfache verdienen zu können. Man kann sich auch fragen, dann müsstest du ja, wenn du doppelt so viel arbeitest, doppelt so viel verdienen. Das würde ja noch Sinn ergeben, aber nein, die bekommen dann komischerweise hundertmal mehr. Und was hier gesagt wird, ist, dass also die oberen zehn Prozent jetzt 14 Stunden mehr pro Woche arbeiten, als die unteren zehn Prozent. Bedeutet also, wir haben da eine ganz klare Selbstausbeutung, die sich entsprechend lohnt, bei der man also sehr viel Geld verdienen kann. Aber das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass diese Leute, die so viel arbeiten, überhaupt gar kein Verständnis haben für Leute, die weniger arbeiten wollen. Das heißt also, für jetzt so strategisch draufgeplickt, sind wir in echt einer ganz schweren Situation. Ich wurde gestern auch bei der EG Metall so kurz angesprochen auf Arbeitszeit. Dann habe ich nur gesagt, es sieht irgendwie gerade schlecht aus, das durchzusetzen. Und ich glaube, das ist der Grund, den wir hier geliefert bekommen. Es gibt keinerlei Akzeptanz von der Elite dafür.
Naja, wenn du als Top Dealmaker bei Morgan Stanley, wie er schreibt, typischerweise zwölf Stunden Arbeitstage hast und wenn sich Geschäfte anbahnen, 20 Stunden, also dann hast du gar keine Zeit mehr, dir Gedanken zu machen, wie so, dann bist du einfach in diesem Trott drin. Dann ist das deine Identität.
Das oberste Prozent betritt das eigene Privatleben, als seien sie Fremde.
Man kommt nach Hause und stellt fest, ich bin schon vor drei Monaten hier eingezogen, ich habe immer noch keine Möbel, wann soll ich die denn holen? Da legt man sich auf so eine Matratze. Und dann kommt Amazon, hier ist das Zitat, lange, hart und klug arbeiten. Also man kann lange, hart und klug arbeiten, aber bei amazon.com kann man nicht nur zwei von drei Optionen wählen. Selbst Apple sagt, aber was heißt selbst Apple? Wir haben ja natürlich immer diese Idee von Apple ist so toll und so. Aber eine Führungskraft bei Apple hat niemals Ferien. Also auch im Urlaub ist man erreichbar und grundsätzlich bis zwei Uhr morgens. Das ist doch absurd. Wieso machen die sowas? Das versteht man einfach nicht.
Ja, es ist erstaunlich, dass sich das so durchsetzen kann. Also jeder weiß, dass es ganz gut ist, wenn man ein bisschen Geld hat und sich Dinge leisten kann. Wir gehen ja gerne in die Oper und sind dann froh, dass wir uns das Ticket leisten können und nicht darüber nachfragen, nicht überlegen müssen, ob wir auch noch ein zweites Mal gehen. Aber diese Leute verdienen ja ganz viel Geld und können ja nie was damit machen. Also das ist ja dann reiner Selbstzweck bzw. dann übertragen sie das so merkwürdig auf ihre Kinder, die aber ja auch nur in diese Mühle getrieben werden, wo die Kinder auch in gleicher Weise oder noch stärker unglücklich sein werden. Also diese Idee, ich mache das mal, arbeite und dann geht es den Kindern einmal besser, das findet man ja in der Mittelklasse dann in 60er, 70er Jahren. Man beißt die Zähne zusammen, damit beide studieren gehen können oder so etwas. Aber hier sehen wir ja eigentlich nur, dass diese Klasse Monstern produziert, reproduziert eigentlich selbst schon, Monsterhaft sich aufführt und Monstern reproduziert, ohne die eigentlichen Vorteile, die man haben könnte, wenn man reich ist, zu genießen.
Er schreibt, die Industrie ist für die meritokratische Elite ebenso unverzichtbar geworden wie eins, die Muse für die Art Aristokratie. Also die Industrie, die eigene Aufgabe ist jetzt die neue Muse.
Ja, was mir auch so klar wurde, wir haben ja auch hier schon über Superjachten und all das gesprochen, klar, das Geld ist so prall vorhanden und sie können ja nichts machen, wofür sie Zeit aufwenden müssen. Die Zeit ist ja nicht vorhanden. Also muss man so diese eine Woche auf der Luxusjacht haben und die gehört einem selbst. Da hat man alles vergoldet und da kann man aber noch arbeiten. Das ist dann die einzige Idee oder im kleineren Maßstab haben wir ja auch schon hier Podcasts zugehört, Leute, die enorm viel Geld verdienen in der Medienlandschaft und dann einfach Uhren sammeln. Da kann man immer sagen, da habe ich wieder 15.000, 30.000 dahingebracht und eine Uhr mit nach Hause genommen.
Die ist unvergänglich, die darf man auch mal drei Monate liegen lassen. Sie ist dann einfach glänzt immer noch.
Die ruft nicht, will nicht gestreichelt werden.
Als die Uhrständen kürzlich gefragt wurden, wie viele Arbeitsstunden pro Woche sie maximal akzeptieren würden, gab der Durchschnitt 70 Stunden an. Es sind also zwei Arbeitsleben in einer Person. Zwei Arbeitsleben und kein Privatleben.
Jetzt werden aber manche, die uns schon länger zuhören, gerade bei mir fragen, ja, aber Wolfgang, du arbeitest doch auch so viel.
Aber noch an der echten Muse.
Da würde ich sagen, ja, aber ich arbeite ja völlig unentfremdet. Hier wird ja nur entfremdete Arbeit gezeigt. Also er hat diesen Begriff Entfremdung von Marks. Denk, bringt er immer wieder ins Spiel. Ich arbeite, außer wenn ich vielleicht Steuererklärungen oder sowas machen muss, arbeite ich ja unentfremdet. Das heißt, ich setze mich mit Themen auseinander, die mich interessieren und lese Bücher dazu und rede mit interessanten Leuten. Das ist für mich so, dass Muse und Arbeit da eins sind. Ich könnte diese Tätigkeiten, die dort beschrieben werden, in diesem Buch nicht mal 30 Stunden die Woche machen, geschweige denn 70 oder 80.
Ja, das verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt auch immer nicht so richtig. Warum man es machen will? Nein, es gibt ja wirklich Leute, wie du jetzt sagtest, wenn man seine Steuererklärung machen muss, das ist ja ein regulärer Beruf. Also Leute machen Steuererklärungen, nicht mal mit ihrem eigenen Geld. Und sie halten das mehr als 30 Minuten am Tag überhaupt durch. Sondern die machen das ja acht Stunden. Und es fällt mir ernsthaft schwer, mir das vorzustellen, wenn das mein Schicksal wäre.
Ja, Grüße an alle Steuerberater, die uns hier gerade zuhören. Ja, wir brauchen sie, Stefan.
Wir brauchen sie bringend. Das ist ja auch alles toll. Aber Steuerberatung ist vielleicht sogar noch mal interessant, wenn man da so persönliche Biografien mit begleitet und so. Aber es gibt eben auch in diesem Metier hier, also wo es wirklich schwierig ist...
Vor allem, wie ich das gerade anfühle, also nicht, dass hier ein falsches Verständnis von Steuerberatung entsteht. Steuerberater, wenn sie nicht selbst den Laden haben oder Partner sind, verdienen nicht besonders gut. Das ist eine ziemlich harte Ausbildung. Also man muss da diese Prüfungen schaffen und das ist nicht so wahnsinnig gut bezahlt.
Er geht das hier so ein bisschen biografisch durch. Er beginnt vor der Empfängnis. Eliten heiraten zunehmend untereinander, klar. Also das ganze Paarungsverhältnis ist schon bei ihm. Aber er kommt eben auf diese sehr stabilen Ehen zu sprechen. Ich würde sagen, nochmal genau nachschauen, wenn man wirklich für jeden Aspekt in seinem Leben ein Budget hat, das alle anderen übersteigt, dann kann man im Grunde alles auf Dauer stellen. Man sieht ja auch, wie in so, sagen wir mal jetzt diese Guinness-Serie hier zum Beispiel, da ist das Guinness-Bier und dann vor 200 Jahren da in Dublin, war es Dublin, ich glaube schon, einfach diese riesige Fabrik, wo auch nur gearbeitet wird und dann gibt es halt zwei Eigentümer. Und er möchte, also der eine Erbe möchte eben auch in die Politik, braucht also eine Ehefrau, ist aber homosexuell. Also wird es einfach arrangiert.
Ja.
So. Und dieses Arrangement, finde ich, steckt ja hier auch so weit drin.
Ja. Also die Elite lässt sich deutlich seltener scheiden. Kinder nur innerhalb der Ehe. Von den Elitefrauen ist es bei denen es so, dass eins von 30 Kindern außer-ehelig geboren wird. Das hat überhaupt nichts mit der Realität der Mittelschicht zu tun.
Also Außer-ehelig-Seite eigentlich nochmal.
Und die heiraten und erst dann kann es das Kind geben. Sonst ist man eigentlich wie in Verhältnissen, man ist zwar nicht mehr moralisch disqualifiziert. Also bei Jane Austen, die beschreibt ja die austro-kratische Gesellschaft, da ist natürlich damit das Schicksal der Frauen besiegelt, wenn sie ein außer-eheliges Kind hätten. Aber jetzt ist es so, dass sie dann vielleicht diesem meritokratischen Maßstab nicht mehr gerecht werden können. Zwischen 1970 und 2010 stieg der Anteil der Kinder, die ohne beide Elternteile aufwachsen, in Haushalten im mittleren Drittel der Einkommensverteilung dreimal so schnell wie in Haushalten im obersten Drittel. Das Ausmaß der Unterschiede ist heute erstaunlich. So leben beispielsweise etwa 55 Prozent der Kinder in Haushalten mit einem Einkommen von etwa 25.000 Dollar nur mit einem Elternteil, verglichen mit etwa 25 Prozent in Haushalten mit einem Einkommen von etwa 60.000 Dollar und nur 10 Prozent in Haushalten mit einem Einkommen von mehr als 100.000 Dollar. Darüber hinaus leben 90 Prozent der Kinder, die in den reichsten und am besten ausgebildeten fünf Prozent der amerikanischen Postleitzahlgebieten leben, mit beiden leiblichen Elternteilen zusammen. Das heißt, man hat hier aristokratische Verhältnisse insofern, als man sich miteinander verbindet, in dieser Genealogie sich befindet, dann arrangiert man sich vielleicht in irgendeiner Weise. Ich glaube, arrangieren ist das ist das richtige Wort, aber fest steht, dass diese Familientradition fortgeführt werden muss. Und man lässt sich auch viel mehr Zeit für die Kleinkinder. Wir haben ja interessanterweise von dieser Elite immer wieder gesagt, ja warum gehen nicht alle früher arbeiten? Muss man überhaupt so lange Mutterzeit machen oder Elternzeit? Wenn man es jetzt mal pari pari betrachtet, wie das ja heute eigentlich auch viele wollen. Es ist ja nicht nur jetzt so, dass das die Emanzipation sind. Und viele wollen ja auch gerne für die Kinder da sein. Und das wird ja eigentlich so der Mittelklasse eher ausgeredet. Da wird ja eher so gesagt, naja, man kann auch, guck doch mal nach Frankreich oder so, viel früher die Kinder abgeben, obwohl das ja viele Eltern gar nicht wollen, aber dann auch aus einer finanziellen Note heraus machen. Hier bei den Eltern der Super-Elite, da ist es so, dass insbesondere die Mütter, also interessant, dass da auch wieder so alte patriarchale Strukturen sich verfestigen. Dass dieser Trend enorm ausgeprägt ist. Zu Fallist beispielsweise schreibt er, etwa die Hälfte der weiblichen MBA-Absolventinnen aus Harvard und Chicago mit zwei oder mehr Kindern in den Arbeitsmarkt und arbeitet in Teilzeit, um sich um ihre Kinder zu kümmern. Und die Mutterschaft treibt Elite-Anwältinnen in so hohem Maße aus dem Arbeitsmarkt, dass führende Kanzleien von einer Abwanderungsgefahr sprechen, von einem Flying Risk. Es ist völlig akzeptiert, in der Elite zu sagen, ich bleibe zu Hause und mache die Kinder fit für die Elite-Uni. Und wenn die Kinder Nachhilfe brauchen, dann buche ich ihnen, wenn es sein muss, den Harvard-Professor, der für 1000 Euro die Stunde unterrichtet.
Er macht das ja schön. Und nach der Empfängnis kommt ja erstmal der Kindergarten.
Ja, unbedingt.
So, der Kindergarten kostet 50.000 Dollar im Jahr. Fieldstone zum Beispiel. 80% der Kinder dort haben Eltern, die das einfach bezahlen. Da gibt es ja keinen, wie bei Harvard oder so, dass du da nochmal so ein Pentium-Programm oder sowas hast. Sondern da werden einfach 50.000 Dollar im Jahr. Tatsächlich kämpfen elitäre Eltern mit allen Mitteln um die Aufnahme ihrer Kinder. Die renommiertesten Vorschulen nehmen nur 5% der Bewerber, wie er schreibt, wodurch sie schwieriger zu erreichen sind als Harvard oder Yale. Also damit ist schon mal ein Punkt gesetzt. Dann kommt so und so Grundschulen, die Büchereien mit 160.000 Büchern haben. Das ist natürlich für 50.000 Dollar im Jahr und so schon mal gut ausgestattet. Ich würde sagen, eine der Sachen, die man aus diesem Buch auf jeden Fall lernen kann ist, Bildung ist wirklich das Einzige, was überhaupt jemanden befähigt, in dieser modernen Welt noch klarzukommen, weshalb es ein bisschen unverständlich ist, warum das, was Leute in ihrem in ihrer privaten Dynastiegestaltung als Top 1 ansehen, in der Politik nur so Top 10 ist.
Ja, das ist der Wahnsinn. Also, weil ja auch immer wieder von der Politik...
Offenbar ist ja Bildung die Lösung...
.von der Politik gesagt, ja, das ist nicht alles mit Geld lösbar, doch. Das ist alles mit Geld lösbar. Die lösen das alles mit Geld. Es werden dann die entsprechenden Lehrer, Professoren und so weiter herangezogen. In der Vorschule hat man alles, was man braucht an finanziellen Mitteln. Und wir haben ja auch die Studie, wir hatten sie hier kurz besprochen von Patrick Kaczmarczyk und Tom Krebs, die sagten, ja, der Multiplikator liegt bei 0,5, wenn es um Aufrüstung geht. Also aus jedem Euro, den man ausgibt vom Staat für die Aufrüstung, kommen nochmal so 50 Cent vom privaten Kapital. Wie ist es aber, wenn man in Bildung investiert, da war der Faktor drei. Also da kommt was ganz anderes zustande.
Und jetzt war ja immer wieder die Frage, die bekomme ich wahrscheinlich jetzt morgen in Erlangen auch wieder. Warum wird dann trotzdem so ein Schludrian politisch? Naja, weil man diese Gewinne halt nur partikularistisch verrechnen kann. Also einfach höhere Steuern für höhere Bildung, das kommt ja dann allen zugute. Das geht ja nicht, soll ja nur meinem Kind zugutekommen. Also diese Nachhilfezahlen. Familien, die 5 bis 15.000 Dollar im Jahr für Veritas ausgeben, also eine Nachhilfeorganisation Standard, 100.000 Dollar. Da wird es für diese Nachhilfeschulen natürlich interessant. Prüfungsvorbereitung steht an. Ja, dann in New York 90 Minuten Skype Nachhilfe per Videotelefonie. 1500 Dollar. Also da wird ein Kind schon, ja wir haben jetzt gerade 1500 Dollar für dich ausgegeben, damit du diese Matheaufgaben löst.
Und dann kommt diese Rechnung. Stellen sie sich vor, dass die Differenz zwischen den Ressourcen, die für die Ausbildung eines Kindes aus einem typischen Haushalt, der obersten Einkommensschicht aufgewendet werden und den Ressourcen, die für die Ausbildung eines typischen Kindes aus der Mittelschicht aufgewendet werden, jedes Jahr in einen Treuhandfonds investiert würde, der dem reichen Kind nach dem Tod seiner Eltern als Erbschaft ausgezahlt würde. Berechnen sie dann die Höhe der Erbschaft. Die übermäßigen Investitionen in Humankapital, die in einem typischen reichen Haushalt getätigt werden und über die Bildungsinvestitionen nicht nur armer, sondern auch mittelständische Haushalte hinausgehen, entsprechen heute einer traditionellen Erbschaft in Höhe von etwa 10 Millionen Dollar pro Kind. Das ist also diese zugegeben originelle Rechnung, die er aufmacht, mit der er aber auch ganz deutlich sagt, also die vererben hier schon mal so steuerfrei 10 Millionen.
Genau. Über die Bilder. Das empfängt ja jemand als Erbe und dann auch noch materiell umgesetzt, dass es passgenau ist für diese Meritokratie.
Ja und die Häuser und all das kommt ja später dann.
Also der globale Nachhilfemarkt ist jetzt 100 Milliarden Dollar, damit 20 mal so groß wie die ganze Harvard-Universität. Und er nennt Südkorea, da kennen wir das ja so ein bisschen, 12 Prozent des Haushaltseinkommens geht dort für Nachhilfe der Kinder draus. Also Kinder kommen aus der Schule, sind zu Hause und dann gehen sie noch mal drei Stunden, vier Stunden in die Schule. Jeden Tag. Das macht niemanden glücklich. Er hat noch mal einen Hochschulkapitel, aber das ist ja sowieso regend, das ganze Buches. Und dann diese 10 Millionen Dollar, da muss ich es selber noch mal wiederholen. Also er schreibt den Satz einfach zweimal. Ja, ja. Finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Und beschreibt daneben ganz viele Jobs, aus denen es kein Entkommen gibt. Dead-End-Jobs nennt er diese, zum Beispiel Flipping Burgers, also in den Fast-Food-Ketten zu arbeiten. Man bekommt 9,15 Dollar die Stunde und das war's. Und es gibt keine Idee von Aufstieg. Es gibt aber Manager, und damit sind jetzt gar nicht die einzelnen Fiat-Leiter gemeint, die verdienen nämlich auch nicht viel, sondern wirklich Manager an der Spitze, die Millionengehälter bekommen. Du hattest ja auch schon CEO-Gehälter und sowas erwähnt. In den letzten Jahren hat der bestbezahlte amerikanische CEO fast 100 Millionen Dollar nach Hause gebracht und das Durchschnittseinkommen der 200 bestbezahlten CEOs lag bei etwa 20 Millionen Dollar. Das ist 300-fache des mittleren Arbeitseinkommens. Das CEOs großer Unternehmen heute erzielen entspricht etwa dem 15-fachen des Verhältnisses zwischen CEO und Arbeitnehmer-Einkommen von 1965. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt da nochmal mit Marx draufblicken, dann sehen wir, okay, diese neue Klasse hat es geschafft. Also diese Manager-Klasse, nennen wir sie einfach mal, hat es geschafft, das, was geleistet wird, noch viel stärker herauszupressen durch alle möglichen Managementmaßnahmen und all das, aus den Angestellten. Sie selbst sind zwar als Manager auch noch angestellt, aber das fließt in einem großen Teil ihnen zu, was dann dafür gesorgt hat, dass sie vervielfachen konnten, das, was sie sonst verdient haben. Also der Lohnabstand ist so fundamental gestiegen, dass man sagen kann, wir haben es eigentlich hier mit, ich habe überlegt, wie könnte man es nennen, eigentlich mit Angestellten Kapitalisten zu tun.
Und hier nennt er eben auch, also klar, in Zahlen können wir das runterbrechen und sagen, wow, die sind wirklich super reich. Aber er beschreibt irgendwie, sie mit Angst infiziert werden. Eigentlich war das immer so ein Phänomen der Unterschicht, dass Kinder keine Perspektive haben im Sinne von, ich weiß nicht, was nächstes Jahr ist, ich gucke erst mal, dass morgen gut läuft und so. Und so ist das hier erstaunlicherweise auch. Diese Kinder werden also infiziert, wie er schreibt, mit oberflächlichen Ambitionen. Dafür eine tiefe gehende und allgegenwärtige Angst vor dem Scheitern. Da kommen dann auch die exzellenten Schafe vor, oder das Bild der Zombies, die sehr intelligent, aber völlig verwirrt sind. Und ohne eine Vorstellung davon, was als Nächstes zu tun ist. Also man hangelt sich sozusagen von einer Prüfungssituation zur nächsten und kann die dann auch immer bewältigen. Aber man hat jetzt nicht wirklich so eine, ja es kommt quasi immer nur der Druck von außen, der dich immer wieder in den Moment zurückholt und sagt, ne ne, du musst jetzt heute noch den All-Nighter machen, ansonsten kommst du ja nicht weiter.
Dadurch sind sie auch die totalen Opportunisten, was ich, wie ich finde, man auch jetzt merken kann. Nämlich, aus dieser Klasse gibt es keinen Protest gegen Trump.
Nö, er schreibt ja auch genau hier diese von den 15 Stunden pro Woche. Als kürzlich eine Gruppe von Elite-Studierenden gefragt wurde, wer von ihnen bereit wäre, 15 Stunden pro Woche für eine an sich wertlose Aufgabe aufzuwenden, um sich einen Karrierevorteil zu verschaffen, sagten alle, dass sie dazu bereit wären und zeigten sich darüber hinaus überrascht über diese Frage. Also es ist genau dieser Opportunismus, der Zukunft austreibt, aber auch so eine Sensibilität wie das Gesamtgefüge.
Dabei sind die mittelqualifizierten Jobs seit den 1980er Jahren immer weiter verschwunden. Und auch da muss ich an die eigene Familie denken, an jemanden, der so einen mittelqualifizierten Job hatte als Angestellter im Büro in den 80er Jahren. Und wie er dann auch immer mehr Schwierigkeiten bekam, so einen Job wiederzufinden, dann dort entlassen wurde, dorthin, ging dahin, dahin. Und er eigentlich dann auch so mit den 90er Jahren bis in die Nuller, bis er dann verrentet wurde, eigentlich so einen Abstieg genau erlebt hat, obwohl er eigentlich mal diesen 70er Jahre Aufstieg mitgenommen hat, so Realschulabschluss und dann eine eigentlich ganz gute Position, wo man doch hätte weiter noch zwei, drei Schritte die Karriereleiter raufklettern konnte. Aber genau das hat sich dann nicht eingestellt.
Die Fahrtabhängigkeit hängt wirklich ganz eng an diesen völlig absurden Aufgaben, die da so formuliert werden.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt demnächst mal irgendwie fliegt und an der Business Class vorbeigeht, dann muss man immer sich vergegenwärtigen, da sitzen die Unfreien.
Ja, hast du diese eine Fußnote oder? Nee, er hat es in Klammern geschrieben. Wenn du an einer First Class vorbeigehst ins Flugzeug, mach dich das so oder empirier es, führt das so häufig zu Rage auf dem Flugzeug, dass es die Leute unglücklich macht, als hätte der Flieger neun Stunden Verspätung. Einfach nur dieses Gefühl, ich laufe gerade an der First Class vorbei und denke mir, das sind die Gewinner, die sind schon wieder separiert, die sind schon wieder fleißiger als ich gewesen, wie auch immer. Also diese Unzufriedenheit, das führt zu so viel Unzufriedenheit und Ärger wie eine neunstündige Verspätung. Das ist einfach sehr, sehr witzig. Die Faulheit. Ich fand das ja sehr interessant, dass hier als Textgeber einfach der Schwiegersohn Frank Karl Marx genannt wird, nämlich Paul Lafargue oder wie auch immer.
Paul Lafargue.
Ich kenne ich gar nicht, aber scheint ein Autor zu sein. Das Lob der Faulheit 1883 oder Recht auf Faulheit. Recht auf Recht auf Faulheit, genau. Es wird kontrastiert mit John Maynard Keynes, der 1930 sagte, also die technologischen Innovationen vor 100 Jahren, die Technologen, wir wollen drei Stunden Tag haben. Ja. Da kann man schon mal abschätzen, was die KI bedeutet. Also sie wird niemanden befreien, außer uns, die völlig Unabhängigen usw. Alle, die in Organisationszusammenhängen sind, kriegen erst mal richtig Druck. Warum bist du nicht so gut wie die KI? Ich kann dich auch rausschmeißen. Ja. Dagegen versprechen, nicht auf.
Ganz kurz noch ein Wort zu den Editeunis und dem Militär. Das sollten wir nicht unerwähnt lassen, weil wir so viel diskutieren. Wer soll jetzt gerade an die Front? Er hat sich angesehen, wie ist denn das eigentlich mit den Gedenkstätten für die Kriegsopfer an den Universitäten? Die Alumninnen der Editeuniversitäten haben dort immer solche Gedenkstätten, auf denen alle Namen stehen, derer, die im Krieg gefallen sind und dort den Abschluss gemacht haben. Dabei zeigt sich dann noch, dass bei den Weltkriegen viele, viele Namen dort zu finden waren. Also tatsächlich noch Klassen zusammen kamen. Ja, die, wenn man aber dann sich ansieht, bei den folgenden Kriegen, Vietnam, Irak, Afghanistan und so weiter, dann werden diese Gedenktafeln immer kürzer und kürzer, weil immer seltener irgendwelche Elite-Studenten zum Militär gehen. Dieser Trend ist so stark, schreibt er, dass während des Golfkrieges 1990 bis 1991 mehr Yale-Studenten in New Haven ermordet wurden, als im Irak getötet wurden. Das heißt, auch das gibt es nicht mehr. Die Uniform ist also nichts, was die Elite sich anzieht. Und Arbeitskleidung, das ist, ja, was ist das heute? Das ist etwas für die Nichtqualifizierten und die haben aber auch keine würdige Arbeitskleidung mehr, sondern, wie er dann schreibt, Arbeitskleidung für die Nichtqualifizierten sieht heute so aus, Throwing on a goofy head. Auch da wissen wir alle sofort Bescheid, wie wir da so sehen, wenn wir durch die Stadt gehen und uns irgendwo noch ein Eis kaufen oder so. Mögen die Eliten zwar gegen das Patriarchat sein, am Ende bleiben die Frauen ja dann doch zu Hause, haben wir jetzt gelernt. Und diese, die da zu Hause bleiben, sind im Prinzip dann ja eigentlich viel unemanzipierter als die arbeitenden Frauen der Mittelklasse.
Ja, diesen Rückschritt haben ja Ostdeutsche schon gemacht. Da ist ja diese Entwicklung auch. Es kommt zu interessanter operationalisierung. Deswegen, ich habe dieses eine Text hier gerade gefunden. Also der Wortlaut lautet Die Anwesenheit einer First Class Kabine erhöht die Häufigkeit von Wutausbrüchen unter Passagieren der Economy Class um denselben Betrag wie eine Flugverspätung von neun Stunden und 29 Minuten. Und wenn Economy Class Passagiere durch die First Class gehen müssen, um ihre Sitze zu erreichen, dann um den Betrag einer Verspätung von 15 Stunden. Also das müsste man sich jetzt nochmal, er hat es auch in Klammern nur geschrieben, anschauen, was das genau operationalisiert bedeutet.
Also man sitzt dann hinten im Flieger und hat Prass, dass die da vorne so schön sitzen.
Genau. Es ist ein bisschen wie die 10 Millionen Dollar, die eben nicht investiert, sondern in das Kind fließen, als Erbe zu verstehen, das jemand erhält und jemand anderes nicht. Und die nächste interessante Operationalisierung, finde ich, ist hier zur Lebenserwartung. Denn dieser Separatismus, den du ja schon beschrieben hast gerade, es ist ja auch die Frage, wo das amerikanische Militär seine Plakate aufhängt, um zu sagen, wir brauchen dich. Denken Sie daran, dass die Hälfte der Absolventen der Universitäten, Harvard, Princeton und Yale in den reichsten und gebildeten 5% der Postleitzahlgebiete lebt. Also da weiß man einfach, wo man Bogen drum macht, weil es da sowieso nichts zu holen gibt und wo man die Leute einsammelt. Und man holt sie zum Beispiel aus Mississippi. Die Kluft in der Lebenserwartung, und wir hatten ja eben schon, dass der Klassismus sogar den Rassismus schlägt, auch wenn er so unsichtbar ist. Die Kluft in der Lebenserwartung bedeutet, zwischen Connecticut und Mississippi liegen heute fast sechs Jahre. Rein durch diese Regionen erklärt. Der Unterschied zwischen den Vereinigten Staaten und Nicaragua besteht aus vier Jahren. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, Nicaragua scheint ja nicht das mega ärmste Land zu sein. Es ist jetzt nicht so ein Somalier-Vergleich oder so. Aber es ist schon bedeutsam, wenn Innere im Vergleich zu Inter-Vergleichen zu so krassen Diskrepanzen führen. Hier geht es ja um 50 Prozent Unterschiede der Lebenserwartung innerhalb Amerikas.
In Deutschland steht das jetzt nicht im Buch. Es ist so, dass die obersten zehn Prozent sieben Jahre länger leben als die untersten zehn Prozent. Sieben Jahre!
Ja, also an diesen sieben Jahren, und es sind ja mehr als die sechs Jahre, die hier genannt werden, sieht man schon, in Deutschland liegt einiges am Argen, auch wenn selbst Leute, die sich mit den Sachen befassen, klar, jetzt Amerikaner, aber er schreibt ja auch über Deutschland.
Und dann sagt er, hier ist noch alles wunderbar.
Genau, und er kommt so auf Empirie, wo ich mir denke, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Es ist so halb, richtig. Man kann das so schreiben, weil es in Gesetzbüchern steht, wie zum Beispiel er lobt Berlin dafür. Aber als halt vor Kai Wegner, also man muss sich auch aktuell nochmal anschauen. Es gibt keine elitären Kindertagesstätten, da niemand erlaubt ist, einen Zuschlag höher als 90 Euro pro Monat zu berechnen. Also es wäre sozusagen gar nicht möglich, einen teuren Kindergarten einzurichten, es sei denn, du machst ihn halt wirklich komplett privat. Und das hast du eben bei Tagesmuttersystemen. Ich weiß nicht genau, inwieweit das angemeldet werden muss.
Naja, ich kenne zum Beispiel auch jemanden, der einen Nanny hat und dann hat man eben einen Nanny.
Genau, auch bei einer Tagesmuttersysteme zeigen ja immer schon, das muss der Staat so hinnehmen, weil er nicht in der Lage ist, Kindergärten zu betreiben oder überhaupt eine Struktur zu schaffen. Also sagt man so, ja, dann machen wir das mal mit Uberfahrern und Tagesmüttern. So, die kommunale Politik. Und ich glaube nicht, dass da einfach die 90-Euro-Regel gilt pro Monat.
Ja, ja, ich habe ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass er sich so ein paar Sachen hat zuarbeiten lassen. Hier mal was zu Deutschland als Kontrast. Und ja, wir haben ja eben über den Genikoeffizienten gesprochen. Da sieht man noch einen deutlichen Unterschied zu den USA, aber wir bewegen uns natürlich in diese Richtung. Und das kann man auch daran sehen, dass Privatschulen dann beliebter werden. Dass es da auch einen Run drauf gibt. Das heißt, ja, nur weil man noch besser dasteht. Die allgemeine Tendenz ist ja absehbar. Und wir können uns ja auch vorstellen, welche Politiker das besonders gerne beschleunigen möchten. Nämlich die, die zum Beispiel auch dagegen sind, dass es kostenlose Mittagessen an Schulen gibt. Damit ja nicht alle gut ausgebildet werden.
Also erst halt hier. In Deutschland gibt es praktisch keine Privatschulen oder Universitäten. Und dann sagen wir, also hier in Frankfurt am Main, ich kann dir zehn aufzählen. Das ist einfach falsch.
Ja, ja. Also das ist ein bisschen unsinnig. Ich glaube, er wollte ein positives Beispiel nehmen. Und ja, dann gibt es in Deutschland mit dem Sozialstaat immer noch viele Dinge, die besser laufen. Aber auch gerade jetzt in Frankreich gibt es ja auch nicht so einen kleinen Sozialstaat, sondern da passiert ja auch noch relativ viel. Aber auch da gibt es ja eine ganz unerbittliche, meritokratische Gesellschaft, wo ein Hauen und Stechen ist und man dort auch in jungen Jahren seinen Berufsweg allen für allemal manifestiert, stärker noch als in Deutschland, obwohl da der Sozialstaat auch wesentlich besser funktioniert als in den USA. Also so kann man das doch nicht einfach herunterbrechen.
Und damit sind wir so fast am Ende. Und er hat ja zwei Ideen. Also einmal ein New Deal und das andere ist, Universitäten mal so ein bisschen aus der Public Charity rausholen. Trotzdem hier noch eine Zahl, wo man so ein bisschen, das ist in Deutschland, droht das jetzt. Princeton gibt pro Jahr pro Student 100.000-5.000 Dollar aus. Und eine öffentliche Uni, die er gegenüberstellt, die Essex County, das Essex County College, dort sind es 2.400 Dollar. So wir sind also hier im Faktor 50 oder sagen wir mal 40, unterschieden. Und jetzt diese Gini-Koeffizienten in Deutschland, beim Einkommen so 0,3, beim Vermögen 0,8. Diese 0,8 müssen in Sicherheit gebracht werden. Das wird demnächst über Einkommen geschehen. Von daher wissen wir schon, wir sehen ja auch, wie gerade Markus Söder jetzt zu langt. Und einfach das nächste ist jetzt das Gesundheitssystem. Wir werden auch ans Bildungssystem nachgehen, dass man sich noch mehr Freiheit einfach nichts zu tun, die Verantwortung komplett abzugeben, indem die Hälfte der Bevölkerung, die sich dafür interessieren, einfach private Wege eröffnet werden. Und von daher ist dieses Abfeiern von, wer hat jetzt wieder welche Budgets für irgendwelche Forschungs, extra Forschungsbereiche und so weiter und so fort. Sonderforschungsbereiche und dann wird die LMU nochmal abgefeiert. Also da sind wir ja genau auf Track, würde ich sagen.
Ja. Wann begann es im Kino? Mir ist es dann direkt eingefallen. Wall Street, du kennst den berühmten Film von Oliver Stone mit Michael Douglas. Und da wird ja Gordon Gekko gefragt zum Mittagessen, ob er zum Mittagessen geht und dann sagt er, Lunch ist for whims, also für Flaschen, für Schwächlinge. Das ist genau der Zeitpunkt, wo diese meritokratische Klasse sich breit macht und dann auch sagt, ja Freizeit ist mir nicht mehr wichtig und Mittagessen. Also früher war die Elite, die Banker Elite, ging sehr gut essen und nahm auch schon einen teuren Rotwein zu sich. Aber nein, Gordon Gekko arbeitete schon durch und wurde dann zum Vorbild für so viele.
Ja, aber so wie man jetzt den Rave verlagert auf die Frühstückszeit am Morgen, um sich sozusagen ein bisschen Freizeitvergnügen zu holen, während man sich aber, ich bin befreit von Schuld und Sühne. Ich habe ja in der Zeit gefrühstückt. Ist natürlich der Lunch, gerade auch im amerikanischen Film. Also wie gehen Banker lunchen? Naja, sie treffen natürlich ihre Kollegen und dann wird die große Bande gezogen.
Ich finde aber jetzt so, du hast es gerade mit der ersten Klasse beschrieben, diese Wut. Also ich kann diese Wut auch dann nachvollziehen, die da beschrieben wird. Aber was eigentlich doch...
Weil du immer siehst, wenn diese Zweitklassen-Leute dann schon mal in der ersten Klasse einsteigen und die vorbeigehen.
Ich fliege so gut wie nie und bin noch nie in meinem Leben erste Klasse geflogen, weil das immer kurze Strecken waren.
Das macht man auch nicht.
Das heißt, ich kann da nicht mitreden. Ich weiß aber, wie das aussieht, weil ich mir natürlich schon Videos dazu angeguckt habe und dachte aber gleich, ja, aber am Ende hängst du auch dann in diesem Flugzeug trotzdem und musst dich da acht Stunden disziplinieren, bis du dann wieder da raus kannst. Also so grandios finde ich es dann auch nicht. Jedenfalls kann man ja, wenn man jetzt demnächst solche Situationen hat und vielleicht sogar mit so Leuten mal ins Gespräch kommt und die sich ja auch gerne dann direkt produzieren, denn wir wissen, ihre Identität sind Berufszertifikate und und und. Dann kann man sagen, das tust du mir aber leid, was du da musst du so lange arbeiten.
Na ja, ich würde so sagen.
Also ich glaube, man kann schon den mal quasi in einem anderen Diskurs entgegensetzen. Statt jetzt das so abzufeiern, kann man ja auch einfach mal sagen, ja, aber dann kannst du auch gar nie ins Kino gehen. Das ist aber schade.
Ich bin auch sehr dafür, dass man im öffentlichen Raum wieder mehr die Gelegenheit nutzt, darüber sich auszutauschen, was man gerade tolles erlebt hat. Ja. Statt von der Arbeit zu erzählen. Einfach nicht von der Arbeit zu erzählen. Von der Arbeit erzählt man einfach nur, weil das das einzige Thema ist, dass man so auf dem Kasten hat. Das ist wie beim Wetter. Man kann ihm halt nicht entrinnen, aber einfach wieder über die anderen Sachen reden.
Und dabei wird man feststellen, dass die Leute gar nicht so viel anderes zu erzählen haben, weil sie ja nur gearbeitet haben.
Dann muss man dafür sorgen, dass sie das quält.
Ja, richtig.
So der New Deal. Er sagt, ok, es gab ja schon mal die einzige Entwicklung, wo man Eigentumsverhältnisse umgemodelt hat. Das war also das wirkliche Industriezeitalter. Man hat die Aristokratie hinter sich gelassen und gesagt, Public Schools und so weiter. Das pervertierte heute in Public Charity für Universitäten, die nicht ihrem öffentlichen Auftrag nachkommen, sondern einfach, wie er dann auch sagt, also wenn die Entwicklung so weitergeht, gehört das ganze Land bald nur noch diesen Universitäten. Also die grasen ja da auch die Gelder ab. Das ist ja unglaublich. Er sagt, das System muss halt überholt werden. Jetzt kann man natürlich noch mal bei ihm nachfragen, wie steht es, um deine eigenen Bemühungen Yale abzuschaffen, oder die Zugangsregeln zu ändern.
Als Adam Toos, glaube ich, das erste Mal bei Tido im Interview zu Gast war, hatte er auch erzählt von der Elite-Universität Columbia. Dort lehrt er ja nun einmal und hat dann auch gesagt, wie da so eine Elite herausgebildet wird und so. Der Effekt dieses Interviews war, das hatte dann Adam Toos also das zweite Mal dort erzählt. Er hat lauter E-Mails bekommen von Eltern, können sie irgendwelche Tipps geben.
Genau, wie geht das da? Also in der Ansicht, da ist einfach, also es ist völlig unmöglich, die Motivationsstruktur jedes Einzelnen, widerspricht hier jegliche Änderung.
Deswegen brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht weiter über den New Deal, wie alle wissen, Roosevelt und so weiter. Aber daran jetzt zu glauben, also er glaubt ja auch nicht dran, er sagt, das wäre eine Möglichkeit und ja, man kann Gesellschaft auch noch ganz anders gestalten. Aber wir sind eigentlich hier an einem Punkt, an dem wir sagen müssen, das ist so mit das Traurigste, was wir je gelesen haben im Salon, oder?
Hier wird einfach nur erklärt, wir sind alle doof und so ist es halt. Und auch wenn der letzte Satz lautet, die Arbeiter der Welt, jetzt sowohl die Mittelschicht als auch die Oberschicht, sollten sich vereinen. Sie haben nichts zu verlieren, als ihre Ketten und eine ganze Welt zu gewinnen. Ja gut. Da ist Marx wirklich zur Literatur verkommen.
Ja.
Und man macht einen großen Haken dran und sagt, hey, aber verrückt, dass das Buch nicht übersetzt wurde, dass es nicht auf Deutsch erhältlich ist.
Klar, es ist sehr, sehr amerikanisch, aber wir haben das ja mit so einem Gewinn gelesen. Und wir bräuchten jetzt eigentlich nur von jemandem wie Butterwecke oder so ein Vorwort für eine deutsche Ausgabe, der sagt, naja, so ganz stimmt das nicht, was der Markovits über Deutschland da schreibt. Das ist nämlich eigentlich so und so. Aber dann wäre das eigentlich das ideale Buch, um vor allem jetzt diese Diskussion anzufachen. Oder jemand, nicht wir, oder vielleicht willst du es machen, sollte jetzt einfach so für Deutschland das schon mal so aufschreiben, wohin wir uns schon entwickelt haben und wo es mal hinführen könnte, nämlich zu dieser Falle, die Markovits uns schildert.
Also ich sag mal so, soziologisch gesehen ist es jetzt nicht so sonderbar, dass einfach Sachen aufgeschrieben werden, denen es einfach heißt, ja und so ist es halt.
Ja eben. Aber das könnte man doch jetzt mal machen für Deutschland.
Also es ist sozusagen das Genre der Abklärung. Und ich bin auch total dafür, dass man diese, also gerade die Perversionen im deutschen Bildungssystem und so oder wie Familien bestresst werden, haben wir ja selber geschrieben, dass man das mal aufschreibt und auch die Zahlen nennt, die so im Raum stehen. Wie bei Lanz auch noch mal gesagt, eine Billion Schattenhaushalt, die den Familien einfach erbringen, ohne dass der Staat da mal ein bisschen unterstützt, wie auch immer.
Aber nicht reportagehaft. Also ich meine jetzt nicht wie gestatten Elite von Julia Friedrichs, die war ja auch schon bei der WHO und bei anderen Eliteinstitutionen, hat sich das so ein bisschen angesehen, hat mehr so die Stimmung aufgefangen, mit ein paar Zahlen dann unterfüttert. Aber ich würde jetzt mir eigentlich so ein Buch wünschen, wie Markovits das geschrieben hat, also mit einer sehr klaren Studiendichte, die uns zeigt, wohin führt das.
Ich würde das aber noch ein bisschen abwandeln. Ich finde auch eine Lehre aus dem Buch ist jetzt, es macht nicht so viel Sinn, den Eltern noch einmal zu erklären, wie ihre Falle aussieht, aus der sie eh nicht rauskommen. Weil ehrlich, niemand, der gerade 600.000 Euro im Jahr verdient, ist davon abzubringen, dass das Kind irgendwie nach Salem muss oder sowas. Also da gibt es einfach gar keine. Aber es gibt einige Einflugsschneisen für Abklärungsliteratur. Denn das, was wir gerade sehen, ist ja, dass Superreiche auch noch so einen Weltveränderungsambitions-Scheiß drin haben. Allen voran Elon Musk, der einfach sagt, ich mische mich jetzt mal in die amerikanische Regierung ein, dann kanzle ich USAID, dann lasse ich über mich herfallen, dass da 600.000 Tote zu verzeichnen sind. Hauptsache, ich habe hier meine Finger im Spiel. Und da ist einfach nicht Aufklärung, sondern wirklich Abklärung. Im Sinne von, wir sehen es, wir haben alle dieselbe Meinung, wir wollen das nicht und das ist auch irgendwie dumm. Also es ist einfach, wir müssen jetzt alle mal kurz mitdenken. Niemand muss jetzt sein Leben verändern, aber bitte keine Verherrlichung mehr von diesem Superreichtum, gerade wenn wir ihn sehen. Denn sind wir doch mal ehrlich, das, was wir da sehen, dafür gibt es keine Verherrlichung. Also wir haben ja vorhin Donald Trump besprochen, da steht er da und sagt, ich will das Öl. So und Merz sagt dann, das ist völkerrechtlich komplex und alle so, vielleicht ist ja noch was dran und irgendwelche Spiegelautoren schlüsseln dir dann auf, dass das vielleicht doch gar nicht so schlecht ist, wenn man das Öl jetzt auch endlich mal ruht oder irgendwas kommt ja auch den Venezuelanern zugute. Ja. Und da muss einfach Abklärung rein.
Das bedeutet aber doch auch, dass wir anders über Bildung reden müssen, denn worum es ja hier eigentlich geht in diesem Buch, ist, dass ja nur geschildert wird, wie sich Menschen instrumentell bilden, um dann in den entsprechenden Kanzleien oder Vorstandsetagen zu wirken, Finanzprodukte zu stricken, die nie einer brauchte, aber mit denen man sich dann selbst bereichern kann. Während es auf der anderen Seite ja das humanistische Bildungsideal gibt, das ja in Europa und besonders in Deutschland hochgehalten wurde, was aber dann jetzt immer weniger wichtig ist. Man sieht ja auch, dass zum Beispiel die Elite nicht mehr alte Sprachen oder so etwas lernt. Und wir sehen es ja auch daran, dass jemand wie Gabor Steingart dann noch mal betont hat, unser Problem ist eigentlich, dass wir an diesem Bildungsideal noch festhalten. Und er will ja eigentlich nur eine Bildung haben, die instrumentell genutzt werden kann. Denn was wir ja hier produziert bekommen bei dieser sogenannten Elite, und das ist ja auch meine Kritik gewesen, als wir hier mal über diese permanenten Campus-Debatten sprachen, dass man da eigentlich so eine ungebildete Elite herangezüchtet hat. Die ist zwar exzellent in diesen particulären Fällen, die hat auch ordentlich Rechenleistung im Kopf und die kann auch fünf Sprachen und all das. Und die hat auch schon 17 Rhetorikkurse gebucht, dass sie alles Mögliche verargumentieren kann und dann in so Debatten sich wunderbar stellen kann. Aber eine wirkliche Bildung, eine wirkliche Grundlage, was eigentlich das Leben bedeutet, ist bei diesen Leuten ja nicht mehr anzutreffen, weil sie eigentlich nur von Fall zu Fall, von einem Zertifikat zum nächsten Leben. Und das wäre eigentlich jetzt die interessante Gegenbewegung. Die muss man aber gar nicht jetzt den reichen Leuten erklären, wie sie es angehen sollen, sondern ich glaube, dass man viel selbstbewusster jetzt aus einer Mittelklasse und ich würde auch bitte nicht nur die Mittelklasse hinzunehmen, sondern auch alle anderen, dass man sagt, Bildung und diese muss politisch unterstützt werden, die nicht instrumentell ist, die ist eigentlich wichtig und die bildet den Gegenpol. Und wir sind eigentlich dann diejenigen, die mit dem Leben was Vernünftiges anzufangen wissen und nicht 90 Stunden arbeiten wollen, weil es noch andere schöne Seiten gibt.
Das bedeutet aber, finde ich, ein bisschen zulassen, liebe Hörerschaft. Wenn dann jemand kommt wie ich und sagt, also bei diesen und diesen und diesen Fragestellungen, verschwendet bitte nicht eure Zeit, fragt einfach Kloten. Und dann will ich nicht hören, nee, das ist viel besser, wenn man das selber kann und so, dann sag ich, nee, ich weiß schon, das 1 mal 1 ist ganz wichtig und das sagt man auch schon ab der Grundschule und das sollte man sicher drauf haben, aber es gibt so ein paar kleine 1 mal 1, die man jetzt auslagern kann.
AGBs lesen ist kein Vergnügen und wenn man es outsourcen kann, sollte man das tun.
Also juristischen Text zu verstehen ist keine spezielle Leistung mehr, denn der kann einem jetzt einfach erklärt werden.
Jetzt gehen wir zur Literatur, jetzt hören wir die Musik, jetzt machen wir andere Dinge.
Wir haben jetzt Zeit für Mitmenschen und die Arbeitsergebnisse von Mitmenschen. Wir müssen uns jetzt nicht länger mit Semantik und Grammatik und dem ganzen Kram von irgendwelchen High Profession und so weiter.
Das Handwerkliche.
Genau. Und in Nähensicht sage ich, man ist auch froh nicht so bereich zu sein, weil man sich gerade nicht mehr der Frage befasst, wie kriege ich meine Juristendynastie fortgesetzt, wenn ich die ganze Zeit schon sehe, welche Aufträge ich nicht mehr bekomme. Und die ganzen Hospitanten bei uns, die Referendare, die gucken uns immer so komisch an. Wissen die irgendwas? Ja, die wissen irgendwas. Die haben sich das heute als Audio-Podcast persönlich zusammenstellen lassen, was heute in dieser Sitzung besprochen wird. Während du nach, Frau Sekretärin, können Sie mal kurz mitschreiben. Ich habe eine Idee, ja, sagen und so. Und von daher, ich war ja bei Humano-Meri im Corp of Therapy, da kommt aber noch, da reden wir auch über diese Frage der Obskurität. Management und Maschinen. Und mit Management meine ich genau dieses meritokratische Bildungszeug. Das war bisher obskur. Man hat es nicht durchschaut. Man hat einfach nicht genug Leserfahrung oder grundsätzlich. Man war nicht so ein guter Seminarist, weil man ist gar nicht in Seminar eingeladen worden. Das hindert auch heute nicht mehr daran, spezifische Sachen in seinem Leben so in die eigene Hand zu nehmen, dass man es einfach trotzdem macht. So wie ich, Discourse zu installieren, obwohl ich dafür Docker brauche auf einem Root-Server. Oder eben wir einfach Verträge mit Werbekunden machen, ohne dass wir noch mal einen Anwalt konsultieren müssen, weil so kompliziert ist das alles nicht.
Ja, die Frage wird also sein, inwieweit die KI diese meritokratische Edite disruptiert, oder die Elite es doch schafft, mit der KI sich wieder neue Konstrukte zu basteln, um diese Defense-Income-Defense-Industrie weiterhin aufrechtzuerhalten oder sogar noch zu verstärken.
Die Income-Defense-Industrie, die müssen wir uns jetzt genauer anschauen. Und auch ein bisschen rücksichtslos, auch wenn wir jetzt viel von diesen privaten Schicksalen gehört haben, aber diese Leute sind immer noch super reich.
Jaja, also kein Mitleid. Eher so ein Mitleid, dass man ihnen das Gefühl gibt, wie ich werde jetzt gar nicht gelobt wegen meiner Zertifikate. Der guckt so komisch.
Also wer jetzt in der Wall Street zu den 175.000, die 400.000 Dollar im Jahr, die müssen einfach nur Manhattan verlassen und dann können die davon 30 Jahre lang leben.
Jaja. Machen sie interessanterweise nicht.
Genau. Und das ist eben dieser Punkt. Man muss sie jetzt nicht zu, sondern man kann jetzt diese KI und die Income Defense Industry, wie sich die beiden jetzt ko-evaluieren. Das muss man sich genau anschauen, denn da droht ja dann doch auch vielleicht Schlimmes.
Also große Empfehlung. Ja. Fast alle sind Verfechter der Leistungsgesellschaft, aber damit gerät man in eine Falle, sagt der Yale-Rechtswissenschaftler Daniel Markovits in seinem sensationellen Buch The Meritocracy Trap, das schon 2019 erschienen ist, hier aber gar nicht auf dem Radar. Der Publizistik war auch kein Verlag, hat sich diesem Buch angenommen, es ins Deutsche zu übersetzen. Dabei ist es so wichtig, genau darüber zu diskutieren, dass die Leistungsgesellschaft das Problem ist und dass sich eine Elite herausgebildet hat, die viel mehr arbeitet als der Durchschnitt, sehr viel mehr verdient, sehr unglücklich ist, fast, möchte man sagen, bemitleidenswert und wir hier sehen, wie der Kapitalismus in einer Ungleichheit manifestiert wird, wie es nie zuvor da war, nicht einmal zu aristokratischen Zeiten.
Ja, auf Deutsch sollte das Buch einfach Die Falle heißen. Sie gilt für jeden Einzelnen, der es in die Hand nimmt. Man nimmt es in die Hand und ist sofort verzaubert von dieser Falle, von dieser Aufklärung. Und das Vorwort sollte einfach die Realität schreiben. Ich bin dafür, dass man die KI das Vorwort schreiben lässt, inwieweit das erstens Deutschland betrifft und zweitens, was die sechs Jahre seit Erscheinen passiert ist. Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendwer dieses KI-Vorwort über zehn Seiten übertrumpfen kann, denn es ist wirklich interessant, dass wir dieses Buch mit diesem Abstand lesen. Selten hat die Realität nochmal so viel Plausibilität unterfüttert wie in diesem Buch, auch wenn es von der anderen Seite der Welt handelt. Aber das ist, was Deutschland droht. Und jetzt kann man überlegen, ob man das abwendet. Also es ist abzuwenden, aber wie das geht, das muss man sagen, da sind wir ratlos.
Wer glaubt, die Welt wird gleicher dadurch, dass wir einfach nur Leistungen belohnen, der irrt gewaltig. Und das ist auch ein wichtiges ideologiekritisches Werk insofern. Kommen wir zur Literatur, auf die ich aufmerksam wurde, weil im April in den Kinos ein Film anläuft, der heißt The History of Sound mit Paul Maskell und Josh O'Connor in den Hauptrollen. Dann las ich, dass das auf einer Erzählung basiert des Autors Ben Shattuck, der auch das Drehbuch dann für den Film geschrieben hat. Was ich über den Film so gelesen habe, ist, dass es sich wohl ein bisschen anders wählt als mit der Erzählung. Also man hat es frei adaptiert, darum soll es jetzt aber nicht gehen, sondern um die eigentliche literarische Grundlage, nämlich die Geschichte des Klangs, erschienen bei Hansa. Das ist ein Buch, eine Erzählung oder man könnte fast sagen ein kurzer Roman, hundert Seiten lang, aber wahnsinnig viel passierte. Es werden nämlich zwei Liebesgeschichten erzählt und die Grundfrage, die gestellt wird, ist, wie ist das mit der ersten Liebe? Ist sie dann intensiv, wenn sie kurz war und abbricht und man sich lebenslänglich daran erinnern kann? Oder wäre es eigentlich gut, die erste Liebe zu verewiglichen, also daraus dann eine Lebensbeziehung abzuleiten? Da ist das eine Modell bzw. da sind Lionel und David im Jahr 1916, die sich kennenlernen, wie sie an der Uni sind, die beiden jungen Männer, verbindet gleich auch das Interesse für Volkssongs. Sie reisen dann gemeinsam durch Kentucky, hören sich dort gesungenen Lieder an, nehmen die auf mit einem Phonographen und es ist eine Liebesgeschichte, eine intensive, monatelang verbringen sie Zeit miteinander. Der Roman beginnt jetzt aber so. Ich war 17, als ich David kennenlernte, so das schreibt Lionel. Damals 1916. Inzwischen lege ich nicht mehr viel Wert darauf, meine Jahre zu zählen. Es ist April 1984 in Cambridge, Massachusetts. Vor dem Fenster an meinem Schreibtisch schweben seit Tagen kleine weiße Bäusche vorbei, zweifellos irgendwelche Samen, die auf dem Bürgersteig liegen bleiben wie erster Schnee. Mein Arzt hat mir geraten, diese Geschichte aufzuschreiben, als Mittel gegen die Schlaflosigkeit, die angefangen hat, als ich ein Paket von einer mir unbekannten Person bekam, einen Kanton mit 25 Wachswalzen für Phonografen aufgegeben in Brunswick, Maine auf einem mit Klebeband befestigten Zettel stand. Ich habe sie im Fernsehen gesehen und bewundere ihre Arbeit. Das hier gehört ihnen. Ich habe es gefunden, als ich das Haus, das wir gekauft haben, ausgeräumt habe. Was ist auf diesen Walzen? Naja, es ist das, was sie damals aufgenommen haben, diese Folk-Songs, die Leute eingesungen haben in Kentucky und anderswo, die sie sammeln wollten, analysieren wollten. Er, Lionel, hat dann eine akademische Karriere gemacht, hat Bücher über Folk-Songs auch geschrieben, ist im Fernsehen aufgetreten und er erinnert sich nun an diese Liebe im Jahr 1916 zurück. Er erinnert sich an diese sehr intensive Zeit, aber auch daran, dass das Jahr irgendwann endete. Es endete sehr abrupt und er fragt sich jetzt, wo diese Liebe so lange eigentlich vergangen ist und man viele Jahrzehnte ein anderes Leben gelebt hat, was war das eigentlich? Nachdem wir also dann eingeführt werden in diese Beziehung von David und Lionel, heißt es, ich bin mir nicht sicher, was ich erwartete, was ich zu hören hoffte, jetzt wo er die Phonographen da hat, aber mir fiel die berühmte Geschichte über den Phonographen ein, dass er Addisons erster Erfindung war, die sofort funktionierte. Er entwarf das Konzept einer Nadel, die über eine weiche Oberfläche fuhr und ließ ein Ingenieur einen solchen Apparat bauen und siehe da, es funktionierte gleich beim ersten Mal. Dies, die reine Mechanik des Vorgangs, diese haarfeine alte Schlucht, die Davids Stimme gegraben hatte, war es, auf was ich mich konzentrierte, während ich auf die rotierende, hautfarbene Walze starte. Addison wollte den Phonographen nicht für Musik einsetzen, ihm schwebte vor, was David getan hatte. Er wollte, dass damit Botschaften aufgenommen wurden, dass man den Apparat am Sterbebett eines Menschen aufstellte, damit dieser seinen letzten Willen kundtun konnte. Oder, dass man ein kleines Kind aufnahm und dieselbe Person 20 Jahre später und dann noch einmal, wenn sie alt war, sodass man in einem einzigen Artifakt ein ganzes Leben einfangen würde. Er glaubte, dass das den Hinterbliebenen Trost spenden würde. Aber dies war kein Trost. Es rief mir eine Reue in Erinnerung, die ich längst für überwunden gehalten hatte. Ich hätte in Augusta auf dem Bahnsteig stehen bleiben sollen. Oder ich hätte ihn zwingen sollen, mit mir nach Boston zu kommen. Es rief mir in Erinnerung, dass ich tatsächlich und erstaunlich David noch immer liebte, dass meine Empfindungen für George oder Clarissa fürsorglich und bedacht gewesen waren, im Vergleich zu den tief in den Knochen sitzenden Gefühlen, die Davids Stimme in mir weckte. Wie soll ich es sagen? Eine Art Traurigkeit, nicht Nostalgie, nicht Schmerz, nur die plötzliche glasklare Erkenntnis, dass mein Leben ein paar Zentimeter kleiner war, als es hätte sein können. Dass ich mein bestes Jahr mit 20 gehabt hatte. Das ist also die Erinnerung des alten Mannes daran ausgelöst, durch diese Aufnahmen, die da auftauchen. Dann macht der Roman einen Satz, wir sind in einer anderen Situation. Annie sitzt vor dem Fernseher und da sieht sie einen Wissenschaftler über Volksmusik sprechen. Das ist diese Lionel und sie hört dem Geband zu. Sie langweilt sich in ihrer Ehe und eigentlich ist das Fernsehen. Wenn dort ein paar interessante Gespräche geführt werden, das, was sie daran erinnert, dass es auch ein anderes Leben gibt. Sie ist es, die diese Bänder findet, weil sie in das Haus zieht, wo einst David mit seiner Frau dann gelebt hat. Und so lässt sie dann leihende diese Bänder wieder zukommen. Aber es bleibt nicht einfach dabei, dass uns das erklärt wird, sondern jetzt sind wir plötzlich in ihrer Liebesgeschichte. Denn diese Liebesgeschichte, die begann auch in einem akademischen Milieu. Sie hat da einen Mann gesehen, aber dann hat sich das alles wieder verloren. Ganz kurz waren sie sich begegnet. Es war keine schicksalshafte Begegnung. Aber dann gibt es zufällig eine zweite Begegnung. Und die ist wie Schicksal. Dann wird aus der allwissenden Perspektive erzählt, auf der Schnellstraße und in New York war viel Verkehr. Und Annie musste einen Umweg fahren und alle zehn Blocks halten, um jemanden nach dem Weg zu fragen. Sie verfuhr sich. Müde parkte sie schließlich in irgendeiner Parklücke. Sie war zwar in der Gegend, aber nicht in der Nähe der Adresse, zu der sie wollte. Es würde einfacher sein zu laufen. Die Parklücke war direkt vor einem kleinen Getränkemarkt. Es wäre nett, eine Flasche Wein mitzubringen, dachte sie, als sie den Wagen abschloss. Sie trat in den Laden und da war Henry und kniete vor dem Weinregal. An diesem Punkt der Geschichte sagte sie später immer, sie wäre um ein Haar gar nicht nach New York gefahren. Es habe hundert Gründe gegeben, die dagegen gesprochen hätten, aber sie habe es trotzdem getan. Das ist die schicksalhafte Begegnung, die erste große Liebe und mit diesem Henry lebt sie immer noch zusammen. Das ist eine unglaubliche erzählerische Ökonomie. Ich habe schon gesagt, hundert Seiten lang ist dieser Roman. Zwei große Liebesgeschichten werden erzählt. Eine endet so früh und abrupt und bleibt als Schmerz lange präsent, aber auch als intensive Liebe. Und diese Liebe hier, die faded so aus, könnte man sagen. Es gibt eine eindrückliche Szene, in der das geschildert wird, um auch nochmal zu sagen, wie grandios das gemacht ist. Also man muss ja jetzt auf 40, 50 Seiten beschreiben, wie kann das eigentlich sein, wenn dann doch diese große Liebe da war? Wie hat sich das Paar verändert und in welchem Verhältnis steht das zueinander? Für was interessiert man sich noch am anderen? Was erwartet man vom Leben? Und dann wird eine Szene geschildert, ganz schlicht, dass er nach Hause kommt, Henry, und er hat ein Geschenk für sie dabei. Und das ist so ein Präsentkorb mit einigen Zutaten für die italienische Küche. Dabei ist dann auch noch ein Buch, Die Toskanische Küche. Und sie sieht das dann, fragt sich, was soll ich denn damit? Und dann sagt er, es ist nur, du hast neulich abends so traurig ausgesehen. Ich dachte, das würde dir vielleicht Spaß machen. Er sah zufrieden aus. Henry sagte sie leise und sah den Korb. Das sind die Zutaten für Spaghetti mit Tomatensauce. Dafür braucht man kein Kochbuch. Sie nahm das Buch und plätterte darin. Er sagt sich nämlich, sagt zu ihr, dass sie doch eigentlich immer mal nach Italien wollten, aber da kommen sie ja nicht hin. Und dann hat er doch jetzt ein schönes Geschenk gemacht. Sie starte auf eine Seite des Buchs. Sie begann zu weinen und klappte das Buch zu. Ihre Haut begann zu kribbeln. Sie spürte eine Welle von Übelkeit. Was ist, sagte er, warte mal, ist alles okay, was ist los? Das ist eine nette Idee, wirklich. Aber was ist denn los? Schnürte ihr die Kehle zu. Sie spürte, dass sie errötete. Du willst, dass ich uns Nudeln koche, sagte sie. Ist es das, was du willst? Schatz, es war nur eine Idee, tut mir leid. Sie zwang sich auf zu sehen. Er hatte den Blick abgewendet, starte aus dem Fenster und sah aus, als hätte er Schmerzen. Er bis sich auf die Lippe, steckte die Hände in die Taschen, war unruhig. Er wirkte schwach und besiegt, als würde er den Raum am liebsten so schnell wie möglich verlassen. Damit hat man die Ehe da geschildert und es bleibt nicht dabei, sondern sie begegnet noch einer Person. Das verrate ich jetzt nicht. Aus dieser Situation begegnet sie. Da wird noch einmal über die Liebe gesprochen. Sollte man sie verewigen oder sollte man sie vielleicht kurz erleben? Und als Erinnerung behalten? Darum geht es. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie diese Verfilmung sein wird. Mich fasziniert, dass man mit wirklich so schlichten Sätzen, die aber so gekonnt gesetzt sind, dass man hier einen Autor hat, der mit wenigen Worten so viel beschreiben kann, es hinbekommt zwei Liebesgeschichten, miteinander über Jahrzehnte zu verbinden, auf nur 100 Seiten. Ich kann mir fast nicht vorstellen, wie man das verfilmen will. Als Literatur zumindest ist es geglückt.
Sehr gut. Dann kommen wir später auf die große Frage, welche Frage stellt sich die Literatur zurück? Wir müssen aber jetzt in den Ukraine-Krieg abbiegen, denn CJ. Chivers hat einen investigativen Report mitgebracht. 18 Monate Recherche an allen Standorten, inklusive Front-Testgelände und Fabriken für neue Drohnen. Denn es gibt einen technologischen Wandel zu bezeichnen, den er beschreibt als der Übergang von Drohnen, die eh schon das Kriegsgeschehen bestimmen, zu semi-automatischen Drohnen, die also nicht mehr durch Störsender oder Jammer, oder wo man nicht mehr so ein Glasfaserkabel mitschleppen muss und der ganze Kram. Und damit sagt er, beginnt ein neues Zeitalter eben nicht nur in der Ukraine, denn wir haben ja schon gehört, das ist vor allem ein Testgelände, für zum Beispiel Bumblebee. Bumblebee ist eine Drohne aus einer Firma, die Eric Schmidt mitgehört, also dem ehemaligen Google-Chef, der mit Targeting schon viel Erfahrung hat. In diesem Text geht es auch darum, wie Russland oder die russische Regierung, das russische Militär, darauf reagiert. Denn man zitiert ja auch aus Geheimdiensterkenntnissen, in denen Sätze stehen wie There are no effective countermeasures against it. Also die Russen sehen sich einfach bedroht von einer Lage, bei der sie selber gerade sagen, wir haben noch keine Antwort darauf gefunden. Es geht hier um neue Technologien höchster Qualität. Und er berichtet von Panik im Kremel. Also Eric Schmidt war damals Google-Chef und versteht sich heute so als lizenzierter Waffenhändler. Der durchaus in Kiep vor Ort ist.
Wirklich?
Und dabei ist, wenn diese Technologie eingesetzt wird, um mitzugucken, wie das Produkt funktioniert. Also es ist beim Thema amerikanische Einflussnahme und so. Wir wissen ja, dass Eric Schmidt damals auch schon für das State Department nach Nordkorea gefahren ist, um da Verhandlungen zu führen und sowas. Also unter Clinton als Außenministerin und so. Nennt sich nicht ganz verwunderlich, aber ja, eine der Schlüsselszenen hier. Schmidt besucht also Kiev und beobachtet live, wie eine seiner Drohnen über 300 Meilen Entfernung dann russische Militärtransporter zerstört. Ein zweites Projekt ist Hornet. Auch davon Tausende in der Stückzahl, die jetzt im Einsatz sind. Und wir wissen ja eh, es gibt relativ viele Start-ups, die sich um diese Sachen kümmern. Also allein in der Ukraine 200 verschiedene Firmen, die Drohnen herstellen. Aber hier geht es jetzt eben um diese semi-automatischen Neuen, nur von wenigen Herstellern. Und da gibt es einen, Nazar Bigun, der hat Pixel-Log erfunden. Und Pixel-Log ist im Grunde das, was Tesla macht mit rein optischer Aufklärung, was im Straßenverkehr los ist. Also ohne weitere Sensorik, einfach nur Kameras. Und dann kann man eben so ein Pixelfeld markieren und es bleibt dann einfach im Fokus. Egal, ob sich das bewegt oder ein bisschen verändert oder wie auch immer. Also alle sind sehr beeindruckt davon, wie dieser Pixel-Log funktioniert. Ein bisschen wie in so einer Kamera, dass du einmal das Objekt markierst, das scharf sein soll und dann zieht der Fokus einfach immer mit. Und es gibt Brian Stream. Das ist ein ehemaliger Filmemacher aus New York, der durchaus Filmgeschichte mitgeschrieben hat. Kommen wir gleich drauf. Der hat VPS erfunden. Also das G in Global Positioning System wird einfach durch Visual ersetzt. Also alle wollen jetzt diese handelsüblichen, da ist halt eine Kamera mit an der Drohne, möglichst breit ausbeutendechnisch, dass man das einfach nutzt. Beschrieben werden auch Soldaten vor Ort. Die werden natürlich immer nur, wie man das so macht, mit Vornamen genannt. Juri zum Beispiel kam als Arzt, besucht immer wieder Soldatenfriedhöfe, ist also auch moralisch und emotional angetrieben, da seinem Land zu helfen und sagt eben, ja, also ich habe mit Antibiotika Bakterien bekämpft und jetzt töt ich halt andere Käfer. Killing Bugs. Damit meint er dann die Russen. Also wir haben sozusagen diese Gemengelage aus, es ist Eile, es ist drifftig, es ist ein echter Krieg, die Leute sind alle emotional involviert und dann kommt Eric Schmidt und bringt einfach neue Technologie mit. Wo ich jetzt gleich kommentierend sagen würde, ja, ja, also dafür braucht man das Konfliktfeld auch noch eine Weile. Wenn es jetzt immer heißt, da droht jetzt bald der Frieden und die Investoren finden das nicht gut. Also ich kann mir das noch nicht so ganz vorstellen, dass da als bald Frieden herrscht.
Ja, wir haben ja auch schon Alex Grabs Kollegen aus London gehört dazu.
Ja.
Der sagt, das ist leider, hat er noch eingefügt schnell, es ist ein tolles Labor.
Genau, also die Unternehmen wissen ja schon, was sie daran haben, dass da Krieg herrscht.
Aber es ist ja auch so interessant, ich meine, wir haben ja die Phase gut vor Augen, Consumer Electronics, diese ganzen sozialen Medien, die Google-Suche, Don't Be Evil, dass man eigentlich so eine Welt produziert, aber in der man sich eben nur noch die Frage stellte, wie viel Überwachung soll es denn sein, um herauszufinden, welche Bettwäsche ich kaufen will oder soll. Und jetzt ist es aber dann doch irgendwann immer dieser Schritt hin zu den Hardfacts, zu Militär. Und dann ist es wieder so ganz, ganz traditioneller Kapitalismus, so wie es seit immer funktioniert hat, von der Stahlproduktion früher bis hin jetzt zu Google. Es hat sich dann eigentlich vom ersten Weltkrieg bis heute nicht so viel geändert.
Genau. Und die ganze intellektuelle Schicht hat halt Szenarioplanung und Spieltheorie im Kalten Krieg gemacht, ist dann einmal in Silicon Valley und nach in die Wall Street gewandert und jetzt...
Kommen sie wieder zurück.
Wieder in ihre neuen Gebiete und sind wieder im Krieg. Also es geht um das Terminal Guidance System so allgemein. Die Drohne wird schon kontrolliert gestartet und in eine Richtung gelenkt. Aber die letzten Meter fliegt sie ohne Funkverkehr, also völlig autark. Sie hat ihre eigene Energieversorgung an Bord und damit ist alles erledigt. Alles andere findet innerhalb dieses Geräts statt. Bumblebee hat also eine Trefferquote von 70 Prozent, während die Russen es zuletzt gut hingekriegt haben, sich komplett abzuschirmen durch dieses Jamming und so weiter. Die wurden ja hunderte Kilometer einfach mit Draht überzogen, also wo man wie durch so ein Drahttunnel fährt, einfach nur damit sie ihre Front bestellen können, weil das ist dann wie so ein Faridescher Käfig, da sieht man dann, kann man nicht groß durchfunkten und so weiter. Und jetzt können diese Drohnen einfach alles, die fliegen in Gebäude rein, orientieren sich da selbstständig, explodieren an der richtigen Stelle. Es sind alles Kamikaze-Dronen, also das kommt auch noch dazu. Es geht jetzt nicht darum, hier Material zu schonen oder so, sondern das wird produziert, um komplett vernichtet zu werden. Und das nächste Problem, was sie noch lösen wollen, ist Nachschub an der Front ist schwierig. Also wäre es doch gut, wenn ein Drohnenpilot einfach eine Leitdrohne startet und dann so ein Schwarm quasi in der richtigen Formation hinterherfliegt.
Das ist ja wie in dem von dir eben angesprochenen Roman.
Genau, wie bei David Suarez. Da sind halt die Drohnen glaube ich so wahnsinnig klein. Also so, aber Bumblebee als Hummel ist ja auch so zu sein. Da weiß man ja, um welche Größen Zielsetzung es so geht. Klar, man braucht immer Payload, die dann explodieren soll. Entsprechend ein bisschen größer. Die Drohnen sind wahnsinnig billig und es besteht die Möglichkeit, die Radikalität wird hier formuliert, dass die gesamte konventionelle militärische Infrastruktur, Zitat, obsolet wird. Also im Sinne von Rheinmetall und hier nochmal ein Marschluckkörper und ein Panzer und so. Dann sagen die, wozu genau. Also einfach nur Zeug, das kaputt geht.
Ja, das ist der Konflikt, den wir jetzt bald erleben werden. Und wir sehen ja auch schon, wie sich verschiedene Thinktanks da aufstellen. Also die einen Thinktanks sind eher auf der alten Schiene, Rheinmetall und weitere Panzer und Munitionsproduzenten. Während auf der anderen Seite diese Thinktanks sind, die sich mit Startups wie Helsing verbünden und da gerade jetzt lobbyieren bei der Politik und sagen die eigentlichen Milliarden müssen an diese jungen Unternehmen, die den Drohnenkrieg in die Zukunft führen.
Genau. Die Zitate, die das begleiten, lauten dann, ich glaube, wir haben das Monster erschaffen von vor Ort. Jetzt hier ein schöner Abschnitt, der für dich vielleicht ganz interessant ist, denn der Brian Stream hat eine Firma gegründet, die heißt Air-Robo, also Luft und Roboter. Mit der hat er Drohnenaufnahmen hergestellt, zum Beispiel für den Film Spider-Man Homecoming oder A Quiet Place. Spider-Man wissen wir ja, da muss ein bisschen durch Gebäude geflogen werden und so. Und die Kamera muss aber trotzdem auf einen noch nicht vorhandenen, sondern später erst eingefügten Spider-Man. Und das muss aber trotzdem alles passen. Also da braucht man schon so ein bisschen technische IQ, damit das alles passt. So und er fällt dir mit dem schönen Zitat auf, If you think military drone missions are hard, try making Steven Spielberg happy. Also der ist auch in den Ukraine-Krieg gegangen, weil ihm das Hollywood-Business, das gerade wegstirbt, ein bisschen zu brutal war. Ja. Denk mal darüber, was das bedeutet. So und er hat jetzt eben dieses Visionell Positioning, also dass man den Shot, finde ich auch witzig, dass man in der Film- und in der Kriegstechnik vom Shot spricht, den man da einfangen will.
Gibt es ja Krieg und Kino, diesen großen Essay von Paul Virilio, der darauf auch schon eingeht.
Genau, also da hat man eh schon so eine semantische und in der Fragestellung auch fast ähnliche Bezugnahmen. Da ist der Technologietransfer natürlich entsprechend easy. Eric Schmidt selbst spricht hier warnend, aber ironischerweise vom Dr. Strange-Love-Szenario. Was ist, wenn die Bombe fliegt und man hat nicht mehr so ganz die Hoheit darüber. Skynet Terminator wird natürlich angesprochen. Ich selber sage Kill Decision von Daniel oder David Suarez. Ich glaube Daniel. Das sollte man sich nochmal anschauen. Und Eric Schmidt wird hier und der Autor der Chivers verwendet das ganz hervorragend auch als Poante. Er spricht vom Gatling Paradox. Eric Schmidt rechtfertigt sein Handeln heute als guter Liberaler mit der Hoffnung auf totale Abschreckung. Wenn hier eine Person ein ganzes Land mit Drohnen überziehen kann. Und wir sehen ja auch in China schon, das finde ich auch eine interessante Machtdemonstration, dass man in China einfach sagt, wir machen kein Feuerwerk. Wir schicken 40.000 Drohnen, die Bilder malen. Und das Besondere ist, die ganze Welt sieht es. Wir wissen bei jeder Einzelne, wo sie ist. Wir können in jeder Billisekunde sagen, was sie tun soll. Da sitzen ja nicht 40.000 Leute und steuern die, sondern das ist natürlich einfach Technologie. Das ist eine Show of Force, würde ich mal sagen.
Da weiß man wieder, die zu schätzen, die bollern.
Genau. Also das ist wirklich sehr abschreckend, das zu sehen, wenn man sich überlegt, ja, die haben jetzt so Lichter dran gehängt, aber da kann man auch Payload dran hängen. Und jetzt kommt der Autor hier mit der Erfindung des Maschinengewehrs, denn wir hatten ja schon mal diese Idee von Richard Gatling, ich habe das Maschinengewehr erfunden 1877. Das ist so gefährlich und abschreckend, es wird keine menschlichen Kriege mehr geben. Und dann dauert es 70 Jahre und wir haben der Soldat James Ryan mit Steven Spielberg, zeigt uns zehn Minuten lang, ja ja Maschinengewehre, genau, da geht dann die Klappe auf und dann zack, zack, zack, alle tot. So und dieses Gatling Paradox muss ich sagen, es ist alles sehr potenziell aufgeladen, man weiß nicht genau in welche Richtung und der Mensch spielt doch eine entscheidende Rolle. In der Hinsicht ist Eric Schmidt mit all seiner Targeting-Erfahrung aus dem Google-Werbe-Business in Verknüpfung mit diesen Leuten, die aus der Filmbranche kommen und einfach wissen, wie man mit einer Kamera umgeht, plus den ohnehin großen Erfolg der Drohne in diesen Kriegseinsätzen, haben wir hier eine Gemengelage, bei der ich denke, crazy.
Ja, ja und diese Idee, die ja die ganze Zeit ventiliert wird, dass wenn genügend dann aufgerüstet ist, wo man sich ja mal fragt, wie viel ist dann genug? Also da frage ich mich, gibt es ja auch eine Obergrenze, sagen wir dann 500.000 Drohnen oder was, dass dann die Abschreckung groß genug ist, aber die ist ja nie groß genug, weil die anderen auch immer in dem Spiel mitspielen wollen und weitermachen und dann ja nicht sagen, ach so, jetzt haben die uns aber zu sehr abgeschreckt, jetzt werde ich aber nichts mehr tun, sondern es ist ja ein Verhältnis zueinander und nicht einfach eines, wo der eine angibt, was passiert und dann ist Schluss.
Diese Abschreckung gibt es einfach nicht. Das kann man, also dieses Argument kann man historisch aussatieren, weshalb ich nochmal anmerke, ich formuliere als Spaßpublicist meine Texte zum Thema Atombombe. Ich will damit eigentlich mehr einen Diskurs kurz als…
Ja, aber selbst diese zeigt ja immer wieder, dass trotzdem Kriege geführt werden. Dann über Stellvertreter.
Ja, genau. Also in der Hinsicht, das ist auch ein sehr langer Text. Also New York Times hat dann doch immer, ich habe ihn mir vorlesen lassen hauptsächlich, der steht dann einfach 45 Minuten oder so. In meiner Speechify-App. Das kann man mal wieder auf Deutsch irgendwo sehen, dass mir mal jemand einen Text darlegt.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht, kann man das überhaupt kritisieren? Ist es nicht eigentlich immer genau richtig?
Ist immer genau richtig.
Findest du?
Im internationalen Vergleich werden wir bewundert und...
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Jetzt pass mal auf. Rechtswissenschaftler Uwe Volkmann hier an der Uni Frankfurt hat einen Text geschrieben, der heißt Die unpolitische Gewalt in der FAZ erschienen. Da geht es um die Begründungen oder beziehungsweise den Begründungsstil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts. Er greift sich erstmal etwas heraus, nämlich die Regelung zur Triage. Die ist ja eingeführt worden, 22, inmitten der Pandemie hat man gesagt, da muss was getan werden. Aber jetzt kommt das Bundesverfassungsgericht dann am 23. September 2025. Da gab es also einen Beschluss des ersten Senats. Uwe Volkmann schreibt, diese Triagemaßnahmen waren 2022 inmitten der Covid-Pandemie in das Infektionsschutzgesetz eingefügt worden, nachdem das Bundesverfassungsgericht in einem voraufgegangenen Urteil vom Ende 2021 ausdrücklich eine gesetzliche Grundlage für den Fall des Eintritts der entsprechenden Situation gefordert hatte. Auf die dagegen von einigen Ärzten mit Unterstützung ihrer Standesorganisationen erhobenen Verfassungsbeschwerde erklärte das Bundesverfassungsgericht die Neuregelung nun für mit dem Grundgesetz unvereinbar und nichtig, dem Bund fehle für eine solche Regelung die Gesetzgebungskompetenz. Heißt, das muss also eigentlich an die Länder gehen. Also wir halten jetzt erstmal fest, es gibt da vom Bundesverfassungsgericht den Auftrag, ihr müsst da eigentlich was machen. Dann machen die was, dann gibt es eine Verfassungsbeschwerde und das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, ja stimmt, könnt ihr so nicht machen, ist eigentlich nicht Kompetenz des Bundes. Was ist das eigentlich, wenn das jetzt so delegiert wird? Das ja erstmal wird das dann formal juristisch argumentiert und Uwe Volkmann sagt, das sei ja auch erstmal so hinzunehmen, das sei schon sauber argumentiert in der Logik, in der man sich befindet. Diese Logik, sagt er, folgt einem uralten Werk, Staatsrecht des Deutschen Reiches von 1877 von Paul Laband, wo es ausdrücklich heißt, die juristische Arbeit als rein logische Denktätigkeit zu begreifen. Für ihre Lösung gibt es kein anderes Mittel als die Logik. Alle historischen, philosophischen oder politischen Betrachtungen sind dafür ohne Belang. Das heißt rechtspositivistisch wird hier argumentiert, aber dieser Uwe Volkmann fragt sich nun, ist das eigentlich gut, wenn man rein juristisch immer nur vorgeht oder müsste man nicht eigentlich dieses unpolitische hinterfragen und politisch sehen? Also wir haben zwar jetzt immer so einen Diskurs gehabt, um Gottes willen, wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch noch politisiert wird, dann wird es ja ganz schlimm. Aber hier wird natürlich gezeigt, was das bedeutet, wenn es unpolitisch bleibt. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hatte selbst in seiner ersten Entscheidung zur Triageproblematik Ende 2021 zwar eine gesetzliche Regelung zum Umgang mit entsprechenden Situationen gefordert, aber mit keinem Wort auch nur angedeutet, dass hier eines liegen könnte. Auch im Darauf-Im-Gang-Gesetz, also ein Problem liegen könnte, dass auch im Darauf-Im-Gang gesetzte Gesetzgebungsverfahren hatte die Frage keine Rolle gespielt, wer eigentlich dafür zuständig ist. Die Kläger im jetzigen Verfassungsbeschwerdeverfahren, mehrere von ihren Standesorganisationen unterstützte Ärzte, hatten dem gegenüber die fehlende Kompetenz des Bundes zwar gerügt, aber wohl eher nur der Vollständigkeit halber. Gestört haben sie sich am Inhalt des Gesetzes. Das heißt, es gibt eine Verfassungsbeschwerde, die richtet sich vorwiegend auf den Inhalt, aber das Bundesverfassungsgericht setzt sich nicht mit dem Inhalt auseinander, sondern fragt, wer ist eigentlich zuständig. Ihnen jetzt, also die da die Verfassungsbeschwerde eingereicht haben, sagt Uwe Volkmann, wurden jetzt eigentlich Steine gegeben statt Brot. Und das wirft die Frage auf, so folgt man, ob sich überhaupt etwas Positives abgewinnen lässt an dem Bundesverfassungsgericht. Das sagt ja, das ist Länderkompetenz. Sie wäre zunächst von den praktischen Folgen her zu beantworten, diese Frage. Diese liegen darin, dass der Ball nun im Feld der Länder liegt. Und diese sehen müssen, was sie daraus machen. Gibt es also einen vernünftigen oder sonst wie einleuchtenden Grund, mit der Aufgabe einer Triagegesetzgebung statt des Bundes nun die Länder zu betrauen? Dafür wären zunächst die verschiedenen Szenarien durchzumustern, die sich dadurch ergeben. Eine keineswegs nur theoretische Möglichkeit besteht darin, dass einzelne Länder überhaupt keine Regelung treffen. Und das gibt es zum Beispiel auch beim Thema Sterbehilfe. Das ist also gar nichts Neues. Dann fragt er sich aber auch, naja, was wäre denn eigentlich, wenn die sich alle einigen, alle Länder unter sich auf eine Regelung? Na ja, dann hätte es ja auch der Bund regeln können, wenn man ja eh eine Einigkeit haben will. Wenn man keine Einigkeit herstellt, wenn jedes Land da so eine eigene Idee verfolgt und eine eigene Gesetzgebung herausgibt, dann bedeutet das natürlich, dass möglicherweise dem einen in Wiesbaden geholfen wird, dem anderen in Mainz aber nicht mehr und es am Ende entscheidend ist, ob man, wenn es die Not dann will und man mit einem Krankenwagen liegt, ob man nach Wiesbaden oder nach Mainz gefahren wird. Wo sehen wir hier irgendeinen Vorteil? Volkmann fragt sich das und kann es eigentlich nicht beantworten, weil es schwer zu beantworten ist. Vielleicht ist da nichts. Insgesamt, so lässt sich bis hierher sagen, bekommen die Länder eine Regelungsaufgabe zugeschanzt, bei deren Lösung sie sich nur verheben können, zumal sie ohnehin damit rechnen müssen, dass jede Lösung, die sie wählen, von irgendjemanden erneut vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht getragen wird. Heißt also, das Gericht tut jetzt zwar so, als hätte man jetzt was geregelt oder etwas mal klargemacht, da müsst ihr euch darum kümmern, aber eigentlich ist die Verwirrung größer, wodurch die parlamentarische Demokratie nicht gerade gestützt wird, sagt Folgtmann hier. Wie steht also das Gericht auch nach dieser Entscheidung da? Und er sagt, naja, das würde ja auch nicht gut dastehen, denn man würde ja eigentlich hier sehen, dass das Gericht gar nicht eine Anweisung gibt, bei der man klar was befolgen kann. Denn zunächst mal gab es diese Triage-Situation und da wurde damals nur vom Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt, dass der Gesetzgeber das regeln soll. Aber damals wurde nicht gemeint damit oder wurde zumindest nicht explizit darauf verwiesen, das sind die 16 verschiedenen Gesetzgeber der Länder nämlich. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich die Gesetzgeber, so formuliert er es hier, ins offene Messer laufen lassen. Und jetzt erinnern wir uns, wenn wir mal von diesem Triage-Fall weggehen, daran, dass ja die Regierungskoalition auch deshalb zerbrochen ist, also die Ampelkoalition, weil wir ja da dieses Urteil hatten, des zweiten Senats zur Schuldenbremse. Da heißt es, das markanteste Beispiel aus jüngster Zeit ist das, vor zwei Jahren ergangene Urteil des zweiten Senats zur Schuldenbremse, dass diese in all ihren Bestandteilen immer auf die jeweils rigideste Weise interpretierte. Ohne, dass man sich um die politischen Auswirkungen groß scherte. Eine Regierung ist über diesem Urteil zerbrochen. Das Land durchlitt eine quälend lange Phase politischer Lähmung. Und eine neue Regierung konnte zuletzt nur noch deshalb so schnell zusammenfinden, weil man gerade so eben im alten Bundestag noch eine verfassungsändernde Mehrheit zustande bekam, um die Schuldenbremse den Bedürfnissen der Zeit entsprechend zu reformieren und so die unmittelbaren Wirkungen des Urteils zu beseitigen. Die Frage für Volkmann ist hier, wenn man nur so fein juristisch argumentiert, nur positivistisch, fehlt da nicht etwas. Sowas wie Akzeptabilität, integrierende Wirkung und Sachgerechtigkeit. Müsste man nicht eigentlich das Nachdenken über das, was man da verursacht, auch im politischen Sinne mit einbeziehen, statt nur einen solchen Formalismus zu betreiben. Ich hätte das alles nie so formulieren können. Ich habe nur mich manchmal sehr gewundert, dass immer diese Länderkompetenz und wenn die Länder dann die Bundeskompetenz und dass das immer in diesen Urteilen so hervorgehoben wird, dann alle so sagen, ach so, okay. Aber man fragt sich schon, welche Dysfunktionalität geht eigentlich auch mit einer solchen Institution, die ja an sich hoch zu schätzen ist, einher. Und offenbar ist das eine gewisse Mode, die sich breit gemacht hat in der Juristerei, dieses rein formal juristische Argumentieren, nur auf die Logik ausgehend. Und möglicherweise ist das auch ein Problem und ein Blockierer von großen Veränderungen. Ich finde, das ist ein interessanter Beitrag und bin gespannt, ob da sich Kontroversen dran anschließen, da das bestimmt viele anders sehen werden aus der Zunft.
Ja, ich zum Beispiel. Also ich sehe es wirklich ganz anders, als er erschien.
Ja, jetzt vor wenigen Tagen.
29. Dezember erschien im Pföter, finde ich schon mal, ist für die FAZ, die sich ja dafür rühmt, den Einspruch als eigene Marke jetzt aufzubauen. Also hat bestimmt auch in der Zeitung für Kontroverse geführt. Denn selbst bei dem Beispiel des Schuldenbremsenurteils würde ich sagen, das Verfassungsgericht wird angerufen, um das, was in der Verfassung steht, auszulegen. Dass Zeit ins Land gegangen ist seit 2009 und andere Sachen thematisch inhaltlich drücken. Darauf muss ja die Politik reagieren. Und dass die Politik angehalten wurde, diese Grundgesetze neu zu formulieren. Also da sind wir ja mit sozusagen erste Reihe in dieser Argumentation. Dass man von der Politik jetzt verlangt, eine vernünftige Verschuldungsgesetzeslage zu schaffen. Wir haben das ja auch kritisiert, dass da eine Entdemokratisierung des Parlaments stattfand, in dem gesagt wurde, der Parlamentarier ist seinem Gewissen verpflichtet, darf aber nur noch so und so weit entscheiden, weil der Rest regelt das Grundgesetz und da liegen wir einfach alle in Ketten. So, die Antwort ist also nicht, dass das Verfassungsgericht jetzt plötzlich aufgrund einer Nachrichtenlage imperativ Tagesschau plötzlich das Gesetz anders auslegen. Und das ist ja kein Originalismus oder sowas, sondern man interpretiert halt im Grundgesetz, was da drinsteht. Das ist das eine. Also das Versagen ist hier politisch. Die FDP hat sich einfach darüber gefreut, dass die Gesetzeslage ist, wie sie ist, weil dann Christian Lindner immer sagen konnte, seht ihr, ich bin ein ganz verfassungstreuer Finanzminister und das Land ist dabei in die Knie gegangen. So, das jetzt nachträglich dem Bundesverfassungsgericht unterzuschieben, als ihr hättet ja da einfach das ein bisschen lockerer sehen können. Nee, das ist dann schon die demokratische Entscheidung der Parlamentarier, wie sie ihr Gesetz überhaupt gestalten.
Na, aber es geht doch hier darum, dass diese Gesetze so ausgelegt werden, dass sie nur formal juristisch stimmen müssen. Alles andere spielt keine Rolle. Also inhaltliche Konsequenzen sind egal.
Deswegen war ja die Schuldenbremse so hart. Deswegen haben wir ja 15 Jahre verschwendet.
Ja, aber die Schuldenbremse wurde ja jetzt auch nicht reformiert dadurch, durch diesen Schritt des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, sondern das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat gesagt, diesen Verschiebe-Bahnhof, den ihr da gemacht habt, mit Klimatransformation, bla bla bla, den könnt ihr nicht machen, weil wir da nochmal genau nachgesehen haben. Oder jetzt bei der Triage als Fall wird ja nur gesagt, ja, wir setzen uns jetzt gar nicht da inhaltlich primär miteinander, sondern sagen, das ist nicht bunt, sondern Ländersache und spielen es an die Länder zurück. Und da fragt man sich ja jetzt schon, mit Uwe Volkmann zurecht, finde ich, was bedeutet das eigentlich dann für ein verantwortliches Handeln, wenn man jetzt sagt, gut, 16 Bundesländer, die sollen mal gucken, ob sie das klären, werden wir zugleich wissen, dass zum Beispiel bei dieser Frage der aktiven Sterbehilfe, das einfach so brach liegt. Dann kann man glaube ich nicht einfach nur sagen, ja, das liegt an der Politik, sondern offenbar wird hier hier in einer Art und Weise begründet, die vielleicht andere Dinge mit hinzunehmen sollte, womit man nicht gleich Bundesverfassungsgericht nach der Tagesschau ausrichtet. Auch wenn ich sehe, diese Gefahr besteht natürlich da, dann braucht man natürlich ein Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht mehr, weil dann ist alles nur noch politisch. Aber die Frage ist ja schon nach den Dimensionen, die eine solche formal juristische Entscheidung hat. Und da wird ja hier eigentlich eine Frage der Verhältnismäßigkeit von Uwe Volkmann aufgerufen.
Aber all die Fragen, die du stellst, also zum Thema Triage, zum Thema Sterbehilfe oder zum Thema wie ist Verschuldung geregelt, möchte ich doch, dass das in einem demokratischen Prozess alle vier Jahre mit verschiedenen Vorlagen mir dargelegt wird. Und dann suche ich mir das Programm raus, das mir passt und lebe mit den Konsequenzen. Weil ich habe ja in vier Jahren wieder die Möglichkeit. Was ich ja nicht will, ist, dass irgendwelche Juristen, weil gerade die Sachthemen drücken, jetzt eine Entscheidung treffen, die vielleicht in meinem Sinne sind. So wie du jetzt sagst, naja, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat es ja in der Hand, das ein bisschen lockerer auszulegen. Ja, aber die Parlamentarier haben das super hart da reingeschrieben. Ich will ja auch nicht das mal ein für mich wichtiges Anliegen, das super hart reingeschrieben wird. Und dann später heißt es, ja, aber das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich gerade so ein bisschen in den Wind gelehnt. Und da hieß es halt, nee, wir haben ja gerade eine Pandemie, wir müssen das jetzt mal locker sehen. Und wir haben in Deutschland und deswegen ja auch diese, die reagieren ja auf eine Verfassungsbeschwerde. Ja, aber sie haben das halt in drei Abschnitten. Entweder sagen sie von vornherein, dafür sind wir nicht zuständig. Oder sie sagen, wir klären hier nur Zuständigkeiten. Mietendeckel zum Beispiel. Darf das Land Berlin oder Hamburg Mietendeckel machen oder ist das einfach BGB? Also muss der Gesetzgeberbund da einfach für das bürgerliche Gesetzbuch grundsätzlich eine Entscheidung treffen. So und die markieren einfach, wo der nächste Wahlkampf stattfinden muss, wenn jemand beim Thema Bildung, Sterben, Miete ein Problem hat. Greift aber nicht selber in diesen und das ist ja das, was in Amerika stattfindet, dass einfach eine Handvoll Richter das ganze Land im Griff hat, weil die nämlich dann über ihre Belange hinaus, also sie werden eigentlich nur angefragt zum Thema, was war das zuletzt, ich weiß gar nicht, und dann hieß es ja und damit sind alle parlamentarischen Einwände gegen die Macht des Präsidenten nichtig. Man sagt sich so, warte mal Momentchen.
Ich sehe auch die Gefahr, nämlich der Politisierung des Gerichts. Also wenn er sagt, die unpolitische Gewalt ist das Problem, dann ist er das Gegenteil von unpolitischer Gewalt, eher politische Gewalt.
Ja und wir hätten sofort einen Text mit, die überforderte Gewalt zum Beispiel, die überlastete Gewalt.
Ja, ja, nur du siehst ja schon auch die Probleme, die hier beschrieben werden, dass die nicht besonders gut sind, wenn aus Karlsruhe kommt, der Gesetzgeber soll sich bitte um die Triage kümmern, dann kümmert sich der Gesetzgeber, dann gibt es eine Verfassungsbeschwerde, dann sagen die, ja der Gesetzgeber ist ja gar nicht der Bund, sondern das Land. Dann muss man das ja vielleicht früher mitteilen, dass das das Land ist.
Wenn die Inkompetenz der politischen Klasse so weit geht, dass man die Kompetenzen nicht im Blick hat, wie sie im Gesetz stehen zwischen Land und Bund, auch wenn das bedeutet, und das ist natürlich bei Wiesbaden und Mainz wirklich nur eine Brückenüberquerung.
Aber du wirst doch sagen, dass es wirklich keinen Sinn ergibt, dass ein Triagegesetz länderspezifisch ist.
Doch, das macht ganz großen Sinn. Ich würde sogar sagen, lieber kommunalpolitisch.
Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Na ja, du hast nun mal ein konkretes Krankenhaus und einen konkreten Krankenfall und konkrete Wege dazwischen und eine konkrete Anzahl von Ärzten und eine konkrete Anzahl von...
Na ja, aber eine Triage ist eine Triage. Also du kannst ja jetzt nicht von Rheinland-Pfalz zu Hessen einen Unterschied machen, wie Leute in Krankenhäusern behandelt werden.
Also ich würde zwischen Gelsenkirchen, Kiel und Garmisch-Partenkirchen in so vielen Möglichkeiten wie geht, politische Unterschiede einziehen. Das muss unterschiedlich geregelt werden. Wir haben doch gerade ein Buch gelesen.
Aber doch nicht bei so existenziellen Fragen.
Nicht gerade bei denen. Wir haben doch gerade ein Buch gelesen, in dem klar ist, wir haben Gebiete, in denen 5% aller Spitzenuniversitäten anlanden. Und dann haben wir diese Region.
Es geht ja zum Beispiel um die Frage bei der Triage. Darf ein Patient von dem Gerät gelöst werden, um jemanden anderen zu retten, der sehr wahrscheinlich gerettet wird, weil er jünger ist, stärker ist oder sonst etwas. Das ist ja beispielsweise eine klassische Triagefrage. Und die kann man für sich beantworten im Allgemeinen. Und da muss man nicht wissen, wo ist eine Uniklinik gerade und wo ist ein Stadtkrankenhaus. Sondern man kann diese Frage, der man sich offenbar stellen muss, wenn man ein Triagegesetz will, dann kann man diese Frage beantworten, regionsunabhängig. Man kann über Regionen nachdenken, wenn man sagt, wie viele Krankenhäuser brauchen wir, dann werden manche Stadteile, manche Länder mehr brauchen als andere, weil die eine höhere Bevölkerungsdichte haben. Aber in dieser grundsätzlichen Frage, weil sonst kann ich ja, sonst brauche ich ja gar keinen Bund mehr. Dann kann ich ja überall, dann machen wir Wilder Westen. Dann hat jeder, jedes Kaff hat da sein, sein eigenes Law and Order System.
Ja, ich verstehe total diese Sehgewohnheit, die du da hast im Sinne von. Und jetzt muss ich halt ernsthaft fragen, warum hast du da vor Angst und warum ist die Lösung dafür der nationale Rahmen? Ja, wie bei der Wehrpflicht?
Der nationale Rahmen ist deshalb sinnvoll, weil es praktikabel ist. Es ist ja, wenn du, wenn du jetzt gerne noch runtergehen würdest, sogar von den 16 Ländern weg hin zu Kommunen. Und die machen alle ein eigenes Gesetz zur Triage. Und jeder kann wieder eine Verfassungsbeschwerde einreichen. Und dann macht Karlsruhe in den nächsten 100 Jahren nur noch Verfassungsbeschwerden über Triagegesetzgebungen in Kommunen.
Und genau das würde ja nicht stattfinden, wenn die Leute mal wissen würden, dass jedes Bundesland auch ein Verfassungsgericht für die dort geltende Verfassung hat. Es muss nicht immer alles in der Bundesliga und Champions League geklärt werden. Man kann auch einfach mal die Gerichte anrufen, die dafür zuständig sind. Und davon gibt es eben in Deutschland einige. Und wir haben ganz zentrale Fragestellungen. Bildung zum Beispiel, Pflege und Gesundheitssystem und so. Da würde ich sagen, die Unterschiede in Deutschland sind so groß, dass man gar keinen einheitlichen Gesetzeskörper drüber spannen kann. Weil wir einfach in Gelsenkirchen oder in einer thüringischen Landschaftslage, wo man sich fragt, ja, das sind ja ganz schöne Gesetze, nur materiell ist hier gar nichts gegeben. Also, ja, von Gesetz her muss hier das Kind in den Kindergarten gehen dürfen. Und dann ist die Frage, wer genau, also wir können nicht die einzige Person, die überhaupt unter 50 Jahre ist, jetzt hier Gesetzeswesen einspannen und so.
Wir sind ja hier in einer Debatte, die hier aufgemacht wird, eigentlich zwischen Rechtspositivismus und Naturrecht. Also gibt es noch andere Verbindlichkeiten, die leitend sein sollten? Ja, da kann man dann bis zur Ratbruchsen Formel oder so. Ja, gibt es irgendwas, wo man grundsätzlich dann Nein sagen sollte, auch wenn es formal juristisch irgendwie ginge? Oder Argument, schafft man es mit einem reinen Rechtspositivismus, eigentlich eine Demokratie zu gewährleisten? Die Frage stellt sich ja hier. Und ich finde, ich kann dem auch gar nicht jetzt, ich kann das nicht 100 Prozent verteidigen, weil ich zu wenig Ahnung davon habe. Ich finde nur eigentlich diese Diskussion hoch interessant, weil sie uns ja genau an den Punkt führt, wo wir sagen müssen, ja, das ist also alles logisch argumentiert. Aber irgendwie merken wir auch, das birgt ja ganz viele Probleme. Und möglicherweise müsste man andere Kriterien mit hineinbringen, die er ja auch hier nennt, bei denen aber auch schon wieder klar ist, ja, wie werden die definiert und wo stehen wir dann eigentlich dazu? Wie stehen wir dann eigentlich dazu? Und wie sehr politisieren wir dadurch? Also verabschieden wir uns dann eigentlich von dieser rein positivistischen Rechtsprechung. Und das ist ein hochinteressanter Debattenbeitrag, finde ich deshalb, der auch, glaube ich, Widerhall finden wird. Deshalb, weil man natürlich eine große Dysfunktionalität aufgrund dieser Urteile auch hat. Natürlich gibt es diese große politische Inkompetenz. Und die Regierung ist jetzt nicht nur zerbrochen, weil man in Karlsruhe gesagt hat, du, du, du, das macht man nicht mehr weiter.
Das hätte Christian Lindner auch ohne das Urteil geschafft.
Aber man sieht, welche Effekte daraus sofort hervorgingen. Und du hast ja damals sogar am Presseklub dazu gesessen und hast gesagt, das ist aber toll, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht das jetzt mal gemacht hat. Dann können wir jetzt uns Kleid verschaffen. Aber du siehst, es ist ja dann nicht zu einem positiven Signal gekommen.
Ja, und das ist nämlich der große Unterschied zwischen uns beiden, dass ich sage, nein, es sollten grundsätzlich alle Menschen wählen dürfen. Und der erste Einwand ist, ja, aber dann wählen auch die falschen. Also dann wird auch die AfD gewählt.
Nein, nein, das sage ich nicht.
Ja, genau.
Nein, das ist überhaupt nicht meint.
Doch, das war genau der Tenor, als es hieß, ich will wählen ab Null.
Nein, ich habe.
Da war der erste Widerspruch. Aber dann wählen ja auch Leute die AfD.
Nein, mit der AfD, das habe ich nicht gebracht. Ich habe gesagt, ich will nicht, dass irgendwelche Leute. Du hattest die Idee, dass dann progressiver gewählt wird, wenn junge Leute, wenn Kinder wählen dürfen, was ich nicht glaube, was ich nicht glaube. Aber ich bin nicht der, ich bin nicht der, du bist viel mehr für ein AfD-Verbot vermutlich als ich es bin.
Also ich bin total für die Überprüfung aller Parteien.
Insofern, insofern will ich da nur sagen, naja, das ist nicht mein Argument. Ich habe nicht Angst vor denen, die falsch wählen, sondern ich frage mich nur, ob man durch eine solche Gesetzgebung eine Dysfunktionalität herstellt und sich so sehr an die Logik klammert, ohne dabei noch über die Verhältnismäßigkeit nachzudenken. Und wo müsste eine Verhältnismäßigkeit sein? Kann man das machen oder ist das Risiko zu groß und sollte man einfach diese gewisse Dysfunktionalität beibehalten, um aber dem Rechtspositivismus die Treue zu halten? Das finde ich ist eine interessante Debatte. Die können wir jetzt nicht hier schlussendlich entscheiden. Aber dass überhaupt mal so ein Beitrag jetzt da stattfindet, finde ich genau richtig und hoffe mir mehr dazu.
Und ich möchte nochmal markieren. Ich habe ja schon markiert, dass ich die kommunalpolitischen Thematisierung grundsätzlich so interessant finde, dass ich denke, das könnte durchaus ein Buchprojekt sein, weil ich immer wieder beobachte und vor allem angeleitet durch Fernsehkonsum und allgemeine Nachrichtenlagen, dass wir das kommunalpolitische Leben, also dass wir dem kommunal oder dass wir unserem lebensweltlichen Leben in den Nachbarschaften, in denen wir tatsächlich unseren Geschäften nachgehen, das eigene Abstraktionslevel Politik nicht zugestehen, sondern immer mindestens eine Ebene zu hoch ansetzen. Und dann müssen plötzlich, zum Beispiel bei der bayerischen Regelung, neu zum Thema Grundsteuer, dann macht es plötzlich keinen Unterschied mehr, ob wir von einem Quadratmeter mitten in München reden oder von einem, wo sich die Bewohner schon sagen, ich würde gern zu Thüringen gehören, damit hier mal überhaupt wieder was los ist. Bayern bietet mir gar nichts. So, und ich sage, da können wir bei manchen Rechtsthemen keinen einheitlichen Schirm drüber spannen. Und beim Thema Leben und Tod halte ich das für eine ganz relevante Fragestellung. Also ja, weil du jetzt immer das Leben retten willst und so weiter. Und das ist natürlich alles total akzeptabel. Nur es macht halt, es führt einfach zu praktischen Konsequenzen. Und sehr viele Menschen müssen sich plötzlich mit Fragestellungen beschäftigen, daraus wächst auch viel Bürokratie, die sie überhaupt gar nicht betrifft, sondern einfach nur aus dem Abstraktionslevel. Aber wir haben da ein Gesetz zu, so runter trickelt und alle stehen da und sagen sich, ne, wir haben eigentlich ja gerade auch anderes zu tun. Und jeder, der das im Einzelfall sieht, der dann als ein Journalist, der wirklich mal dahin fährt, sich das anschaut, bringt Empörungsberichte mit, bei denen jeder Einzelne, der den Clip bei YouTube sieht, sagt, wow, das ist so doof. Und das sind auch Fragen um Leben und Tod. Das ist nicht immer alles nur Gewissensfrage. Der Bundestag lässt jetzt mal die Fraktionsdisziplin links liegen und das Bundesverfassungsgericht nickt das nochmal ab. Das kann man auch mal anders regeln. Ungleichheit.info ist also die korrespondierende Webseite zu dem unverdient Ungleichheit Buch. Ich nehme mal an, diese Webseite gab es schon und dann ist diese Buchidee entstanden. Wir erfahren, was wir schon wissen. Es ist nämlich kaum zu glauben, jeder sechste Mensch an oder unter der Armutsgrenze. 2018 hieß es noch 45 Superreiche besitzen, so viel wie die ärmere Hälfte. Jetzt sind es schon nur noch zwei Familien. Wir haben so die typischen Trends, die wir soweit wissen. Und es wird hier mit Grafiken gearbeitet, bei denen ich sage, kann man sich mal anschauen, man sieht so ein bisschen, dass sie vor dem KI-Zeitalter entstanden sind. Also darf ich sagen, kann man nacharbeiten, aber verstehen, vermitteln, verringern. Ich will mal eins aufgreifen, wenn man die globale Ungleichheit nimmt, also 2100 Milliardäre besitzen mehr als 60 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung, wäre das so, und das finde ich sehr eindrücklich, als würde von Lissabon nach Köln sich Menschen an die Hand nehmen. Es wären 2,2 Millionen Menschen, die alle so insgesamt gemeinsam so viel Geld haben, wie der eine, der ganz vorne steht. Also das finde ich mal sehr eindrücklich, muss ich sagen. Weil da kann man stundenlang drüber fliegen und immer noch ist es nicht erreicht und der eine da vorne hat so viel wie alle anderen zusammen. So, es gibt zwei Sektionen, von denen ich mir wünsche, dass sie aktuell gehalten werden. Denn der letzte Stand der Webseite ist 2021, nämlich Positionen der Parteien und ich lese vor, also Grüne, Linke, SPD haben natürlich Meinung zu diesen Themen. Ich lese vor CDU, CSU, Framing, Leer, Keins, Ungleichheit wird mit keinem Wort im Wahlprogramm erwähnt. FDP, Framing gibt es nicht, Keins, Ungleichheit wird mit keinem Wort im Wahlprogramm erwähnt. AfD, genauso, Ungleichheit wird mit keinem Wort im Wahlprogramm erwähnt. Also dieses Shaming, das hier schon mal stattfindet, allein durch Nicht-Erwähnung. Das kann man noch mal aktualisieren für den letzten Bundestagswahlkampf. Dann gleich formulieren, welche Hoffnung man so hat und wie auch immer. Wir haben jetzt in der meritokratischen Gefahr gelesen, wie es schon 2019 aussah, was Deutschland droht und so weiter. Und es gibt eine Presseschau. Sie dokumentieren also journalistische Thematisierungen und das finde ich ziemlich gut gemacht, weil mit Labels gearbeitet wird. Also wenn man auf der Recherche ist und sei es nur, weil man zum Weihnachtsgespräch mit Onkel Egon und so weiter, kann man sich das noch mal alles einzeln daraus ziehen. Ich erwähne das jetzt auch, weil die Webseite, finde ich grundsätzlich die Idee einer Webseite, muss 2026 eine Renaissance erfahren, da heute absolute Waffengleichheit gilt. Eine Webseite, die so hochkomplex ist, funktional wie die der New York Times, kann heute jeder selber machen. Es fehlt natürlich an Schreibern, die die füllen. Das allerdings kann ja das zweite Problem sein. Ich finde, sehr viele Menschen...
Was redest du jetzt? Wir können jetzt alle eine New York Times-Sowpage machen?
Ich möchte ein neues Blogger-Zeitalter ausrufen. Wir haben sowieso die große D-Day-Diskussion. Also beim Kongress war das auch großes Thema. Mark-Uwe Kling war da. Alle verabschieden sich jetzt so nach und nach von amerikanischen Servern. Das finde ich sowieso sehr begrüßenswert, denn so wie in Berlin der Strom ausfällt, kann es auch einfach mal heißen, Gmail ist jetzt gesperrt. Was machen dann die Leute, wenn Word nicht mehr geht? Also ich sehe große Einbrüche am BIP einfach dadurch. Und ich finde, da wir dieses Social-Web haben und sehr viele Technologien, die das einfach ersetzen, also sehr viele freie Protokolle, die kann man auch einfach mal nutzen. Ich werde das Ende des Monats noch ein bisschen thematisieren, aber es muss jetzt eine Renaissance der privaten Webseite geben und sie muss lebendig sein. Also da muss einfach was stattfinden. Und sei es nur, dass man jeden Scheiß, den man irgendwo postet, da noch mal chronologisch auflistbar macht, wie auch immer. Also dass man das einfach als Adresse vorhält. Jeder Podcast muss eine Webseite haben.
Welchen Vorteil hat das?
Eine eigene Webseite zu haben.
Ja.
Die Webseite ist die eigene Adresse. Gerade für Leute, die eine eigene öffentliche Adresse brauchen. Und wir sind jetzt im dritten Zuge dieser Entwicklung. Erstens, unsere Adresse ist unser Wohnort. Dann zweitens, Passagiere und Papiere. Wir sind jetzt überall zu Hause, aber haben unsere Adresse immer dabei. Leute sitzen jetzt schon im Flugzeug und haben Internet. Können angeschrieben werden. Nicht mal da, ist man vor seinem Chef sicher, wie auch immer. Und jetzt sind wir in dieser dritten Phase. Man hat seine Adresse nicht nur dabei, sondern man hat eine omnipräsente Adresse. Wo zum Beispiel für uns, also wo einfach klar ist, wie viele E-Mails bekommen wir mit mein Freund hat Geburtstag, ich möchte ihm eine Live-Salon-Karte schicken. Ich habe gehört, ihr macht so Live-Podcasts. Wann sind ihr die nächsten Termine? Es muss für alle völlig klar sein, es ist ein Podcast. Der hat also eine Webseite. Diese Webseite hat Informationen und der nächste Termin für ein Live-Salon ist eine Information. Wo kriege ich sie also her? Von der Webseite des Podcasts. Ich schicke keinen Brief mit Stempel und sei es als elektronische E-Mail irgendwohin in die Weltgeschichte, weil ich glaube, ich werde jetzt persönlich betreut von den Hosts dieses Podcasts oder sowas. Dieser Gedanke ist einfach, niemand schreibt an Herrn Sulzberger, weil er einen Kommentar der New York Times nicht mag. Es ist einfach völlig ausgeschlossen. Also man geht natürlich auf die Webseite, weshalb ich sage, wir ziehen sowieso jetzt alles auf die Webseite, also unsere Termine, was auf der Webseite geben. Wir haben das Diskussionsforum, wo ich dann auch vorbeischaue. Du kannst ja gucken, wie du es einbauen magst. Wir kriegen auf jeden Fall die Olivia-Auswertung von dem ganzen Zeug, das da stattfindet. Also es läuft jetzt über die Webseite. Ich möchte, dass die Idee, die vor 20 Jahren richtig gut war, wiederbelebt wird, nämlich eine Blog-Sphäre. Und mit Blog-Sphäre meine ich nicht, jeder setzt sich hin und schreibt einen Text, sondern man hat jetzt eine lebendige Webseite, da ist was los. Wie so ein Agenten-Führer ein, der schon mal die ersten Sachen so abfängt. Ich weiß, der Bedarf ist natürlich nicht überall so groß, aber diese Idee von, jetzt haben wir endlich Facebook. Mark Zuckerberg hatte eine, sind die Mädels auf meiner Uni eigentlich hot? Ja, und daraus leiten dann Leute auf der anderen Seite der Welt ab, dass sie jetzt endlich mal Klassentreffen machen können, weil man sich auf Facebook wiederfindet. Das geht auch ohne Facebook. Und ich möchte gerne diese Renaissance jetzt 2026 haben.
Ich bin gespannt. Bleiben wir beim Thema KI. Hito Steyerl ist Künstlerin und Essäistin. Bei Die Affarnis ist jetzt ein Buch erschienen mit gesammelten Essays. Der Titel des Werks Medium Hot. Bilder in Zeiten der Hitze. Du siehst hier schon auf dem Cover merkwürdig generierte Menschen. Bei der Frau stimmt irgendwas mit dem Dekoltän nicht.
Die Brustmuskeln stimmen, aber die Beine nicht.
Bei den Beinen stimmen so manche Dinge gar nicht. Nämlich, wir sehen hier irgendeinen nackten Körper, der aber nichts nacktes explizites aufweist. Was hat es damit auf sich? Nun, sie nennt das Haxenporno. Und wir fragen uns, was ist damit gemeint? Was ist damit gemeint? Der Einsatz generativer künstlicher Intelligenz zur Abbildung von Menschen hat lange Zeit Probleme aufgeworfen. Menschliche Körper sind kompliziert. Anscheinend sind Finger, Bewegungen und Gesichter für Bildgeneratoren schwierig darzustellen. Und oft entstehen dann Hände, die zwischen vier und sieben Finger haben und allerhand überflüssige Gelenke dazwischen. Das Problem ist nicht trivial. Die Frage ist, wie sehen diese Systeme den Menschen? Wie sieht ein menschlicher Körper aus, wenn er aus statistischen Daten erzeugt wird? Welche anderen Kräfte wirken auf diesen Typ der Repräsentation? So fragt sie sich und bittet dann eine KI, Bilder zu generieren. Da geht es um stable diffusion. Stable diffusion 3 soll ein Mädchen im Gras liegend generieren. Aber man sieht, da funktioniert so mit der Anatomie einiges nicht. Da ist ein Bein zu viel da oder die beiden Beine sind am Ende miteinander verwachsen. Wenn man dann sagt, generiere doch mal etwas auf Grundlage eines kunsthistorischen Vorbildes, nämlich Eduard Manet's berühmtes Gemälde Le Dugener sur l'herbe, könnte man auswählen. Dann bekommt man eben sowas präsentiert, dass dort Leute halbnackt oder nackt zu sehen sind, ohne dass wir etwas Expezites von ihnen sehen. Der Manet prompt produziert Chimären, wie sie in der westlichen Bildproduktion seit der Voraufklärungszeit nur noch selten zu sehen waren.
Kreaturen eines dunklen Zeitalters, ein Pestarium an Basilisken, Monopoden und Strutopoden. Der Regress zur Fähigkeit zur Darstellung der menschlichen Anatomie erinnert an mittelalterliche Abbildungen von Monstern und Ungeheuern aus unbekannten Weltregionen, die keinen Kopffarben oder ein paar Armen zuviel. Die Diagnose des Technologiekritikers und Journalisten James Pridle, ein dunkles Zeitalter des digitalen Aberglaubens stehe bevor, wird hier anschaulich bestätigt. Das interessante ist ja nun, dass diese so merkwürdigen Verwachsungen auch deshalb entstehen, diese Monstrositäten deshalb entstehen, weil es nicht nur ein Produkt von technischen Fehlleistungen ist, sondern wir ja auch in Zeiten leben, in denen es Regeln gibt, was zum Beispiel an Nacktheit dargestellt werden darf und was nicht. Sie schreibt, diese Regeln sind prüde und sensationsheischend zugleich. Und aus diesem Spannungsverhältnis gehen die Körper verdreht und verstümmelt hervor, mit zu vielen und zu wenigen Gliedmaßen zugleich. Die Regeln dienen zudem vor allem dazu, jede Haftung zu umgehen für den Fall, dass jemand diese Tools zur Entstehung illegaler Pornos einsetzt. Das KI-Standard ist sich voll auf bewusst, dass früher oder später irgendein User das Modell feinjustieren, sprich den unerlaubten Content wieder einführen und realistische Pornos generieren wird. Man will bloß nicht dafür zur Verantwortung gezogen werden können. Das heißt, Haxenpornos sind das Resultat einer bewussten Weigerung, Verantwortung zu übernehmen. An diesem Beispiel wollte ich deutlich machen, wie Hito Steyerl denkt in diesem Essay-Band. Sie geht also von Bildern sehr häufig aus und macht dann Assoziationen zu anderen Themenfeldern mit unter, aber auch zu der zum Beispiel kolonialistischen Struktur, die in der KI steigt, zu Blockchain. Auch darum geht es. Was bedeutet das eigentlich so, ein interessanter Essay, wenn die Durchschnittlichkeit zum Maßstab wird? Da heißt es eine Essay, gemeine Durchschnittsbilder. Und mit gemein ist so wohl das Allgemeine wie das uns gemeine gemeint. Ja, da sieht man doch, dass man plötzlich so generiert wird als ein Sammelsurium von Daten, die gemittelt werden. Sie selbst findet sich in so einem Pool von Bildern wieder. Sie hat also auch genügend Kenntnisse, um sich da selbst hinein zu begeben und findet dann Bilder von sich. Und bittet dann StableDiffusion doch mal ein generiertes Bild aus diesen Bildern, die vorhanden sind, von ihr zu erstellen. Und das ist nicht besonders schmeichelhaft, was dann dabei herauskommt. Wie aber gelangt StableDiffusion von A nach B? Was wir hier sehen, ist nicht gerade die schmeichelhafteste aller Vorher-Nachher-Gegenüberstellung. So viel ist klar. Ich kann das Verfahren nicht empfehlen. Es ist ziemlich gemein, mean, um nicht zu sagen herabwürdigend. Aber genau darum geht es ja gerade. Die Frage ist, was macht dieses gemittelte Bild so gemein? Wessen Gemeinheit ist es? Und was für einen Durchschnitt zeigt es? StableDiffusion rendert dieses Porträt von mir in einem Zustand eingefroren durch unbekannte innere Vorgänger angetriebenen Alterszorns, der vorgeblich in Bezug zu den Trainingsdaten steht. Dahinter steht kein Blackbox-Algorithmus, denn der Code von StableDiffusion ist bekannt. Man könnte es vielleicht einen Whitebox-Algorithmus nennen, einen gesellschaftlichen Filter. Es ist eine Approximation daran, wie die Gesellschaft vermittelt durch einen Filter an durchschnittlichem Internetmüll mich sieht. Dazu muss man lediglich das Wirklichkeitsrauschen aus meinen Fotos entfernen und das soziale Signal extrahieren. Das Resultat ist ein Mean-Image, ein gemeines Bild, ein Ergebnis korrelierter Durchschnittswerte oder Schattierungen des gemeinen Durchschnitts. Und was bedeutet das dann? Da kann man weiterlesen. Also es ist ein Buch, das gerade vom Bild ausgehend über KI, wie ich finde, sehr intelligent und oft kontraintuitiv nachdenkt.
Wobei es fast, also es ist ja antike Geschichte.
Sie beschreibt es ja auch immer wieder als, da war die KI noch nicht so weit und so weit. Also es ist nicht ein Buch, das uns sagt, seht mal, die KI ist gar nicht so gut, sondern die Frage, die sich ja schon stellt, wie verändert sich also unsere Bildwelt dadurch und was sind wir irgendwann auch bereit zu akzeptieren? Und da geht es ja dann nicht nur um Fehler, die produziert werden, sondern schon auch, welche Regeln werden jetzt gesellschaftlich wieder eingeschrieben, welche Bilder dürfen entstehen? Also solche Haxenpornos dürfen entstehen, während zum Beispiel Geschlechtsteile und selbst ein Bauchnabel scheinen schon ein Problem zu sein und wird deshalb nicht mehr angezeigt.
Ja, was ich auch interessant finde, ist es gibt 40 Bilder von Vermehr. Ich habe jetzt kürzlich eins gesehen in einem Museum und ich kann natürlich Stable Diffusion oder Mid Journey einfach sagen, das aber wie ein Vermehr. Also es gibt jetzt quasi tausende Vermehr-Entwürfe, die diese Idee tragen. Aber es gibt ja nur 40 Vermehrs. Also dieser ganze Slop hat auch sehr viel mit Quantität zu tun. Zwei Texte zum Thema KI. Ich binde sie zusammen, weil sie zusammengehören und weil der erste dir die Möglichkeit bietet, nochmal durchzuatmen, bevor es beim zweiten dann zur Sache geht. Also Benjamin Riley, das ist the founder of cognitive resonance. Ich würde sagen, das ist mehr so cognitive resistance. Also eine Interessenorganisation, die sagte, building human knowledge to halt AI hype. Also sie wendet sich sozusagen gegen dieses Rumgehype die ganze Zeit. Und natürlich erschienen bei The Verge, aber dort übernommen, weil der Text woanders aufgefallen ist im Rahmen dieser aktivistischen Arbeit. Und ich finde, das ist auch ganz gut, dass man das auf so einer techie Seite dem Publikum nochmal vorführt. Also die Fragestellung ist, ist in der KI mehr drin als einfach nur grammatikalisch richtige Sprache? Also Innovationskraft, Überraschungspotenzial? Oder ist es tatsächlich einfach nur schreibt man diese E-Mail richtig? So und hier wird das natürlich sehr kritisch gesehen. Also diese Idee des Large Language Mistake zeigt da schon, in welche Richtung hier argumentiert wird. Der Text beginnt natürlich mit den ganzen Verherrlichungen, die wir hier auch besprochen haben. Also Dario Amo-Dais großer Text für Anthropic mit den tollen Maschinen. Und Mark Zuckerberg dann nochmal sagt, der Superintelligence ist jetzt in sight. Sam Oidman wird natürlich auch thematisiert. Und die Frage ist aber, was genau, also wie ernst muss man es jetzt nehmen, dass von Large Language Models gesprochen wird. Haben Menschen nicht noch mehr Beitrag, als einfach nur zu sagen, wir sprechen miteinander. Denn auch wenn wir nicht sprechen, wissen wir, wir denken. Wie sich das dann äußert, ist eine andere Frage. Aber dann kriegen wir wieder Texte, dass sehr viel nonverbale Kommunikation stattfindet und so. Das wird hier alles so eingepreist. Es gibt eine Schlüsselstudie aus dem MIT UC Berkeley Kontext, in dem eben argumentiert wird, Language is primarily a tool for communication rather than thought. Also es gibt Kommunikation und Kognition. Wird hier nochmal ganz ernst genommen. Und die Sprache ist sozusagen das Werkzeug, um Gedanken zu vermitteln, aber noch nicht der Gedanke selbst. Etwas, was uns als Menschen, die wir ja individuell und sozusagen unterschieden von anderen sein wollen, sehr entgegenkommt. Und die Hörnforschung geht natürlich in allen Richtungen genau mit dieser Idee mit. Denn Menschen können die Sprache verlieren und sind deswegen aber nicht völlig verblödete Würmer. Genauso wie Babys durchaus schon am sozialen Leben teilnehmen, lange bevor sie sprechen. Allein weil sie schon früher gehen können, bevor sie sprechen. Und da also in sozialen Netzen aufgehoben sind, ohne dass der Spracherwerb hier von zentraler Bedeutung ist. Weshalb hier also eine vernichtende Pointe über die LLMs gegeben wird, nämlich wenn du den Computer die Sprache nimmst, hast du nothing at all. Literally. Also es bleibt dann sozusagen nur ein Computer, der einfach Zahlen durchrechnet. Also man sieht noch so ein bisschen, welche Vektoren da eine Rolle spielen, aber sie haben ja nichts zu bedeuten, sie werden ja nie in Sprache übersetzt. Und dieser Text, hier wird es also hart argumentiert, dass es genau so ist. Es wurde mal kurz darauf verwiesen, dass dieser Jan Likun, der so lange bei Meta war, der Vorgänger von diesem Alexander Wang, heute in einem eigenen Start-up, so ein bisschen abgeschottet von der Welt, so an World Models arbeitet, in denen so ontologisch erst mal die physikalischen Grundlagen gelernt werden, wie auch bei kleinen Kindern. Also wenn du diesen Schritt machst, fällst du runter und dann tut es weh. Das ist einfach Kinetik. Und wir sehen ja bei Maschinen, wie immer wieder das einfach nicht verstanden wird, wie die grundlegenden Zusammenhänge sind, für die man eigentlich typischerweise, sagen wir, gar keine Sprache braucht, weil er versteht sich ja von selbst. Common Sense und so weiter. Großes Thema. Also, es gibt durchaus Texte, die klug geschrieben sind, die genau in diese Richtung gehen und sagen, nur Sprache allein erreicht uns nicht. Wir wollen von der Maschine eigentlich mehr. Und hier wird von Dead Metaphor Machines gesprochen. Metaphor Machines. Also es gibt Living Metaphors. Das sind also neue Ideen, die uns, wenn sie uns kommunikativ erreichen, überraschen. Jemand hat ein neues Rechtsgefüge, eine neue Organisationsform, was auch immer, Managementfamilie und so. Also wir überraschen uns ja ständig mit neuen Ideen. Und hier wird jetzt argumentiert, die Maschinen bringen nur ein Common Sense Repository mit. Also nur die toten Metaphern, die sozusagen schon in die allgemeinen sozialen Skripte übergegangen sind, werden nochmal aktualisiert. Wie schreibt man den Brief richtig? Welche Managementmethode ab? Seitens der, die wir gerade benutzen, gibt es noch. Und dann wird im Grunde das Handbuch einmal aufgeschlüsselt. Aber wenn man der Maschine jetzt sagt, dass die Herausforderungen, das sind die Managementmethoden, wir brauchen irgendwie eine neue, dann, ne, also da allenfalls Assistenz im Sinne von, wir gehen nochmal ins Archiv und gucken nach, was gab. Aber es gibt sozusagen diesen Living-Anteil da nicht. Ich meine, klar, die gehen dann auch in diese Richtung. Wir verlieren das Fahrradfahren nicht und müssen nie wieder darüber reden. Wir fahren dann einfach Fahrrad und solche Sachen. Also so auf der Ebene argumentiert das auch. Und dann gibt es aber diesen anderen Text und der kommt jetzt nicht von The Verge, sondern vom New Yorker. Der ist ein bisschen in die andere Richtung argumentiert. Das finde ich witzig, dass wir hier The Verge mit dieser und jetzt den New Yorker mit der anderen Richtung. Also die Autorin heißt, ich muss weiter scrollen. Und sie ist mir vorher nicht aufgefallen, aber ich finde es hochinteressant, weil ich habe diesen Text vorgelesen von Gwyneth Paltrow als KI-Stimme. Also ich fand es wirklich wahnsinnig unterhaltsam. So Vauhini V-A-U-Hini Vara. Ich weiß nicht, ob du sie kennst, aber sie schreibt wohl sehr viele literarische Essays und ist da auch mit Büchern zur Gegend, aber hat auch diesen tech-journalistischen Einschlag. Und sie beschreibt hier ein Experiment auch mit einer älteren KI, nämlich GPT-4O. Tuhin Chakrabati, ein Literaturwissenschaftler, sitzt, also ein Professor des Themas sozusagen, des Milieus, fährt in den Urlaub, sitzt in Tokyo und hat diese Idee. Er nimmt jetzt die KI und sagt ihr, schreibe mir mal bitte diese eine Szene, die ich dir ganz genau definiere. Sie sollen nichts Neues finden, sollen nur die Sprache finden. Aus Han Kangs Buch. Und er liest das dann und denkt sich so, ich gebe das mal im Testpublikum. Er hat ja so ein kleines Testpublikum, seine Studenten, die so ein bisschen entscheiden sollen, was hat es damit auf sich? Ist das jetzt überzeugende Literatur, wie auch immer? Das ist der Absatz, lest das mal. Und es findet keinen großen Anklang. Also die Leute sagen, nee, sorry, aber das ist so überdreht, das sieht man sofort. Die Sprache ist zu. Und dann stellt er sich die Frage, kann ich das irgendwie verbessern? Und er entscheidet sich dafür, nochmal diesen Versuch zu machen, also mit einem blind getesteten Publikum, einen Testtext vorzulegen. Diesmal gibt er den gesamten Korpus von Han Kang, der KI, und nimmt genau einen Absatz raus, nämlich wie ihre Mutter über den Tod des Geschwisterkinds, zwei Stunden nach der Geburt und so, man hat das Baby von der Hand und dann. So, also wir haben es hier mit Literatur zu tun, die durchaus auf gelebte Empirie Rücksicht nimmt, im Sinne von, hier geht es um die Wiedergabe, aber nicht eins zu eins, also der Wortlaut der Mutter stimmt wohl nicht so ganz, aber die Autorin will uns etwas vermitteln und nutzt dafür die Literatur. Und plötzlich sind die Testleser Feuer und Flamme dafür und sagen, also bevorzugen das immer einfach, was die KI entworfen hat, auch im Vergleich zu den noch echten Worten der Mutter, die aber für Han Kang nicht die waren, die man dann im Roman drin hatte. Und da war die Frage, was hat es denn damit auf sich? Und die Vauhini Vara beginnt halt damit, sich selber diesen Test zu unterziehen. Also sie macht das selber mit ihrem eigenen Werk. Sie sagt einfach der KI hier, bitte nur diesen Korpus, nur diesen Stil, nur diesen konkreten Text verwenden und daraus Neues generieren. Und sie gibt das dann auch ihrer Agentin, ihren Freundinnen und so weiter und so fort. Und da muss sie sagen, das muss man dann wirklich selber lesen. Es ist wirklich witzig auch, wie sie dann so feststellt, ne, die bevorzugen manchmal, die KI anzustellen, wo ich denke, na, das erkennen die. So, und dann wird sie auch gelobt für Textstellen, wo es heißt, das ist deine Sprache. Aber es war halt von GPT 4o geschrieben und so. Und dieses Szenario will ich jetzt nochmal. Es geht also nicht darum, dass jetzt hier die KI irgendwas macht, auf das man selber keine Lust hat oder so, sondern man weiß genau, was man schreiben will. Man kennt auch die Stimmung. Man findet nur nicht so die richtigen Worte. Also setzt man sich hin und sagt, mach mir einen Vorschlag genau für diesen Satz. Nicht mehr. Musst du jetzt nicht zeigen, dass du ein Supercomputer bist und so, sondern mach genau dann das. Also man hat eine sehr enge Fragestellung und hat dann das Ergebnis einer KI. Und plötzlich ist das Testpublikum so davon überzeugt, was diese großen Fragen aufwirft. Wenn wir Romane haben, von denen alle wissen, das ist Fiction. Warum brauchen wir dann, um das aufzufangen, diese totale Authentizität des Autoren? Wir wissen, wer heißt, wir kennen seine anderen Bücher, die validieren schon, bei dem können wir uns wieder drauf freuen, das ist ein tolles neues Buch und so weiter und so fort. Und wir haben ja sowieso in vielerlei Aspekten diese Frage, Werk und Autor, wie gehen wir damit um? Können wir uns schon ein Werk ohne Autor vorstellen? Ist zum Beispiel so eine Frage. Oder was bedeutet Autorenschaft, wenn wir gar keine Möglichkeiten haben, zu überprüfen, ob wirklich jeder einzelne Satz wirklich nur aus dem Gehirn des Nobelpreisträgers kommt oder der vielleicht auch ein bisschen Hilfe in Anspruch genommen hat und sei es nur für seine Inspiration. Und dann ist er so überzeugt von einem Textentwurf, der da kommt, wo er sagt, den lasse ich jetzt mal so. Ich schreibe lieber die Geschichte weiter. Davon haben die Leser mehr, als wenn ich jetzt ewig grübel und am Ende heiße es, ich habe auch diese Worte selbst gewählt. Also diese leichte Verknüpfung von KI und Originaltext sozusagen von Menschen geschrieben.
Es gibt ja in der Kunst das Beispiel der alten Meister, die ja mit Werkstätten gearbeitet haben.
Genau. Das ist ja gar nicht so neu.
Das heißt, man hatte jemanden, der malte Haare, weil der sehr gut Haare malen konnte. Und dann hat sich der Meister nicht damit abgegeben.
Ja.
Zumindest hat er das Bild konzipiert und auch daran gemalt, aber dann Dinge abgegeben. Und das wäre ja auch so etwas. Ich frage mich aber auch, ob das schon so ein qualitativer Unterschied ist. Denn wenn man jetzt einen Text formuliert, dann steht man ja immer wieder vor der Frage, welches Wort nehme ich? Ich will nicht die ganze Zeit, sagte er, schreiben, sollte ich irgendetwas anderes nehmen, entgegnete er, meinte er, klagte er. Dann kann man ja in einem Wörterbuch oder per Google sich Synonyme geben lassen.
Ja, die sind diese auch.
Man geht eigentlich da ähnlich vor. Hier geht es dann noch weiter. Da werden dann ganze Sätze formuliert. Das ist also eine Praxis, die dann mehr in diese Richtung führt. Das führt weg, also ich gehe jetzt mal vom Autor aus, natürlich weg von dieser ganz subjektiven Stimme, der man eigentlich die Treue, glaube ich, halten will. Ich schreibe keine Romane, aber was doch das Entscheidende bei den Romanen ist, ist ja doch, dass man so einer Stimme zuhört, egal, ob es das jetzt ein Ich-Erzähler ist oder auch der reale Erzähler, was auch immer, wir folgen einer Stimme. Und diese Stimme, glaube ich, ist auch das, was den Autor so interessiert. Offenbar aber kann man diese Stimme dann auch imitieren. Es ist vielleicht am Ende die Frage, wird der Leser damit glücklich und wird der Autor damit glücklich?
Das ist nämlich der Punkt. Der Leser kann ja hier auch eine wichtige Rolle spielen. Jetzt hast du ja zu Recht immer kritisiert, wenn dann Amazon irgendwie anfängt zu sagen, wir wissen ja, wo die Leute aufhören, unsere Amazon Prime Videos zu gucken, dann gucken wir uns mal an, warum. Zielen daraus Schlüsse und dann passiert halt nur noch Sonderbares in so einem Film. Hauptsache, die Leute schalten nicht aus. Und man kann aber auch anders Rücksicht nehmen auf den Leser und auf den Autor, in dem man sagt, es geht uns auch um Einfallsreichtum. Es gibt halt Autoren wie Stephen King, die schaffen beides. Allein die Idee von Stephen King.
Der wäre mir jetzt nicht eingefallen.
Ja, aber allein die Idee von verschiedenen.
Der hat den Einfluss von Einfallen, aber wenn du das literarisch umgesetzt liest, da würde ich beispielsweise sagen und ich weiß, hier werden Stephen King-Fans zuhören, das kann man stilistisch besser machen, wenn man nicht sagt, ich will 5000 Romane an einem Tag schreiben.
Man kann es stilistisch besser machen, gilt nun für jede Geschmacksrichtung. Nicht nur für den allgemeinen Thema, die Idee ist ganz gut, aber die Umsetzung war schlecht oder so, sondern egal, wie man es dreht und wendet, jemand kann einfach sagen, wow, diese Idee war so gut, aber irgendwie hat es mir nicht gefallen. Und jetzt kriegt man eine neue Kombination hin, und zwar mit der Leistung des Autoren.
Aber man kriegt das doch auch mit Denken hin. Ich sehe nicht so richtig den Anwendungsfall, es sei denn, man sagt, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen faul und will nicht selbst über einen Satz nachdenken, dann kann ich mir den schreiben lassen. Also in der Musik ist es ja auch so, natürlich haben Komponisten einen Stil, aber wenn ich jetzt einfach nur eine KI füttere mit dem Stil und sage, mach was Neues draus, dann wird es vielleicht doch ein bisschen weniger als das, was man eigentlich dachte.
Das ist natürlich so eine, also es ist lauernd schon gefahren, aber wir kennen das aus anderen Mediäts. Ich nehme jetzt absichtlich mal nicht Literatur, weil wir da einfach wissen, die Leistung eines Autoren lässt sich eigentlich prinzipiell ganz einfach duplizieren, weil ein Stift und Papier hat jeder zu Hause und trotzdem gelingt es nicht. Wir haben aber verschiedene andere musische Milieus, wie zum Beispiel beim Film, wo ich sage, es ist schon ein Problem, dass die Filme, in denen es besonders knallt, Michael Bay Filme, inhaltlich immer besonders doof sind, während gleichzeitig besonders kluge Filme immer kein Budget haben, dann ist es auch mal knallt. So und diese Verquickung könnte man jetzt mal machen. Und zwar nicht nur aus Budgetgründen, sondern vielleicht auch, weil man diese eine gute Idee von so einem Dogma-Filmmacher vielleicht doch noch mal mit Filmmusik sehen möchte. Statt einfach nur, wenn Schweigen ist, ist Schweigen.
Ich lasse das unkommentiert stehen.
Also es gibt sozusagen, so und ich will es jetzt einfach mal vorführen, denn es besteht jetzt die ganz große Gefahr, dass es total lächerlich ist für alle, die hier zuhören. Aber es geht ja nur um einen einzelnen Satz. Also klar, Nobelpreis gekürt und so, ja. So wir hören jetzt drei Versionen derselben Szenerie. Wie leidet Trauer die Mutter direkt nach einer Fehlgeburt um ein totes Kind? Und wir hören das einmal. Die KI wird einfach gebeten, einen Stil nachzuahmen. Danach, die KI wird darauf trainiert, einen Stil nachahmen zu können. Das ist dann das, was sehr viele überzeugt hat. Und dann hören wir den Originaltext. Einfach vorgelesen von einheitlicher KI-Stimme. Also Version Nummer eins. Live, sie murmurte. Ein Schant, der den Weichwert ihres Beinges bewegte. So, da haben die Leute gesagt, das ist zu viel. Ein Schrei, der die ganze Gewalt des Moments in sich trägt und so. Das war zu viel. Jetzt kommt die Version, bei der einfach das ganze Testpublikum hin und weg war. Und der Professor auch. Sie hielt das Baby zu ihrem Brust und murmurte. Live, bitte lebe. Geh weiter zu leben und bleib mein Sohn. Hör ich auch gar nicht so schlecht. Jetzt kommt die Originalversion, die Han Khan ins Buch geschrieben hat. Für Gott's sake, nicht sterben. Sie mutterte in einer dünnen Stimme, wie ein Mantra, immer wieder. Also drei verschiedene Aufzüge, die in Windeseile generiert werden können. Und jetzt würde ich sagen, ja, das Werk hat ein Autor. Das Werk hat einen gewissen Effort, der da drin steckt. Manche Bücher werden einfach so weggeschrieben. Bei manchen ist es dem Autor wirklich wichtig, dass dieser eine Satz stimmt oder wie auch immer. Aber es ist eben wie bei diesen Dessertationen. Man schreibt so einen Forschungsstand, um zu zeigen, ich habe das Feld verstanden, ich habe mich hier umgeschaut. Dann kommt so ganz viel irgendwas unklar und dann kommt der eigene Beitrag. Und dieser, ich habe mir das Feld angeschaut, ist eben 20 Prozent der Arbeit, der eigene Beitrag ist auch 20 Prozent, bleiben also noch mehr als die Hälfte über. Und da ist wirklich die Frage, ob wir nicht, und sei es nur in Zusammenfassungen oder wie auch immer, mittlerweile auf so einem Niveau sind, dass man sagt, ja, das macht schon Sinn, Text zu generieren, und zwar für den Leser. Nicht, damit der Autor sich selbst darstellt oder hier nochmal einen Umsatz macht oder wie auch immer, sondern wir können, wir haben jetzt Autoren schafft, Textgestaltung, bei der vielleicht auch der Leser so ein bisschen mitzuentscheiden hat. Und wenn man jetzt so ein...
Aber wie würde er mitentscheiden?
Naja, das ist halt die Frage, wie man es gestaltet. Jeder liest ein Buch und kennt die Textstellen, die einem gefallen. Die könnte man markieren. Und eine KI könnte Schlüsse daraus ziehen. Und sei es nur in der Frage, wie variantenreich muss denn, er sagte, sie sagte, sagte, sagte, sagte. Das ist nämlich, finde ich, das Problem im deutschen Harry Potter. Alle Figuren, bei jedem Wortlaut sagen einfach etwas. Keiner schreit, keiner murmelt, keiner macht irgendwas. Alle sagen.
Ist das aber im Englischen anders?
Nein, im Englischen ist es halt verwoben. Also ja, das ist anders.
Die Frage ist, heißt es da auch, she said, he said?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Das ist ja eine Literatur-Schule, zu der ich jetzt nicht so richtig rohlinge. Aber jemand wie Hemingway zum Beispiel wollte ja genau nicht entgegnet, meinte, glaubte es nehmen, sondern hat permanent eigentlich immer nur, sagte er, geschrieben.
Also ich finde, dieses konkrete Beispiel ist etwas, worunter die deutschen Harry-Potter-Versionen leiden. Und ich würde das gern anders haben. Und ich möchte aber nicht eine inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung mit der Autoren oder mit irgendwelchen Literaturwissenschaftlern, sondern ich möchte einfach, dass eine gewisse Lebendigkeit in der Verbform, die mir andeutet, dass da jemand was sagt.
Wie du ja auch die Straußwalzer gerne von andere Réjeux kaputt gemacht bekommst.
Ja, ich möchte, dass die gerne ein bisschen zackig und hier und da. Genau, dass was für andere kaputt ist, ist für mich halt lebendig. So und ich finde, man kann jetzt so langsam Rücksicht drauf nehmen.
Können sie mir mal die Neunte Sinfonie auf dem Kampel lasen? Das wäre mir eigentlich lieber.
Also ich finde nicht, dass Bücher zerstört werden, weil so wie hier vielleicht Variantenreichtum reinkommt, der vorher einfach nicht drin war, weil sie Arbeit macht. Und jetzt kann da dieser Arbeit jemand erledigen.
Würdest du sagen, dass es dann eher etwas ist, was Leser machen in einem kreativen Umgang mit dem Text? Oder glaubst du, dass Autoren mehr und mehr dazu übergehen, wenn sie diese kleine Schreibblockade haben oder diese kleine Hemmung haben, dass sie dann Chet Chippity oder wen auch immer befragen?
Da wir und darunter, aber das thematisier ich oft, leide ich ja wie blöd, da ich nur Leser kenne, die einfach den gedruckten Buchstabenfolge auf Papier akzeptieren und sonst nichts.
Sag einfach Menschen wie dich.
Menschen wie dich, ja. Bei denen es schon heißt, die Speechify-Airpartie, die das vorgelesen und dann noch in höhere Geschwindigkeit. Nee, das ist kein Lesen. Ruth Witherspoon, die ja einen sehr großen Buchklub hat, sagt, hören, sehen, alles ist lesen. Das finde ich sehr sympathisch. Dua Lipa saugt sich an einzelnen Sätzen fest in diesen Lektüren. Finde ich auch sehr sympathisch. Das Rest des Buchs kann man auch einfach mal, ja. Von daher bin ich total für diesen neuen Variantenreichtum in allen Facetten. Aber ich weiß, sehr viele in der Hörerschaft, ich kenne das von mir aus der Oper, die Werktreue ist oberste Pflicht, ja. Aber in der Literatur, in der Textgestaltung, würde ich sagen, kann man durchaus mal ein bisschen.
Kommen wir zu einem Artikel von Nils Schniederjann im Freitag erschienen. Nicht besser als die EKD, die Kriegsrhetorik der deutschen Katholiken. So ist dieser Text überschrieben. Der Friede sei mit euch, so trat der neue Papst Leo der 14. auf den Balkon. Aber die deutschen Bischöfe, die sehen das eigentlich anders. Leo ist sehr bemüht, um zum Beispiel auf Friedensverhandlungen, wenn auch nicht besonders erfolgreich damit. Die Fronten sind verhärtet. Schniederjann erzählt, dass am 4. Juni dieses Telefonat stattfand zwischen Putin und Leo. Man hatte Putin angeboten, auf vatikanischem Boden zu verhandeln. Putin hat das abgelehnt. Leo hat dann auch gleich wieder die Beziehungen versucht zu stärken zur russisch-orthodoxen Kirche. Wir wissen, wie eng die verbandelt ist mit Putin. Man versuchte also, über diesen Weg etwas zu bewirken, wenn auch noch nicht erfolgreich. So ist es doch so, schreibt Schniederjann, dass der Vatikan immer mal wieder sehr erfolgreich war bei Verhandlungen. Allein zwischen 1878 und 1903 agierte der Vatikan elfmal als Vermittler bei internationalen Konflikten. Es war die Amtszeit von Leo XIII., unter dem der Vatikan erstmals systematisch als internationaler Streitvermittler auftrat. An diesen ersten Diplomatenpapst lehnt sich auch der aktuelle Papst bei seiner Namenswahl an. Andere Päpste waren seitdem mit ihrer Diplomatie ähnlich erfolgreich. Johannes XXIII., der 1958 als Papst antrat, wird außerdem maßgeblicher Einfluss auf die Deeskalation der Kuberkrise 1962 zugeschrieben. Und auch Franziskus war ja bemüht um Friedensverhandlungen, auch um Verhandlungen zwischen den Konfliktparteien im Südsodan. Nie wieder Krieg hat Leo auch verkündet. Einmal im Jahr aber, so heißt es dann hier, nimmt die Konferenz der deutschen Bischöfe ausführlich zum Krieg in der Ukraine Stellung. In ihren Statements wird klar, dass sie kaum noch als geistliche Instanz mit überzeitlichem Blick auftreten. Stattdessen unterstützen sie meist schlicht den weltlichen Kurs der Bundesregierung. So forderten die Bischöfe 2022 explizit, dass die Ukraine weiter in ihrem Abwehrkampf unterstützt werden muss. Weiter hat man sich dann geäußert, dass man zwar Dialoge braucht, Spielräume und so, aber grundsätzlich ganz so wie die Regierung. Schniederjann schreibt konkret, heißt das im Zweifelsfall eben nicht auf einen Dialog und einen, wenn auch ungerechten Frieden zu setzen, sondern das Kämpfen und Sterben weiter zu verlängern. Das liest sich eher wie so eine nationale Sicherheitsstrategie, was die deutschen Bischöfe dann 2024 veröffentlicht haben. Dann gibt es so einen Friedenswort. Das ist ein Grundlagentext, ein 170-seitiges Dokument. Das diest sich wie eine Sicherheitsstrategie, nicht wie ein theologisches Traktat. Da ist die Rede von Rüstungsanstrengungen, die die Bischöfe gegenwärtig als unverzichtbares Element ansehen. Und statt darauf hinzuweisen, dass es ja gerade die Nationalstaaten sind, die ihre Bürger zwingen, den Krieg zu ziehen, drehen sie das Verhältnis völlig um und schreiben, dass der Staat, um seine Bürgerschaft vor Gewalt zu schützen, in der Lage sein muss, Notfallsgewaltmittel einzusetzen. Außerdem warnen die Bischöfe entgegen dem Ansatz von Papst Franziskus oder Leo vor einer chaotischen Form der sogenannten multipolaren Welt. Eine multipolare Welt schien für Franziskus aber nicht bloß Gefahren, sondern vor allen Dingen auch Hoffnung zu bedeuten. Das ist aber für die deutschen Bischöfe eher so ein Schreckgespenst generell multipolare Welt. Weiter heißt es ähnlich wie die evangelische Kirche in Deutschland, warnen die Bischöfe in ihrer Friedenschrift, dass ein kurzfristiger Friedensschluss mit Russland keinen langfristigen Frieden in Europa bedeutet, wenn es keine belastbaren Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine gibt. Vielleicht sollte man sich angesichts dieser Stellungnahmen der deutschen Bischöfe noch einmal an Papst Franziskus erinnern, der erklärte vor drei Jahren bei einem Besuch in Kasachstan, dass das Heilige nicht durch das Profane instrumentalisiert werden dürfe. Wer als Bischof der 2000-jährigen Weltkirche positiv über die Rüstungsanstrengung und Gewaltmittel spricht, die ein Staat gerade nun mal auf sich nehmen muss, tut hingegen genau das nicht. Also die katholischen Bischöfe sind da offenbar auch nicht besser als die evangelischen. Es ist interessant, dass dieser deutsche Sonderweg, der ja mit dem Protestantismus entsteht, dann ja auch so einen deutschen Sonderweg wirklich immer bei dieser sogenannten deutschen Bischofskonferenz, also den katholischen Bischöfen hervorruft, dass die eigentlich auch immer so ein eigenes Ding machen und mit dem Vatikan mitunter auch sogar über Kreuze dann liegen und Dinge komplett anders sehen und offenbar aber auch nicht richtig dann gemaßregelt werden dafür. Ja, er endet das Ganze damit, dass er sagt, dass die Bischöfe zwar das so an sich gut finden mit den mit nie wieder Krieg, aber folgendermaßen ist es aus Leos traditionellem und universalistischen nie wieder Krieg wird bei den deutschen Bischöfen ein weltlich pragmatisches lieber Krieg als ein Frieden ohne belastbare Sicherheitsgarantien. Der Geist der Berg predigt, liebt eure Feinde und bittet für die, die euch verfolgen, ist in diesem Dokument nicht mehr anwesend. Ersetzt wurde er durch eine Kriegsethik, die auch jeder Ungläubige anführen würde. Krieg sollte man demnach nicht führen, außer man hat gute Gründe. Um noch einmal die Berg predigt zu zitieren, tun nicht dasselbe auch die Haydn.
Ja, ich frage mich auch so ein bisschen, wozu hat man überhaupt so ein kirchliches Denkebeutel, wenn man am Ende doch wieder alles weltlich begründet? Ja. Also dann macht es ja gar keinen Sinn. Also das ist ja wirklich eine Sicherheitsstrategie. Nur das könnten dann halt auch die vereinigten Manager oder so schreiben, also nur so dann die Bischöfe. Und überhaupt diese ganze Idee von, klar, man soll es jetzt nicht übertreiben, mit der Menschheit und ja, das war auch ein Anlass für Kreuzzüge und so. Aber dass man noch mal ein globales Argument macht, statt in diesen Blöcken zu denken, wo einfach jenseits einer Grenze der Putin sitzt, das finde ich, verstehe ich auch nicht. Ja.
Und die gerade bei den Katholiken, das sind nun wirklich eine Weltkirche.
Ja, die verstehen sich doch als Weltkirche. Das ist wirklich komisch.
Müssen sie ja auch. Also sie können ja nicht in der Block-Konfrontation hineingehen.
Tja.
Zum Schluss noch Musik. Es gibt ein junges Streichquartett, das Aro-Quartett. Das hat bei dem Label Erato Streichquartette von Haydn eingespielt. Und zwar Opus 76. Das ist sehr berühmt, dieses Opus. Da ist auch das Kaiser-Quartett dabei. Und da gibt es Variationen, die du natürlich kennst. Da, da, di, da, da, da, di, da, da.
Oh, das kenne ich.
Ja, das ist dann in Variation. Gibt es vier Variationen. Also das Kaiser-Quartett, das muss man sich unbedingt anhören. Das ist vorzüglich gespielt. Aber auch die anderen sechs Streichquartette, die mit dieser Oppos-Zahl 76 belegt sind.
Also kann man das Hymne hören oder was?
Naja, das war ja ursprünglich eine Art Volkslied und wurde dann aufgegriffen auch von Haydn in dieser Komposition, in dem dritten der Oppos-76er-Quartette. Und daraufhin wurde das ja auch dann später zur Österreichischen Nationalhymne und dann deutsche Nationalhymne. In Österreich ist es ja nicht mehr, seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mehr, also seit Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs nicht mehr Nationalhymne. Hinzu gibt es aber auch das Sunrise-Quartett hier. Also die berühmten Haydn-Streichquartette, die wirklich fantastisch groß sind, die kann man hier hören. Dieses Quartett ist nicht so ungestüm in der Interpretation, wie das vielleicht das Quartor Ebene ist. Die haben auch wunderbar Haydn eingespielt, aber hier ist das etwas zurückgenommener. Hier geht es wirklich um, ich weiß, das ist ein Klischee, wenn man über Streichquartette spricht, aber es ist so. Es geht hier wirklich um das Gespräch vier kultivierter Menschen, die miteinander sprechen und keiner der vier ist dominant mit seinem Instrument. Auch das hat man ja bei Streichquartetten mitunter, dass vielleicht dann die erste Geige doch eigentlich das Ganze dominiert. Das findet man hier gar nicht. Diese langsamen Sätze sind so fabelhaft kontemplativ gespielt, wie man es eben nur kann. Das Besondere hier ist auch, dass sie überlegt haben, wie bringen wir überhaupt das zum Klingen und dann haben sie sich Kopien anfertigen lassen von Bögen aus dem Jahr 1770, damit sie diesen Klang nahe kommen, der auch wirklich so vielfältig ist. Denn wir haben da der Abitänze, wir haben da, wie schon erwähnt, das Kontemplative, wir haben unglaubliche Dynamiken drin. Es wird aber auch der Dudelsack imitiert, dass man wirklich fast den Eindruck hat, da klingt jetzt ein Dudelsack, aber es wird über Streicher hergestellt. Und dieses gemeinsame Spielen, diese Quartette, die so 1797, 1798 entstanden sind, ist herausragend, das kontrapunktische, klar hervortretend. Es ist eine große Freude, diesen Vieren zuzuhören. Ich hoffe, dass man sie auch bald mal irgendwo live erleben kann. Ich werde mir das mal im Internet ansehen. Jedenfalls meine dringende Empfehlung, eine 2-CD-Einspielung, beziehungsweise gibt es das natürlich auch alles über die Streaming-Dienste. Das Quartor Aro mit Haydn Opus 76. Toll.
Etwas, was wir zu Recht aus der Antike gerettet haben. Und mit Antike meine ich in dem Maße, wie wir heute über Geschichte sprachen, dass alles, was gestern war, schon verglühte, wie der berühmte Stern im Millisekundenbereich des Börsen-Schnellhandels. Sehr gut. Hören wir 200 Jahre alte Musik.
Wir lesen das nächste Mal das neue Buch von Patrick Kacmarczyk, der sich mit der neuen Weltordnung auseinandersetzt und der ja auch ein Experte ist für die Entwicklungsländer, für wirklich das auch, was man den globalen Süden nennt, der ja schon dieses Buch Kampf der Nationen geschrieben hat, das wir besprochen haben über den Irrsinn innerhalb Europas, wie da Handel und Wirtschaft geregelt sind jetzt. Aber blicken wir mit Patrick Kacmarczyk dann im Februar in die weite Welt hinaus.
Machen wir. Haut rein.